YEAH. THE. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT. DO THE
CONTINUE STAKEHOLDER WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THING HERE THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT CAPITOL BUILDING. SO
WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LOOK
NUMBER PEOPLE WHAT PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING AND SAID. WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRED MASS BORN IN THIS.
BE MAY. BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
TESTIFY. WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR IF IT'LL- SO. IF YOU'RE
NOT A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. WE'RE IF YOU DO OFFER
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY.
FOR THE PUBLIC IN A ROOM FOR
TWO OH TWO. THE COMEDY A
MINIMAL CONTENT THE STAFF THEY
LIMóN NUMBER OF PUBLIC IMAGE.
SO TO MAINTAIN SIX THE SPACING.
THEY'RE ALSO STREET FOOD THIS
SOMETHING PROTOCOL FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE. IN THE
ROOM. IF YOU. PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM ELECTORAL TESTIMONY PLEASE
RATE AND NOW ASK YOU THE PRO
THE MICRA. DURING PUBLIC. I
WOULD AS THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CONNECTS
THE HEARING ROOM DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. IN ADDITION TO BEING
ABLE TESTS ARE FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE ALSO HAVE SOME
WITNESSES MAKE. OF ONE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO. GAMES WHICH WERE
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. TESTIMONY
STATIONS LOOK CAP GROUND AND IN
A LOCATIONS THROUGH THE STATE.
THOSE WOULDN'T WILL HEAR ME TO
MEMBERS CAN WATER LIFE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. AND
ALL LAST QUESTION. USE TO WHICH
ANY WOULDN'T I TELL ME THE CALL
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN. SIX
MONTHS TO NINE SEVEN ALSO IN
ITSELF. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO TWO. TO
GIVE THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
WHAT. FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO.
ALSO FOR THIS TO ME BUT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE UNDER
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR A WELL AS ON
YOUR TO SCREEN. THE UP ALIGNS
WILL GIVE YOU QUESTIONS ON HOW
TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL THAT NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST IN YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUNDEST PORTION. AGAIN IT WAS
WITH LOTTERY PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT ONCE.
492-099-9163 NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE IN MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY AND HELP YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE'RE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TO. THIS
EMAIL. IT SHOULD SELL NUMBER
FOUR. AT EIGHT. DOT CA DOT GOV
BUT SUB THE NEW FOUR AT YES
THEY DOT CA DOT GOV. THANKS FOR
BEING WITH US AS WE MATH. TO
CONTINUE THIS THE OF. WILL ALSO
BE MINDFUL OF RESPECT FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. WE FACE. LOOK AT
THIS ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB FOR
INFORMATION OVERSIGHT. ON THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. OR MAYBE VISION
HEARING FOCUSED ON THE MASSIVE
PROBLEMS OCCURRING EIGHTY D.
AND THE PROPOSED NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL TRAIN STAFF TO
ADDRESS THE BACKLOG WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS. THIS WALL APPEARING
DIRECT RESULT OF THOUSANDS OF
CONCERNS RAISED IN MY DISTRICT
IN THIS SIX ACROSS THE STATE. I
BROUGHT THIS NEED TO FEEL HOW
OF CALL. DID YOU ONCE TO
CONTINUE TO FACE BARRIERS TO
RECEIVING THESE BENEFITS IN A
TIMELY FASHION NO SIMPLY.
UNACCEPTABLE THE FOCUS TODAY IS
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS. PROPOSED
SOLUTIONS AND PROVIDE IN
ADDITION RESOURCE. AS YOU KNOW
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION WILL
END AT THE END OF THE MONTH
THIS BUDGET HEARING IS EARLY SO
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO PUT A
PLAN FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND A
PLAN. THE PATH FORWARD. I WAS
PLEASED THE GOVERNOR'S NAPA
YESTERDAY THAT HE DEPLOYED A
STRIKE TEAM TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS AT E. D. D. THE
CURIOUS TIMING OF THE STRIKE
TEAM IN ELSE IS NOT LOST ON THE
LEGISLATURE. THE STRIKE TEAM
SHOULD BE IMPROPER. THIS CLAIMS.
AS WITH BENEFITS ALASKA THIS NO
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STRIKE TEAM
DURING THE QUESTION ANSWER
PORTION OF OUR HEARING. I
BELIEVE WE'VE BEEN CRITICAL OF
THE LEADERSHIP OF EDT I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T COMMIT A
THING THE RECORD FOLLOWING
PLEASE OF THE- WHO BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO PROCESS CLAIMS
DURING IS A PRESIDENTE. I
THEY'RE HARD. MISSION ST CAN.
DISCERN PEOPLE OF. IS ALL TOOK
OFFICE STAFF IT THIS OFFICE TO.
WHO FEEL THESE CALLS. PRETTY
MEMBERS HAVE AN OPENNESS TO. I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU LIMIT TO ONE
MAY. OF ADEQUATE TO FOR THE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS AND- ALSO
NOTE. WE WOMAN IS NOT HERE
TODAY SHE SAID BABY SO SHE'S AT
HOME WE'RE SHE SHOULD BE TAKEN
CARE FOR NEWBORN AND WOULD LOVE
TO BE HERE BUT THE FAMILY COMES
FIRST THEY CALL MEMBERS OPENING
COMMENTS MR. TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS DIFFICULT TO
SAY THIS AS SOMEONE WHO
GENERALLYBELIEVES IN
GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO HELP
BUT HE HAS BEEN IN CALIFORNIA
IN TWELVE YEARS AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL I HAVE NEVER BEEN THIS
OUT SPOKEN. PUBLICLY AFTER.
COMMERCE IS BETWEEN THE- AND
PRIVATE MEETINGS PUBLIC
HEARINGS EMAILS AND LETTERS MY
COLLEAGUES MY STAFF AND I ARE
AT WITS END. WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO
ALL THE MAN SOLUTIONS WE'VE NOT
SEEN THEM. BECAUSE OF THE
DUTIES FAILURES ARE
CONSTITUENTS ARE DEPLETING
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS GOING INTO
EXTREME DEBT HAVING TROUBLE
PAYING RENT AND PUTTING FOOD ON
THE TABLE. ET LOST MY FAITH
WANTED TOLD US THAT WE CAN ONLY
EXPEDITE ONE CASE A WEEK. EDT
ASKED TO PICK ONE PERSON EACH
WEEK SAVE. THIS IS WHY I
LAUNCHED. EATING ALL OF THE-
BOND SOCIAL MEDIA AND I WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR PROMPT AND NOW
PLEASE. THAT'S KIND OF LIKE
NEEDED EXPERT. THIS IS WHY I
LAUNCHED HASH TAG EDT FILL THE
ON SO MEDIA AND I CAL TO THE-
YESTERDAY. OUR GOVERNOR SEVERAL
IS THAT ARE LET'S JUST ABOUT
HOW FROM. AND WE WELCOME THAT
WE KNOW THERE SO MUCH MORE THAN
TO BE DONE TO SEE THIS CRIME.
LIKE THE CHAIR I KNOW THERE MAY
GOOD RANK IN FILES. YOUR WORK
HARD. BELIEF FOR. CAN SEE APPLE
LEVEL WE NEED A IT FOR YEARS
AND TO HELP NOW. LOOKING TO
TODAY'S. PETRIE-NORRIS EVERY
DAY MY. COLLEAGUES AND I HEAR
FROM THOU OF WHO ARE DESPERATE
IN DIRE STRAITS NOT SURE HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE BELT
MAKE THE RIGHT OR FEES CHILDREN
AND RIGHT NOW THIS DESPERATION
AS BEING A- TRUSTED. STATE TO.
FAILING TO ANSWER THE PHONE. HI
THE EMAIL ARE OFFERED EVEN THE
MOST BASIC HELP TO THE
DESPERATE CAL. THIS IS PART
WRENCHING IT IS MADDENING AND
IT IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
AFTER MONTHS THING IN OUR HEADS
AGAINST THE WALL I THINK IS
YOU'LL HEAR FROM MY COLLEAGUES
TODAY WE ARE FRUSTRATED AND WE
ARE DONE. CHEN AND TO BE CLEAR
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF US THIS IS
A BECAUSE OF US THIS IS BECAUSE
OF MARY THE PLOT FOR BENNETT.
AND SICKO RECEIVE IMMEDIATE
JENNIFER AND WEEKLY BUT STILL
HAS REACHED ANY PAYMENTS HIT
OUR- RETURN. POLICY THIS IS TO
MY BACK IS AND- JUNE. BUT HE
STILL HASN'T RECEIVED PAYMENT
AND HE HAS NEVER RECEIVE AN
EMAIL OR FOR HI TO HIS MANY
ATTEMPTS TO CONTACT DEPARTMENT
SO FOR THEM AND FOR THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS LIKE. WE'RE
DONE BEING. AND AT THIS HERE.
WE WILL MORE THAT PLANNED
EXCUSE AND BAKED. I INFER. WANT
TO LEAVE THIS ROOM WITH FIRM
ACTIONABLE COMMITMENTS MEANT ON
HOW ARE GOING TO RAPIDLY AND
RADICALLY UPGRADE YOUR
TECHNOLOGY AND UPGRADE YOUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE EXPERIENCE SO
THAT YOU CAN BEGIN TO PROPERLY
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER. MINISTER
DEALING. I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND ALSO POINT
OUT THE FACT THAT WHAT YOU HEAR
FROM US IS JUST NOT OUR FIRST
IS SUPPOSED. OF THE MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF QUE. THAT THAT
HAVE BEEN BANGING THEIR IT'S A
TO BUREAUCRATIC WALL JUST
TRYING TO GET THE MONEY TO PAY
THEIR RENT TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES KEEP THEIR SAYS A FOR.
FACT ALTHOUGH. WE'RE GONNA HAVE.
SOME REALLY TOUGH FOR BUT IN
THE HEARING TODAY THIS IS NOT
AN AD. RELATIONSHIP WE'RE ALL
THE SAME TO HERE REAL TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE WERE. U. D. KIND
OF ORGAN. EQUIPPED SEIZE LIKE
THIS. I KNOW THAT OF DOES NOT A-
ANYONE COULD REASONABLY FOR.
HOW A DROP EMPLOYMENT THAT
RESULT. A MASS INCREASE CAME TO
BE SOME THAT. PROBABLY IN
SOMETHING WHICH THE- ONE YOU
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PREPARED. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING.
JUST PROBLEM AND ON THE
CALIFORNIANS THE WE WERE ABOUT
THAT'S THAT THEY DESERVE. DALY
THANK YOU COOPER I'D LIKE TO Q.
WALKING COMING MAY TO JOIN THE
HERE TODAY WE'VE NAY BEEN MORE
AWARE OF THE VITAL THE
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PLACING
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE NOW
BECAUSE OF THE RECORD NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS. FOR THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THAT
THEY DESERVE. THOSE WHO WORK IN
THE DEPARTMENT AT EIGHTY D.
FROM INDISPENSABLE LIFELINE TO
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS AS HAS
BEEN STATED. I KNOW ALL THE
EMPLOYEES ARE STRUGGLING TO
FIND A WAY RIVER RESULTS. TWO
UNEMPLOYED CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE
HERE TODAY THOUGH TO CREATE
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY. THERE ARE
TOO MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
THERE TOO MANY. HALF HALF BAKED
TO NUMBERS PROVIDED TO THE
PUBLIC WE GET ONE SET OF
NUMBERS AS LEGISLATORS THE
MEDIA GETS ANOTHER SET OF
NUMBERS ARE GOING TO DETAIL IF
THE CHAIR OF. WILL ALLOW TIME
FOR THAT BUT THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE- THAT AND I'M GOING
TO INTRODUCE A BILL TODAY CHOIR
RING. WEEKLY REPORTS. BY THE
DEPARTMENT. AND YOU CAN SEND
COPIES OF THAT REPORT TO
WHOMEVER YOU LIKE. BUT
REQUIRING WEEKLY REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ALL THE KEY
METRIC IN THAT DOCUMENT. EVERY
WEEK HOW MANY APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN OUR OUTSTANDING I THINK
THE NUMBER WE HEARD EARLIER WAS
OVER A MILLION OUTSTANDING
APPLICATIONS AND I SEE IN THE
HEAD NODDING. IN AN OTHER KEY
FACTS WELL AND I INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN IN IN TERMS
OF WHAT ELSE SHOULD BE IN THAT
WEEKLY REPORT. I DON'T THINK
I'M REPORT. IS SUFFICIENT
BECAUSE- CRISIS AND IT'S
REASONABLE IN THE IN THE HIGH
TECH- ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
SHOULD BE IN. AND THAT MANY
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE
ESPECIALLY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND SEE SOME GOVERNMENTS ARE IN
BUT THE WEEKLY REPORT. IS A
SCORE MORE THAT WE CAN ALL. USE
AND ALL THE SUBMITTED THAT
LANGUAGE THE BUDGET STAFF TODAY
AND HOPEFULLY CAN VOTE ON IT
SOMETIME IN THE MONTH OF AUGUST.
AND I FIND IN MY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE AS A PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
LIKE REPORTS. ARE HELPFUL IN
TERMS OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PRODUCING RESULTS IN I'D LIKE
NOTHING MORE THAN THAT WEEKLY
REPORT TO SHOW PROGRESS WEEK TO
WEEK BY NOT GOAL OF THE THIRTY
D. D. GOAL AS WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. YES I WANT
EVERYONE TO KNOW THAT-
SPECIALLY FROM MY DISTRICT HOW
HARD THIS IS BEEN WE ARE NEXT
TO THE V. D. D. BECAUSE WE
HEARING FRESH. FROM THE PEOPLE
WHO THIS DYSFUNCTION IS
IMPACTING DAY TO DAY. MANY OF
THE PEOPLE MY DISTRICT HAD NO
INCOME NO INCOME. STATES MARCH.
THIS IS VERY REGRETTABLE I'M
EMBARRASSED I'M VERY VERY
EMBARRASSED AND I HOPE THAT
MEMBERS OF THE EIGHTY DEAR ALSO
IMPAIR NOT WILL TRIGGER ACTION.
BECAUSE LIKE TELL YOU.
GOVERNMENT NOW LOOKED MORE
BROKE. THEN I RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
OF INCOME WHEN THEY DO ENGAGE
IN THE PROCESS THEY GET SHUNNED
THAT'S WHAT THEY FEEL LIKE. AND
SO WE'RE TO REPAIR THAT
RELATIONSHIP BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO HELP BUT IT'S VERY VERY
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU ARE HOPE
DASHED SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE SOME OF THE
DIFFICULTIES HERE IN THIS
MEETING TODAY BECAUSE I CAN
TELL YOU IS VERY HURTFUL. THE
THIS IS THE AREA. THANK YOU
MISTER. I WAS NOT GO MAKE ANY
COMING IN BECAUSE I WANTED TO
SAVE MY TIME FOR THE QUESTIONS
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE COM.
COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE BUT- BE.
BEFORE WELL INTO THIS MEETING I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M THE ONLY ONE
WITH THE SIX. BUT YES. MISTER
TERRY TO UPON THE TO THE TO
THE PRESS FOR THAT. GOVERNOR IS
OFF HAD PUT OUT. I DON'T KNOW
IF EVERY ELSE PICKED UP ON THIS
QUICK MAY MAYBE I DIDN'T PICK
IT UP AS QUICKLY AS EVERYONE
ELSE. THE WORD. THE PRESS
RELEASE. WAS A LATE TO TWO
LETTERS. ONE MIGHT MISS HIM.
AND ONE BY. JULIE SU SECTOR SU.
AND I DIDN'T SEE THE AND THIS.
BEFORE COMING TO THIS HEARING
SO. IT I HATE IT S. S. ME OF A
CLOAK IN THE GAME. THAT WE
WOULD PLAY AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
IN TRYING TO SAY WELL I DID
THIS BUT IT'S TOO BAD YOU
DIDN'T SEE IT. AND SO
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE THERE'S
PEOPLE'S LIVES AT STAKE THAT
ARE BEING IMPACTED BY THIS
CLOAK AND DAGGER GAME OF MAKING
SURE THAT THE BLAME ISN'T
FALLING ON YOU. SO I HATE TO BE
THE- ABOUT WHETHER IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION OR AGENCIES I'VE
BEEN A STUDENT OF GOVERNMENT
AND- A AND- I'VE I'VE BEEN A
STEP FOR THIRTEEN YEARS BEFORE
FOURTEEN YEARS BEFORE RIGHT.
PUBLIC. OFFICE AND I'VE AND
PUBLIC OFFICE A YEAR. SO
THERE'S A CERTAIN OF URGENCY
YOU SEE PEOPLE HAVE AN- BEING
IN DESPERATE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
TO SEE. THAT WE'RE PLAYING
THESE KINDS OF GAMES OF HIDING
NUMBERS IT'S THAT WITHOUT USING
ANY EXPLETIVES I CAN'T I DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY OF A
VOCABULARY TO DESCRIBE THE
FRUSTRATION THAT I FEEL ON
BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS. AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU THEN FIND
THAT TWO DOCUMENTS ONE ABOUT
THREE PAGES ONE EIGHT PAGES
WERE HIDING AT THE LAST WORD OF
A HYPERLINK OF A STATEMENT. SO
WITH THAT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
HEARING. THANK YOU I THINK YOU
HEAR SOME OF THE FRUSTRATION OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THEIR
COMMENTS. AND TO BE ON THE END
OF THESE PHONE CALLS OR
SOMEONE'S CALLING YOU UP. THERE
AT MONEY THEY HAVE NO MONEY
NUMBER FIVE MONTHS INTO THIS
THEY CAN'T PAY THEIR RENT OR
MORTGAGE. YOU CAN BUY FOOD. THE
CAMPAIGN UTILITY BILL. THERE'S
CELL PHONE PAYMENT AND HAVE
KIDS. AND IF THEY HAVE NOWHERE
ELSE TO TURN. AND I MEAN IT'S
TRAGIC SOME QUESTIONABLE WHAT
IS HAPPENING THESE PEOPLE AND
NOW WE HEAR THAT WOULD STILL
TWO MONTHS BEHIND SO RUSSIAN BE
SEVEN MONTHS INTO THIS BEFORE
WE- GET. ALL THESE ISSUES
ADDRESSED. THAT'S TRAGIC WE
CAN'T GAMBLE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
BECAUSE WE CAN'T GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER. AND THAT'S THAT THE
RESTORATION PEOPLE FEEL AND YOU
KNOW WE GET THESE CALLS AND
ARTISTIC OFFICE DAY IN AND DAY
OUT EVERYONE UP HERE. A NUMBER
OF CALLS. AND IT'S- TO HEAR
THESE CALLS AND HEAR THE PAIN
THEIR VOICE- THAT'S WHY HE'S
MEMBERS ARE PROVIDING SO.
THERE'S BEEN NOTIFIED STAFF- WE
LOST THE LA L. IN THE- BECAUSE
OF A GLITCH A COMMUNICATIONS
LIST SO- WE'RE ON HOLD RIGHT
NOW WE'RE IN STAND BY- THAT'S
APARTMENT TECHNOLOGY SO. I'M IT
SPEECH. THIS. KRISTIN THE IDEA
PART COMMITTED ROLE PLEASE.
MISTER COOPER HERE TO HEAR
SELECT THE ERROR IN THIS AREA.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CHAD ALAMO AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THE COMMITTEE ASKED OUR OFFICE
TO PRESENT AND PREPARE A HAND
OUT PROVIDING A BRIEF OVERVIEW.
OF THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
PERMANENCE RESPONSE TO THAT THE
CODE NINETEEN A FAX IN THE
STATE'S LABOR MARKET- THAT HAND
OUT SHOULD BE OUT WITH YOU AND
HOPEFULLY ALSO THERE TO FOLLOW
ALONG DURING MY TESTIMONY. OF
THANKS DESCRIBE THE AFFECTS ON
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN THE
INTRODUCTION TODAY HOW WE
WANTED TO PROVIDE A BIT OF
CONTACTS TO SOME OF THOSE
NUMBERS ARE ON THE FIRST PAGE
OF OUR HAND OUT. I'M WE NOTE
THAT AS A RESULT OF CODE IN
NINETEEN THE STATE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE- AND THOSE
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
HAS REACHED ON PRESENT LEVELS.
ON UNDER NORMAL ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS SO STAY ABOUT A YOU
GO. ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS FILE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- SENSE
THAT THE MIDDLE OF MARCH WHEN
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BEGAN AFFECTING THE LABOR
MARKETS ON AVERAGE MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAVE FILED FOR
BENEFITS- UNDER THE FIGURE THAT
WE IN OUR HAND OUT HERE ON THE
BOTTOM OF THIS PAGE. IT WAS
MAKES THEM TO HAVE THAT. OUR AS
YOU CAN. DURING THE RECESSION
THE WEEKLY. APPOINTMENT CLAIMS
HIGH THAT THE STATE THE SORT OF
PRE COVERT NINETEEN PETE WAS
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND CLAIMS PER WEEK ON IN
ONE WEEK DURING THE LATE MARCH
EDT PROCESS MORE THAN ONE
MILLION CLAMS. AND THEN FOUR
FOUR WEEKS SINCE THAT TIME EDS
BEEN PROCESSING AN AVERAGE OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CLAIMS PER
WEEK. ON WE HOPE THAT THIS
FIGURE ILLUSTRATES THE
UNPRECEDENTED NATURE OF THE
LABOR MARKET A FAX AND EIGHTIES
WORKLOAD. ON THE SECOND PAGE OF
OUR HAND OUT. WE ALSO DESCRIBE
ANOTHER MEASURE THAT WE LOOK
AT- WHEN THINKING ABOUT
EIGHTIES WORKLOAD AND IT'S THE
LABOR MARKET IN GENERAL AND
THIS ISN'T SIMPLY- NUMBER OF
NEW UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS EACH
WEEK BUT RATHER THE NUMBER OF
TOTAL WORKERS RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
IN THE STATE. HAS A TIME MORE
ONE. IN FIVE WORKERS IN THE
STATE IS RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS I'M THAT'S
APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION WORKERS NOW- OUR HAND
OUT REFERS TO FIGURES FROM LAST
WEEK BUT I AM I. UPDATING THEM
DURING THE TESTIMONY OF DDT IS
JUST RECENTLY PUBLISHED IN WEEK
THERE'S JUST EARLIER AFTERNOON.
OF THE FOUR POINT IVE.
CURRENTLY RECEIVING BENEFITS UP
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION SO THE
MAJORITY ARE TRADITIONAL
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE RECEIVING
BENEFITS ON THE STATE'S
TRADITIONAL PROGRAM- I'M ON TOP
OF THAT THOUGH. MILLION SELF
EMPLOYED TOOLS ARE ALSO
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS UNDER A NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT ALL I'LL
TOUCH ON IN A MOMENT. ALTHOUGH
SO THE NUMBER OF TRADITIONAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT RECIPIENTS
SO YOUR TRADITIONAL EMPLOYEES
HAS STAYED CONSTANT ABOUT THREE
POINT THREE OR THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION RECIPIENTS. SAME TIME
PERIOD THE NUMBER OF SELF
EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING
YOU AYE BENEFITS HAVE HAS
INCREASED BY ABOUT 50% AND
THAT'S ILLUSTRATED HERE IN THIS
FIGURE AT THE BOTTOM OF TWO.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU SEE IT BIGGER
THAT SELF AND YOU I RECEIPT
CONTINUES TO INCREASE BUT IT
ALSO GIVES A SENSE OF SCALE
RELATIVE TO WHAT THE STATE
EXPERT IT'S DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WHICH IS ILLUSTRATED
BY THE- THE LOWER IT GRAY LAW.
NO HOPE TO IMPART FIGURE IS NOT
ONLY OBVIOUSLY THAT THE MAN
DIFFERENCES BUT HOW QUICKLY THE
STATE HAS GONE FROM WHAT IS A
NORMAL WORKLOAD AT EIGHTY THAN
NORMAL LABOR MARKET FOR
ECONOMIC EXPANSION SCHOOL
CRISIS. I'M IN JUST A MATTER
WEEKS AS OPPOSED TO DURING THE
SESSION WITH THE TIME FELT LIKE
A RAPIDLY CHANGING ENVIRONMENT-
THERE WAS MORE THAN AYE AYE AYE
YEAR SORT OF RUN LEAD TIME. FOR
THAT A PART TO BE AGING
INCREASED WORK LOAD THAT THAT
IT OBVIOUSLY HASN'T HAD THAT
OPERA. THIS SUMMER. ONE ON PAGE
THREE OF THE HAND OUT OF
BRIEFLY. A FEW KEY FEDERAL
PROVISIONSRELATED UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IS A BEEN WIDELY
NOTED IN THE IN THE NEWS MEDIA
US ALL BE BRIEF. OFTEN THAT THE
FEDERAL CARE INC. A SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR WEEKLY AD ON TO YOU I
BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO ALL
WORKERS AND ONE HUNDRED AND FED.
FUNDED THAT WOULD AVAILABLE FOR
SIXTEEN WEEKS AND ENDED UP IN
THE LAST WEEK I JUNE
NEGOTIATION FOR A FULL TUITION
OR CONTINUE. CURRENTLY I'M
GOING IN THE US CONGRESS.
FEDERAL CARE AT. SO EXPANDED L.
FOR. SURE TOO SO EMPLOYED
WORKERS- I MENTION THIS POINT
EARLIER THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT ONE MILLION SELF
EMPLOYED WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
NOW RECEIVING YOUR BENEFITS
UNDER THE NEW. FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM. I'M AND FINALLY THE
CARES ACT UP. A THIRTEEN WEEK
EXTENSION TO STE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS- INCOMES.
THE WEAKEST ALLOW. THE WALL.
CURRENTLY THE DURATION OF YOU I
BENEFIT ELEGY. WILL INCREASE
FROM TWENTY SIX PER WEEKS-
WHICH IS UNDER NORMAL STATE
LAW- TO A TOTAL OF A MAXIMUM OF
A. FOR SIX WEEKS FEDERAL. ON ON
PAGEFOUR THE HAND RETURN TO
STATE ACTION. ON THE FIRST NOTE
THAT WE WOULD MAKE. A MILLION
DOLLARS AND SEE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING- AS PART OF THE. AND
EARLIER FEDERAL RELIEF PACKAGE
AND THAT FOOT THOSE FUNDS HAVE
JUST AND IN TWO. SEPARATE
COMPONENTS TO THE STATE IN
RECENT MONTHS AND HAVE BEEN
USED TO ADDRESSED THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD AS WELL THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS RE DIRECTED-
FOURTEEN HUNDRED STAFF MEMBERS
FROM OTHER BRANCHES WITH EDT TO
THE Y. BRANCH AT. OTHER AGENTS
IS TO THE RIGHT. HELLO THE MORE
WE DEVELOPMENT IN THE STAFFING
ARENA RELATES TO ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING UNDER AN
EXISTING- FINANCING SYSTEM- THE
SORT OF UNDERLIES THE STATE
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP FOR YOU WHY
I IN ESSENCE FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR BASED STATE ADMIN COSTS
REALLY PROGRAM I WITH THESE
IT'D WORK HELLO ON FIRST STATE
IS IN THE PROCESS OF HIGH.
PRODUCT I THOUGHT I DID STOP
NOT. I'M FIVE WE TURN THE
TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AT DVDS
WERE. WHAT FIRST POINT OUT THAT
SINCE MID MARCH EDIE HAS
PROCESSED AND DISTRIBUTED MORE
THAN FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS AND
BENEFIT PAYMENTS TO UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WITH THE DEFENSE AUGMENTATIONS
SHE WHY THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THIS FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IS A
FEDERALLY SOURCED FUNDS
ALTHOUGH- THAN TEN BILL DOLLARS
OF THAT AMOUNT- CORRESPONDS TO.
TICKLE OR NORMAL UNEMPLOYMENT.
RATES OF THAT THE STATE'S
PROGRAM THAT ARE. FUNDED BY AN
EMPLOYER PAYROLL TAX AND PAID
FOR OUT OF THE STATE YOU I
TRUST FOR. SIX FINAL THE HAND
WE LOOK CLOSELY AT CROSS WORK
AND SPECIFICALLY AT TIMELINESS
OF PAYMENT OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
SUBJECT. OF TODAY'S HEARING AND
DESPITE THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES BOTH FROM THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND THE STATE LEVEL
PROVIDE DDD IN RECENT MONTHS
THERE CLEARLY WERE. STE
CONCERN. THAT EIGHTY IS. MAY
NOT HAVE A CAPACITY AT THIS
TIME TO. ISSUE YOU AYE BENEFITS
IN A PROMPT FASHION- BUT FOUR
POINT OUT THAT THEIR CURRENT.
CLAIMS PROCESSING WORKLOAD IS
AT AN ALL TIME HISTORIC HI- IN
APRIL MAY AND JUNE SO THE
SECOND QUARTER OF THIS YEAR.
BURKE EDT PROCESS ON OUR
BETWEEN POINT MILLION AND TWO
POINT MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIM FOR MONTH THIS IS THREE
TIMES HIGHER THAN THE HIGHEST
MONTHLY PEAK DURING THE GREAT
RISK TURN. AT ABOUT TWENTY
TIMES HIGHER THAN A NORMAL
MONTHS WORKLOAD FOR EDT. AND I
THINK THE POINT IN THE NEXT
WEEK WE HOPE TO CLARIFY IS THAT.
MOST CLAIMS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THAT ARE SUBMITTED TO
THE EDT ARE PROCESSED IN AN
AUTOMATED FASHION- BUT APART
AND REFERS THESE CLAIMS IS
CLEAN CLAIMS AND BY THIS I MEAN
THAT THAT THE STATE USES
AUTOMATED STAFFS SAYS NAMES
STEP WILL TAKE THE DEMOGRAPHIC
AND EMPLOYMENT INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY THE UNEMPLOYED
WORKER AND NOT. THOSE TO OTHER
STATE DATABASES TO CONFIRM THE
IDENTITY OF THE CLAIMANT BUT
ALSO TO CONFIRM THEIR WAGES AND
ONCE THOSE PIECES OF
INFORMATION ARE CONFIRMED THE
EDT. ELIGIBILITY AND WHAT THE
WEEKLY BENEFIT AMOUNT WHICH
WOULD BE AND THEN ISSUES THAT
BENEFIT BUT IN IN A IN A
MINORITY OF CASES. EITHER THE
DEMOCRATS MISSION OR THE IMP A
SALARY OR WAGE INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY THE UNEMPLOYED
WORKER DON'T MATCH STATE
DATABASES AND IN THESE CASES.
EDT HAS THEM MANUALLY USING
CONSIDERABLE STAFF TIME-
REDIRECT- SORT OF RE OPENED THE
CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION WITH
THE CLAIMANT TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTATION TO.
VERIFY THEIR THEIR EMPLOYMENT
HISTORY OR PERHAPS CORRECT- AN
INCORRECT SO SECURITY NUMBER IT
WAS WRITTEN ON APPLICATION
THESE ARE THE CLAIM THAT TAKE A
LENGTHY PERIOD IN OFFICE OFTEN
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT. ACE.
AND I MAY I. BECAUSE THE PRO IS
A FEDERAL PARTNERS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ESTABLISHED SOME
PERFORMANCE TARGETS FOR STATES
AND ONE OF THE KEY PERFORMANCE
TARGETS THAT THEY'VE ESTABLISH
IS WHAT THEY CALL FIRST BENEFIT
TIMELINESS- AND THIS IS
BASICALLY THAT THE NUMBER OF
DAYS BETWEEN NINE AND AN
APPLICATION IS. WHAT AND WENT
OUT THE PAYMENT BUT ON WORK
RECEIVE HIS OR HER FOR BENEFIT%
UNDER THE FEDERAL SETS OF THE
TARGET. THAT EIGHTY SEVEN PER
OF CLAY. ARE ART WITHIN TWENTY
ONE DAYS AND HIS. FORMAL CIRCUM
THE STATE. IS ABLE TO PAY ABOUT
80% OF CLAIMS WITH TWENTY ONE
DAYS. IN THE SECOND THIS YEAR
SO I MADE THIS INCREASED
WORKLOAD THE STATE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO ISSUE. FIFTY TWO.
WITHIN TWO ONE DAYS IS A SLIGHT
SO THAT US I OF 69% OTHER
STATES AS WELL ARE STRUGGLING
WITH THIS NEW WORKLOAD- AND ONE
THING I WOULD POINT OUT IS THAT
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION WHEN
EIGHTY ALL HAD CHALLENGES WITH
ISSUING BENEFITS PROMPTLY ON.
AT THAT TIME THAT THE
DEPARTMENT A TO ISSUE A OFFERS
BENEFITS PAYMENTS AND IN TWENTY
ONE DAYS ALSO IN ABOUT 62% OF
CASES- SOURCING SOME SIMILAR
BETWEEN TODAY'S WORK
RESPONSIVENESS AND THAT DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION DESPITE.
BEING MUCH HIGHER FOR THE
APARTMENT NOW IT WAS AT THAT
TIME- THANK YOU TAKE QUESTIONS
NOW AND STATE PANEL FOR ANY OR
ALL OF. HELLO BOOKS. A RICH AND
WE HEAR FROM ALL OKAY. AND I
WILL UP TO FOR. THE QUESTION I
LESS EACH MEMBER. TO BE MINDFUL
OF OTHER MEMBERS WHO WERE
WAITING TO ASK QUESTIONS. IN
ORDER TO ASSURE EVERY MEMBER
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS. I WANT TO HAVE A
PROVIDING FIVE MINISTRIES
MEMBER TO ASK A QUESTION IF
TIME PERMITS WE THEN MOVE ON A
SECOND ROUND OF QUESTIONS
POSSIBLY A THIRD. REMINDED WE
ALSO EXPECT FOR OTHER DURING
THE PUBLIC BECAUSE- WE DO HAVE
A NEW NUMBER. TO CALL IT A
BECAUSE OF DELICIOUS SO THEIR
NUMBER TO CALL IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. A NINE.
SEVEN ONCE AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS THREE SIX ONE. SEVEN THREE
OO TO THAT'S. THREE SIX ONE
SEVEN THREE OH TWO FOR THE
ACCESS CODE. MOVE OUT OF THE
PHONE TO HEAR FROM DIRECTOR OF
EIGHTY D. SHARON HILLIARD. IN
THE NEW NUMBERS ON THE SCREEN
ALSO SO. NO HE- YES I AM BEING
TOLD THAT THEY'RE NOT NOT THAT
THAT'S BEEN DROPPED AGAIN WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO FIGURE THAT OUT
RIGHT NOW SO I SORT. OKAY ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE L. L. BUT I
ACTUALLY. THE FOR THE TELL.
WITH REALLY L. L. HERE. WE
START WITH IS PUBLIC COMMENT
CHRISTIAN. OKAY THERE ARE THERE
ARE NOW SO GREAT OKAY MISS
HILLIARD ARE YOU THERE. AND
THIS IS EIGHTEEN ANTI WE ARE RE
CONNECTED WITH YOU PEOPLE ARE
STARTING TO DIAL BACK AND FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. NO WE DON'T
HAVE EIGHTY BACK YET. MISTER
COOPER YOU NEED TO A QUESTION
FOR ME TO DECIDE THAT THE
OPERATOR KNOWS TO PUT HER
THROUGH THE OPERATOR CAN YOU
CLICK MISS HILLIARD SHOWN
CHEERING HILLIARD FROM EDT
PLEASE. EIGHTY ANTI OPERATOR.
THE SHERIN HELL AIRED GOOD
AFTERNOON IS STILL YOUR HOW ARE
YOU. VERY GOOD ARE YOU READY TO
PROVIDE UP TO ME TO WRITE
OPENING COMMENTS PLEASE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN COOPER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M SURE AND HIGHER
DIRECTOR OF EMPLOYMENT AT ALL
DEPARTMENT. I WANT TO START OUT
BY THANKING YOU FOR
ACCOMMODATING MY APPEARANCE
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY BY
TELEPHONE I HAVE SOME FAMILY
MEMBERS OR IN A HIGH RISK GROUP
AND RELATE TO COPE IN NINETEEN
AND I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THAT.
FACT I'M HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
YOU INFORMATION. TO DO HER
SPONSORED STARK I'M PLAN
INSURANCE CLAIM VOLUMES
EXPERIENCES RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. INCLUDING AN UPDATE
ON CURRENT AND FUTURE CALL
CENTER OPERATIONS. AN UPDATE ON
CLAIM PROCESSING. PLANT BUT AN
FOR HIRING AND FUTURE STAFFING
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. BACK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND APPROVED
COMMUNICATIONS WITH CUSTOMERS
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. WITH ME TODAY IS
MY CELL PHONE RANG SHE IS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BRANCH AND AFTER I
CONCLUDE MY OPENING REMARKS
SEAN I WILL BE GLAD TO HAVE THE
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ALL OF
YOUR- QUESTIONS. THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CHANGE THE
WORLD AS WE KNOW IT AND THE EDT
WITH NO EXCEPTION. WELL IT'S
EASY PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO
ASSIST WORKERS DURING AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN THE IMMENSE
WIDESPREAD IMPACT OF KOBE
NINETEEN CREATE A SUDDEN AN
UNPRECEDENTED DEMAND FOR
BENEFITS. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
EXPERIENCE HISTORICALLY LONG
ECONOMIC EXPANSION AS- RECENTLY
AS FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY. AN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE REMAINED AT
HISTORIC LOW THREE POINT 9%
DURING THE WORST OF THREE GREAT
RECEPTION IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
THE DEPARTMENT PAID OUT TWENTY
TWO POINT NINE BILLION BENEFITS
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR WHILE
PROCESSING THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION CLAIMS. SINCE MARCH
EIGHT EDT HAVE PAID FIFTY FIVE
BILLION AND BENEFIT FROM
PROCESS NINE POINT THREE
MILLION CLAIMS AND LESS THAN
FIVE MONTHS. DURING TIME EIGHTY
ALSO NEW FEDERAL PANDEMIC
RELATED PROGRAMS INTO AN
ANTIQUATED YOU AYE SYSTEM
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL PANDEMIC
EMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION.
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE AND PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION. AN EFFORT TO
QUICKLY BOLSTER OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY AT THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC THE EASY PARTNERED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY THE OPPOSITE DIGITAL
INNOVATION AND A VARIETY OF
VENDORS TO ENHANCE OUR CAPACITY.
INJURED DAN ABILITY AND EXPLORE
NEW SOLUTIONS TO MEET THE MAN.
EVEN THE LAN TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTER ON APRIL
TWENTIETH TWO MORE THAT PROVIDE
MORE GENERAL CALL INQUIRED
THEIR REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE
OPEN FROM EIGHT TO EIGHT SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH. ADDING STAFF AGREE ON
THE TYPE OF QUESTIONS FRIDA
FEEDING THESE EXPERIENCE CLAIM
FILING STAFF ANSWER MORE
COMPLEX CLAIM SPECIFIC
QUESTION. ET CONTINUES TO
ANSWER SKILLED OF THE PHONE
AGENTS ARE PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SYSTEM ACCESS TO RESPOND THE
MAJORITY OF QUESTIONS.
INCLUDING A CLAIM AND PAYMENT
STATUS WHICH WAS APPROVED BY
THE MOST COMMON QUESTION WE
RECEIVE. WELL THE NEW TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO ANSWER MORE JOE CHOIR
YOU. WE REALIZE THAT THE
CURRENT HEALTHCARE OPERATIONS
ARE NOT CURRENTLY SERVING ALL
THAT. OUR CUSTOMER IN A TIMELY
MANNER. IN ORDER TO IMPROVE.
THE DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAVE A
PROJECT UNDER WAY TO MERGE THE
TWO DIFFERENT CALL CENTERS INTO
A SINGLE VIRTUAL PLATFORM. AS
WELL AS IMPROVE OUR IT OUR
MESSAGING TO PROVIDE A MORE
SEAMLESS EXPERIENCE FOR
CUSTOMER. FUTURE ROLLOUT TO
THIS PROJECT ALSO INCLUDE SKILL
BASED ROUTING WHICH IS SET TO
BE ROLLED OUT MID OCTOBER. SO
COLLARED LIZARD YOU ARE GOING
TO GET A CALL CENTER
REPRESENTATIVE WHO IS
SPECIALIZED TRAINING WITH THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE. A TOOL THAT
THE- IS PROPER IMPLEMENTING IS
THE KNOWLEDGE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY TO YOUR PROGRAM THE
TRAINING STAFF TO TAKE MONTHS
IN ORDER TO FAMILIARIZE THEM
WITH ALL THE RULES REGULATIONS
AND GUIDANCE INVOLVED IN YOUR
CLAIM PROCESSING. THIS
KNOWLEDGE MANAGEMENT TOOL
COLLECTS ALL THE TRAINING
MATERIALS YOUR PROGRAM NOTICES
INTERNAL STAFF. INTO A SINGLE
SEARCHABLE ONLINE TOOL SO NEW
STAFF CAN MORE EASILY LOCATE
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
AND ADDRESS A CLAIM A CLAIMANT
ISSUES. WE BEGAN ROLLING OUT IN
JULY WILL CONTINUE TO ENHANCE
THE OVER THE COMING WEEKS. IN
ADDITION TO ACTIONS TAKEN TO
IMPROVE OUR CALL CENTER
OPERATION THE DEPARTMENT HAS
ALSO FOCUSED A GREAT AMOUNT OF
TIME AND EFFORT ON IMPROVING
OUR CLAIM PROCESSING ABILITIES.
THE EASY STREAMLINED YOU AYE
SYSTEM OPERATIONS FOR IMPROVED
EFFICIENCY HIGHLY OR PROCESSING
A PAYMENT OF BENEFITS AND
OVERALL IMPROVE SERVICE TO
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS. WORKING
WITH THE LABOR AGENCY EIGHTY
THE OBJECT TO CERTAIN
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR THE UNIQUE
SITUATION FOR THE PANDEMIC. AND
ACTED LIKE CLAIMS PROCESSING
FOR INSTANCE WE EXERCISE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE USUAL- THE
BILL REQUIREMENTS TO LOOK FOR
WORK AND TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
WORK AND BEGAN IMMEDIATELY
PAYING PEOPLE INCOMING CLAIMS
FOR YOU I BENEFITS ONCE
IDENTIFIED AD WAITED HAVE BEEN
VERIFIED. AND PRIOR TO MAKING
FILE THE TERMINATION THE
BUILDING. WE ALSO UPDATED OUR
AUTOMATED SYSTEMS ACCORDINGLY
SO MANY MORE CLAIM COULD BE OUR
PROCESS WITH. STAFF
INTERVENTION RESULTING IN
BENEFITS BEING PAID MORE
QUICKLY. AND IT IS EVEN HANNAH
THE DEPARTMENT BECAME AWARE OF
IN THE NATION WIDE FRAUD SCHEME
BEING PERPETRATED AGAINST STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM.
FORTUNATELY THE EIGHTY THE
CORRECT FRAUD PREVENTION
MEASURES IN PLACE TO MITIGATE
OF CRIMINAL ACTION. CLAIMS THAT
MEET CERTAIN CHARACTERISTICS
ARE PUT THROUGH THAT AGAIN HE
VERIFICATION PROCESS IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE PREVENT FRAUDULENT
BENEFIT FROM BEING PAID THE
THIRD TO PROTECT POTENTIAL
VICTIM WELL THIS PROCESS DOES
REQUIRE STAFF INTERVENTION AND
MORE ACTION ON THE PART OF
PAYMENT THESE. ARE PROTECT THE
PROGRAM INTEGRITY AND PREVENTED
BY RELENT PAYMENT. FROM MARCH
TO JULY EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY EDT HAVE CROSS OF THE
TOTAL EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION
CLAIMS BETWEEN REGULAR YOU AYE
EXTENSIONS. REOPEN CLAIMS AND
THE POOR PROGRAM. OVER THE SAME
TIMEFRAME EIGHTY IS PAID OUT
BUT FORTY NINE. FIFTY MILLION
BENEFIT WELL THE DEPARTMENT OF
BEEN ABLE TO PAY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CLAIMS HAVE BEEN
APPLIED DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
WORST YEAH THAT REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION. SOME
COMMON REASONS INCLUDE IDENTITY
VERIFICATION. WAITED ABOUT THE
CASE AND EVERY COMPUTATIONS. I
THE SIX MILLION UNIQUE
CLAIMANTS WHO. FOR BET MARK
880% OR FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE HAVE RECEIVED
PAYMENT. OF THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
RECEIVED PAYMENT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF EITHER NEVER
CERTIFY FOR BENEFITS OR NOT
PROVIDED THAT THE FERRY WAGE
INFORMATION FOR THE CLAIM. THE
FATHER HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE
CURRENTLY AN ELIGIBLE BASED ON
INFORMATION SUPPLIED DURING A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. THE
REMAINING TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND CLAIMANTS ARE
AWAITING RESOLUTION ON THE PART
OF THE EIGHTY D. WHICH
REPRESENTS 4% OF THE OVERALL
PLAN AND- THIS GROUP REPRESENTS
BOTH AND ID VERIFICATION
PROCESS WHO SUBMITTED THEIR
NECESSARY DOCUMENTS AND THOUGH
THE WEIGHT INVESTIGATION PROP
OF. SUPPLY WAGE INFORMATION.
BOTH GROUPS REQUIRE A WAITER
COMPUTATION FALLING
CONFIRMATION OF THEIR IDENTITY
OR EMPLOYMENT STATUS. WHICH IS
MANUALLY INTENSIVE AND
COMPLICATED PROCESS IT IS THOSE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND CLAIM AT THE 4% THAT
WE ARE WORKING TO RESOLUTION
AND COMPUTER PRIOR TIDIED
CLAIM. BASED ON ONE APPLICANT
ORIGINALLY APPLIED RATHER THAN
WHEN WE RECEIVE RELEVANT WORK
ITEMS FROM THE ITEM FROM THEM
TO PROCESS. WE ANTICIPATE
COMPLETING THE CURRENT ACTUAL
ITEM THROUGH JUNE BY THE END OF
NUMBER. BUT THE RIGIDITY
CURRENT AND FROM TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SEEING THEM
OUT OF CLAIMS THAT REQUIRE
MANUAL INTERVENTION APART EASY
I RECOGNIZE IMMEDIATELY THAT
MANY THOUSANDS MORE ADDITIONAL
STAFF WOULD BE NEEDED. FOR BOTH
CLAIM PROCESSING BUT AND CALLED
OUR OPERATIONS. IN ORDER TO
MEET THE SURGE IN DEMAND. PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC IMMEDIATE CLAIM
SUPPORT CENTER I HAD THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY STAFF ANSWERING
CALLS FROM EIGHT TO TWELVE
MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY. AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
DEPARTMENT TOOK QUICK ACTION TO
BRING VENDOR CALL CENTER STAFF
ON BOARD TO ASSIST WITH THE
IMMEDIATE SURGE. BUT MORE LONG
TERM DVD STAFFING WAS GOING TO
BE NEEDED TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CUSTOMERS. BECAUSE STATE HIRING
PROP CAN BE QUITE LENGTHY I
IMMEDIATELY BEGAN WORKING WITH
CALLIE HER IN ORDER TO EXPECT
THANKS BYE EXPEDITE THE
PROCESSING. THE HIRING PROCESS
TO BRING IN NEW STAFF TO
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. EDT AND A
HIGHER FIFTY THREE HUNDRED NEW
STAFF WHO BOTH. EVERY LEVEL OF
SERVICE FROM ANSWERING SIMPLE
QUESTIONS AT THE CALL CENTER TO
FILING CLAIMS INCLUDING THE
MORE DETAILED WAY THREE
COMPETITION AND IDENTITY
VERIFICATION PROCESS. SO FAR SO
FAR FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN APPROVED FOR HIGHER AND
ARE IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
ONBOARDING TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT. WE PLAN TO HAVE
TWO THOUSAND THE STAFF
DEDICATED DVDS CALL CENTER
OPERATIONS AND THE REMAINING
THREE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
STAFF FOCUS ON CLAIMS FILING
BRING THAT TO A TOTAL OF. FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
CLING FILERS. THIS INCREASED
STAFFING WILL HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT ON OUR
ABILITY TO SERVE THOSE
CUSTOMERS WHO CLAIMS REQUIRE
MORE MANUAL INTERVENTION WHAT
ADDITIONAL STAFF WILL HELP IN
THE NEAR TERM A LONGER TERM
SOLUTION IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE RIGIDITYOF EIGHTEEN
CURRENT IT INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
IMMEDIATE BENEFIT SYSTEM USED
TO ADMINISTER THE UNEMPLOYMENT
AND STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
PROGRAM STILL RELY ON OLD
OBSOLETE TECHNOLOGY. INCLUDING
HOPE ALL WHICH IS A THIRTY YEAR
OLD PROGRAMMING LANGUAGE THAT
IS BECOMING INCREASINGLY AT
RISK OF HAVING PERFORMANCE
ISSUES DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN
AND NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
MODERNIZE. WHAT LEGISLATIVE
WITH LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT EDT
INITIATED THE BENEFIT SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION PROJECT SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WITH THE GOAL OF
REPLACING ALL OF EXISTING
DESPAIRED SYSTEMS AND
APPLICATIONS YOU SHOULD
MINISTER THE UNEMPLOYMENT
STATUS BILLING INSURANCE
PROGRAM INCLUDING PAID FAMILY
LEAVE. THE PROJECT WILL CREATE
A SINGLE AN INTEGRATED BENEFIT
SYSTEM OUT PROVIDE CUSTOMERS A
SINGLE PORTAL MAKING ACCESS
EVEN EASIERTO ALL THREE
BENEFIT PROGRAM. THE BENEFITS
OF MODERNIZATION PROJECT WAS
INITIATED WITH THE GOAL TO BE
OPERATIONAL BY THE MAX ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN BUT UNFORTUNATELY
DEBATE PANDEMIC OCCURRED BEFORE
THAT COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED. THE
EIGHTY DAY WILL BE AWARDING A
CONTRACT TO THE WINNING BIDDER
IN OCTOBER WITH THE NECESSARY
WORK BEING THERE AFTER IN ORDER
FOR THE SYSTEM TO BECOME
OPERATIONAL. ADDITIONAL
TECHNOLOGY UPGRADES TO BE
RELEASED IN THE COMING MONTHS
THAT WILL IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY INCLUDE. AN ONLINE
DOCUMENT UPLOAD SERVICE FOR
IDENTITY AND WAITED
VERIFICATION DOCUMENTS BY THE
END OF SEPTEMBER WHICH I
BELIEVE WILL HELP IMMENSELY. AN
ONLINE POPCORN MET INITIAL
CLAIM AND CONTINUE CLAIMS HER
CASE FORM FOR THE WORK SHARE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL BE RELEASED
AT THE END OF THIS WEEK. I'M
GOING WEBSITE USABILITY TESTING
WITH CUSTOMERS AND RELATED
DISABILITY ENHANCEMENT BASED ON
THE FEEDBACK OF THAT TESTING.
AND REPLACE THE CURRENT
ACTIVITY PLATFORM TO IMPROVE
EASE OF USE TO BE REPLACED BY
FAILED FOR PRODUCT AN
INTEGRATED WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
MANAGEMENT TOOL. AND IT WOULD
BE FLATTERED OF QUE CAN OF A
CALL CENTER AND I AM WITH THE
CLAIM FILING PROCESSES THE
DEPARTMENT TOOK A DIFFERENT
MANAGERS ON THE COMMUNICATION
FROM. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
INITIAL AVENUE GOOD SERVICE FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS INCLUDING A CHAT
BUT TO THE WEBSITE- AND
FACEBOOK MESSENGER THAT IS
CONNECTED WITH OVER ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION THIRD. ATTACK
MESSAGING CAMPAIGN RIGHT EIGHTY
CUSTOMER UPDATES ABOUT THE
CLAIM REDUCING EARLY THREE
MILLION CUSTOMER. CHANGES TO
THE YOUR LINE UP. TO HELP
CUSTOMERS AVOID COMMON ERRORS
WHEN ENTERING THEIR DATE OF
BIRTH IN THE CELTIC YOUR NUMBER.
AND THANKS. FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU CHANGES WERE
INCORPORATED INTO THE U. I.
ONLINE TO PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CURRENT STATUS OF THE CLAIM.
ALTHOUGH A COVERT NINETEEN
REPORT PAGAN UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS GUIDE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION SPECIFIC TO THE
CURRENT NEEDS OF CUSTOMERS. WE
ALSO ISSUE A PRESS RELEASE EAST
THIRD DATE WITH UPDATED CLAIM
DATA FROM THE WEEK OF PRIOR AND
NEW UPDATES AND INFORMATION
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. THAT HAVE
ALSO TRANSLATED INTO THE TOP
FAQ THE WEEK. AND THEN FINALLY
THE WORKFORCE SERVICES BRAND
FOR RIGHT LITTLE RAPID RESPONSE
TEAM SERVICES IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AS WELL AS
CONDUCTING TOWN HALL
INFORMATIONAL TAXES FOR
LEGISLATORS NUMBER. LET ME ALSO
TOUCH ON THE RELATIONSHIP WITH-
THE LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS. I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU YOUR
FELLOW MEMBERS AND YOUR OFTEN
STAFF I'VE DONE A FIFTEEN
CLAIMANTS WITH ACTUALLY
BRINGING BACK THE ALONE. I KNOW
YOUR OFFICE I IT'S DEALT WITH
A NUMBER OF CLAIMANTS WHO HAVE
YET TO RECEIVE RESOLUTION TO
THEIR CLAIM AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
ANSWERING CALIFORNIANS. PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC THE EATING OF
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE RECEIVED.
APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND
UNEMPLOYMENT REFERRAL EACH YEAR.
IT OF A OF THE PANDEMIC OFFICES
RECEIVED A PRACTICE FIVE
HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND CASES A
DAY IN ORDER TO BE MORE
RESPONSIBLE LEGISLATIVE
REFERRAL THE DEPARTING CREATURE
USUAL STAFFING OF THIS PROFIT
FROM A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL NINETY
THREE STAFFING MANAGER WORKING
TO DRAFT CONSTITUENT CASE WORK.
THIS INCREASE THAT HAVE A LOT
OF TO ADDRESS OVER TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND CASES. IN ADDITION A
CAVE QUIRK STAFF MAKE THAT GIVE
MANAGEMENT CLOTHING MYSELF UP
PARTICIPATING DOESN'T MEETING
GOOD LEGISLATORS AND THE STAFF
IN ORDER TO HEAR YOUR CONCERNS
AND THE JOB- FOR IMPROVEMENT
AND HAVE ACTED ON THOSE
SUGGESTIONS. THE LEGISLATIVE
REFERRAL PROCESS IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN EIGHTY THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF. AS PART OF
THIS PARTNERSHIP THE EIGHTY
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE HAS
IMPLEMENTED MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS. FROM
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND
LEADERSHIP. THANK PARTNERING
WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO
ENSURE READERS ARE
STRATEGICALLY- DIRECTED WHO
CONSTITUENTS OCCURRING
PARTICULAR HARDSHIP YOU THE
LACK OF PAYMENT OF BENEFITS.
INCLUDING THOSE CONSTITUENTS
WHO APPLIED IN MARCH OR APRIL
AND HAVE NOT RECEIVED PAYMENT.
WE WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING ANOTHER SUGGESTION
BRING YOUR STAFF THAT WOULD
WRITE A SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT
FOR EACH OF LEGISLATIVE OFFICE.
IF CONTACT WILL HAVE. YOU AYE
CLAIM FILING EXPERIENCE I WOULD
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY
WITH STAFF REGARDING THEIR
PENDING CASES. WE ARE
FINALIZING CAN'T MECHANIC
TURLEY AND PLAN TO HAVE FORMAL
GUIDANCE ON THAT EFFORTS YOU
NEXT WEEK. OUR MAIN ARE WE
COMMITTED TO SERVING
CONSTITUENTS IN THE
UNPRECEDENTED TIME AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE ADDITIONAL
METHOD FOR EXPEDITING
CONSTITUENT CASE WORK THROUGH
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU. IN
CLOSING WELL THE DEPARTMENT
HAVE PAID 80% OF THE CLAIMANTS
WHO OF YOU I SERVICES DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE REMAIN LASER
FOCUS ON THOSE CLAIMS THAT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL ACTION. OUR
GABBARD CARE DEEPLY ABOUT THE
LIVELIHOOD OF OUR NEIGHBORS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES WHICH IS WHY WE
CONTINUE TO WORK AROUND THE
CLOCK AND COMMITTED EFFORT TO
INVOLVE OUR OPERATIONS. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE ENHANCEMENTS BY PREVIOUS
OUTLINED BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
WHAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS IS THAT
EDT SINCERELY REGRET ANY
PAYMENT DELAYS EXPERIENCED BY
OUR CUSTOMERS. LASTLY I WANT TO
THANK UNDERNEATH THEM SECRETARY
TO. AND THEN HIGHER
MINISTRATION FOR THEIR ONGOING
SUPPORT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU LONGER
SECRETARY LONGER RICHARDSON
JENNIFER PARKER AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE STRIKE FOR TEAM
ON APPROVING OUR SERVICES TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WE
WELCOME AND ARE EXCITED HAVE
THEM ON BOARD WITH THAT. AND
WITH THAT I'LL BE GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISS HILLIARD FINALLY
A LET'S CHECK IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS.
CAN YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL BRANDON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AS
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
LA- CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
AN UNPRECEDENTED SPIKE IN
NEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS IN IN
RESPONSE TO THIS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT SEVERAL NEW
PROGRAMS THE EDT WAS REQUIRED
TO SET UP. AND ADMINISTER WHILE
ALSO ADDRESSING IN PROCESSING
THE INCREASING NUMBER OF YOU
AYE CLAIMS. SO TO ALLOW YOU TO
THE TO CONTINUE THIS WORK THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDES ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION STATE OPERATIONS
FOR EDT TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. AND JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT THROUGHOUT THIS COMING
FALL FINANCE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH EIGHTY DEEP.
TWO MONITORS TING LEVELS AND
MAKE NECESSARY MEN'S AS NEEDED
IN THE UPCOMING GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. I AM BEING JOINED TODAY
BY MY COLLEAGUE MIKE. I'M SORRY
MARK BENNETT ON THE PHONE AND
YOU'RE BOTH SALEABLE AND HAVE
AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE. IF YOU. THANK YOU FOR
HELP COMMENTS I HAVE SOME TO
START WITH AND I'M OTHER
MEMBERS FOR THEIR- ADDITIONALLY
WITH A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THAT
WERE SUBMITTED BY OTHER MEMBERS
DO NOT SIT ON THIS COMMITTEE I
WILL TRY TO COVER AS MANY
QUESTIONS WAS THE MIDDLE
QUESTIONS TO DEPARTMENT FOR A
WRITTEN RESPONSE A MISSILE YOUR
IF ICE THE SUBMIT QUESTION TO
YOU WOULD BE WILLING TO RESPOND
BACK TO THOSE QUESTIONS. WITH
THE WITHIN A WEEK OR SO.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FIRST
QUESTION ON STAFFING THIS
HILLIARD ARE THERE ANY BARRIERS
IN THE HIRING PROCESS THEY CAN
BE STREAMLINED IN ORDER TO HIRE
MORE STAFF. YOU KNOW LIKE I
SAID IN MY OPENING COMMENTS
ABOUT- I WORK WITH THAT- THE
DIRECTOR OF KELLY TALKING VERY
BEGINNING TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS. SO WE'RE BEING BRING
PEOPLE ON ON A ON A VERY QUICK
PACE- SO I APPRECIATE THE
ASSISTANCE BUT- THAT IS NOT A
BARRIER AND WERE CONTINUING TO
HIRE EVERY DAY. AND WILL SO I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WE'RE HIRING
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE I
CONTINUE TO ASSESS IF WE NEED
MORE. I'M ALREADY PLANNING- IN
AUGUST TO ADD EVEN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE CALL CENTER TO
ENSURE- FULL SERVICE. THANK
YOU. HOW AND WHY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM. GROW
FROM SIXTY PLUS MILLION. TO
OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
AND NOT ABLE US. TO BE ABLE
SUPPORT THE SURGE FROM THE
PANDEMIC. YEAH SO THAT PROJECT
WAS A PARTIAL MODERNIZATION OF
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAM AND FORTUNATELY AT THAT
TIME- MINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE AT THAT TIME- ONLY
ALLOWED US TO- ENHANCE THE MALL
PORTION. OF THAT YOU AYE
SYSTEM- WHICH- FROM A
TECHNOLOGY STANDPOINT TO WHEN
YOU ADD A BOLT ON SYSTEM TO A
OLD LEGACY SYSTEM. THIS
CREATES- HIGHER EXPAND HIGHER
DOLLARS AND IS VERY COMPLEX. NO
FUTURE OF SUB FORCING THE
MINISTRATION QUITE OFTEN YOU
GET THESE BCP'S THAT COME
THROUGH BUT A CHANGE PROPOSALS
SO ALIVE IT'S BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE WHERE A LOT OF
THINGS DN'T MAKE UP THE CHAIN
OF COMMAND. EITHER STOP THE
DIRECTORS LEVEL THE DEPARTMENT
AGENCY OR EVEN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SO. THAT'S JUST BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE THE PAST SIX YEARS
SINGLES COMMITTEE AND NOT DOING
THIS SO WITH THE- IMPACT OF THE
MONEY SPENT WITH DELIGHT
RELATED TO COVER NINETEEN
SEARCH RESPONSE- WHAT IMPACT
THAT MONEY HAVE. AND ON WAIT
TIMES CLAIMS PROCESS ETCETERA.
HELLO WE HAD A COUPLE OF
CONTRACT WITH THE LAWYER DURING
THE PANDEMIC LINE FOR ABOUT
FIVE MILLION THAT- OR
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AS WE-
PROGRAMS ARE YOU AYE SYSTEM TO
ADDRESS ALL THE ELEMENTS OF THE
CARE BACK PROGRAM- BECAUSE THAT
HAPPENED TO BE DONE IN RECORD
TIME AS WE ALL KNOW. THE SECOND
WAS WE HAD A CONTRACT FOR CALL
AGENT CENTER AGENT AND SUPPORT
SERVICE FOR OUR CALL CENTER.
AND THAT WAS THE WAY TO BRING
CALL. VERY QUICK. OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND WITHIN FIVE
DAYS AND WE WERE ABLE THEM
TRAIN UP RUNNING. SO WHERE
UTILIZING AS A TEMPORARY
MEASURE AS WE WORK TO- LONG
TERM TO FILL- OUR OUR STATE
SERVICE POSITION. AND THE LAST
YEAR YOU DISCUSSED IT
VERIFICATIONS TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE ID VERIFICATIONS.
IN OTHER WAYS TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND BE COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
EXAMPLE HOW DOES EASY TREE THE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I'M NOT I'M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO. I WAS TO THIS
POOR THE PROCESS. BUT HOW DO
STREAMLINED OBVIOUSLY WHO'S WHO
I GUESS WHO REQUIRES ID
VERIFICATIONS THAT UNEASY D. AS
A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRED.
FEDERAL STATE REQUIREMENT BUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR DOES-
ALL STATES ARE REQUIRED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE'RE PROTECTING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE PROGRAM- AS
FAR AS IDENTITY- WE HAVE
CONDUCTED SEVERAL BUSINESS
PROPERLY REVIEWS TO SEE WHERE
WE CAN STREAMLINE ON EVERY
ORDER AT AT ANY POINT. IN
ADDITION I MENTIONED WE'RE
GOING TO BE PULLING OUT A
HOPEFUL BUT WELL ENOUGH- LATER
IN SEPTEMBER AND ID MANAGEMENT
UPLOAD AND THAT WILL HELP
GREATLY RIGHT NOW PEOPLE HAVE
TO SEND YOU WE HAVE TO. SEND
THEM A LETTER AND THEY HAVE TO
MAIL BACK THEIR DOCUMENTS. AND
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT TAKES A LOT
OF TIME- SO WE'RE GONNA BE
ROLLING OUT AT THIS SO PEOPLE
CAN DO IT A LOT TRONG PLEA SO.
HELLO ALL RIGHT. IF THAT WERE
ALL OUT HOW PROMPTED IN IT THAT
ALL BACK THE OVER A- SO WE'RE
EXCITED OF THIS UP LOW AND I'M
GETTING ROLLED OUT OF STUDENTS
BECAUSE AS I MAY THAT IS ONE OF
OUR GAP AREAS IS GETTING TOO I
BUT IT SO EXTREME POURTANT
LEVEL OF FRAUD THAT'S GOING ON.
MY DISTRICT IS WILL LIKELY
DISTRICTS TO FILL THE QUESTIONS
ONE APPLICANT RECEIVES A LETTER
FROM YOU DD THIS IS THEIR
ELIGIBLE FOR ZERO FUNDING OR
DENY. THIS EDT THIS EASY SYSTEM
PROVIDE ANY CLARIFICATIONS FOR
APPLICANTS WHO BELIEVE THEY
RECEIVED AN INCORRECT ANALYSIS.
AND WHAT IS A FOLLOW UP PROCESS.
YEAH SO WHEN ON THE NORTH
ITSELF- YEAH IT IT IT GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CLIMATE THREE
BY BACK AND ASK MORE QUESTIONS-
AND- WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
YEAH YEAH- GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
KNOW THAT THE VITAMINS BUT
CUSTOMER THAT IS THE
INFORMATION ISN'T THAT THEY ARE
MISSING WAKE HIM PERMISSION-
FOR THEIR CLAIM. THAT THEY CAN
RETURN OF INFORMATION TO US ON
THE ADDRESS ON THE NOTE ITSELF.
FOR THAT THERE'S NOTHING IN
HISTORY AND IS THAT THE DVD
WILL BEGIN A WAIT INVESTIGATION
AT THAT POINT- THEY CAN ALSO
SUBMIT AN ONLINE INQUIRY- THE
TOPIC IS UP THROUGH THERE YOU
AYE ONLINE ACCOUNT IT'S CALLED
MISSING WAIT WHILE I'M IN THERE
WAITING AT THE GATE. I'M NOT.
LET WE- TELL ME OR IS IT PIECE
MAILED OUT. THEY HAVE THE MAC
THEY DO IT THROUGH THE MAIL BY
RESPONDING TO THE NOTED OR THEY
CAN SUBMIT AN ONLINE INQUIRY
REQUESTING THAT WE LOOK INTO
THE MATTER. HELLO CAN CONSIST
EXPECT TO RECEIVE BENEFITS
AFTER A CLAIM IS SUCCESSFULLY
PROCESSED. AND IS THERE A WAY
TO GET DEBIT CARDS SICHUAN'S
QUICKER. SO THE DEBIT CARD FOR
THE MOST PART IF THEY'VE
ALREADY HAD A CLAIM ALREADY
HAVE A DEBIT CARD- AND LESSER
BRAND NEW GUN EMPLOYMENT AND
THEN THEY GET MAILED OUT RIGHT
AWAY SO THEY SHOULD HAVE WITHIN
FIVE TO SEVEN DAYS- SO THAT IS
PRETTY QUICK AS IT IS. AND
THAT'S SEVEN DAY AFTER THIS
CLIM IS PROCESSED. IT WOULD BE
AND TYPICALLY- WITHIN THE THIRD
WEEK AFTER THE CLAIM HAVE BEEN
PROCESS AFTER THEY SUBMITTED
THEIR APPLICATIONS FROM THE
APPLE CAMCORDER EIGHT THEY HAVE
TO CERTIFY FOR THE VERY FIRST.
WEEK THEY HAVE TO BE CONTINUED
CERTIFICATION THREE AT THE
ELIGIBILITY IS BASED ON A WEEK
BY WEEK BASIS SO AFTER THEY
SUBMIT THEIR CERTIFICATION FOR
THEIR INITIAL TWO WEEK- COULD
BUT- THERE ARE NO ELIGIBILITY
ISSUES WE AUTHORIZED PAYMENT
THAT THIRD WE- AND THAT. WE
HAVE A CARD FOR THE VERY AND IT.
SEVEN DATE BY MAIL YEAH. OKAY
ENDED MORE QUESTION CAN A
WEBSITE FEATURE TO LOCK TO THE
RAP. OF AND REAL TIME A MAY AS
NEW. NOT NOT WHAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM BUT DEFINITELY WILL TAKE
THAT- ACTION AND WHEN THE TAP-
THE STRIKING COMES IN. THAT WAY
AND MANY OTHER AREAS- WILL
ENGAGE DISCUSSION WITH THEM. MR
DOING AS YOU THE REAL MISMATCH
TO. THANK YOU ME FIRST START BY.
AGAIN THANK THE CHAIR FOR HERE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST OF
THE CHAIR THAT WE HOLD MORE
HEARINGS LIKE THIS BECAUSE-
APPARENTLY THE HEARING HIS HELP
TO TRIGGER US BEING ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION AND I APPRECIATE SO
OF THE- TO THE BUT I CRAWL IN
SAN THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING
OF ALL THAT WE NEED. WELL AT
THIS YEAR'S A QUESTIONS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND REALLY START WITH
UNDERSTANDING THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE PROBLEM. LEGISLATORS IN THE
PRESS HAVE BEEN REPEATEDLY
ASKING DIRECTOR HILLIARD- YOU
ABOUT THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
BACKLOG OF THESE UNPAID CLAIMS
AND WE'VE HEARD YOU CALL SIMPLY
DOCK AND AVOID ANSWERING THESE.
ON TO GIVE IF TEMPLES EARLIER
THIS YEAR. LOCAL CBS STATIONS
ANALYZE DATA THAT SHOW THAT
THREE OUT OF FIVE INITIAL
CLAIMS AND NOT YET THE PAGE. HE
SAID IT DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
TRACK HOW MANY PEOPLE HAD
CLAIMS APPROVED TONIGHT HEY. ON
JULY THE SIXTH. DIRECTOR
HILLIARD YOU MET WITH THE
LEGISLATURE COORDINATION GROUP
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION DOZENS
OF LEGISLATORS AS YOU WILL
REMEMBER. ARE SIMPLY BUDGET
CHAIR. ASKED YOU HOW MANY
CLAIMS RUN PAID. YOU SAID AND I
QUOTE. A HUNDRED THOUSAND. NOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS NO
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND QUOTE. TWO
DAYS LATER JULY EIGHTH ONE
ASKED HOW MANY CLAIMS FOR
UNPAID YOUR SPOKESPERSON SAID
QUOTE THAT'S A VERY SMALL. VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE PROBABLY LESS
THAN 1% NOT A ON JULY EIGHTH
THIS IS A MARK REPORTED. BASED
ON FEDERAL DEPARTMENT LABORS
TO. AS THE END OF MAY. AFTER
THE FIRST THREE A PANDEMIC THAT
ONE POIN EIGHT EIGHT MILLION.
ALMOST MILLION ON THE CLAIMS
FILED. WERE YET TO BE. DR
HILLIARD. WHY DID YOU LIE TO US
WHY HAVE YOU BEEN THIS IN FROM
THE PUBLIC. I WOULD NEVER LIE
TO THE PUBLIC OR TO THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY- MY I CAN'T
SPEAK TO- ALL THE THINGS THAT
YOU CITED BUT CAN'T SPEAK TO
THE FACT THAT. IT HAS BEEN A
STRUGGLE FOR A COLD YEAH- THE
WAY THAT PEOPLE WILL. TO HEAR.
NOT THE WAY THAT OUR IT. SIGNED
OF THE OLD ANTIQUATED SYSTEM SO
WE HAD TO DO MANY. SPECIAL IN
ORDER TO GET AT THE HEARTOF
THE PERCENTAGES AND I DON'T
KNOW WHY- IN MIND THAT WE'RE
FINALLY TO GET A CALL THE DAY.
AND IT'S BEEN SO PEOPLE COULD
HAVE IT THAT IT WASN'T
PUBLICIZED. SO ON AND THAT WAS
ARE YOU KNOW WE JEFF FINISH THE
VERY INTENSIVE DIFFICULT Q. AND
A VERY OLD SYSTEM AND HAVE THE
PROPER DATA TO WHICH TO SHOW.
SO ALL ABOUT. AND THIS EVERYONE
SEE WHAT THE DATA IS BUT AT THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE CORRECT IN
ORDER TO PUT IT OUT THERE AND I
DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE IT I DO
WANT TO PUTTING IT OUT UNTIL IT
WAS READY. SEC SO I ALSO WANT.
THANK MR DAILY WHO I'M GOING TO
BE JOINING IN HIS LEGISLATION
WHERE WE NEED TO SEE WEEKLY
DATA REALLY UNDERSTAND METRICS
OF WHERE WE ARE AS WE ARE
HOPEFULLY GOING TO COME OUT OF
THIS. A BEGINNER PERCENT OUT.
SAYING THAT THE NUMBER OF
CLAIMS THAT WERE UNRESOLVED
CECINA MILLION. AND AS I'M SURE
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WE'RE
WONDERING WHAT MAKES THESE
NUMBERS MORE BELIEVABLE THAN
WHAT'S BEEN SEVEN PASSED. IN AS
I LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS YOU SEE
A MILLION. DIFFERENT EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE ALL WITH
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ONE
NUMBER LESS. BUT THERE'S OTHER
NUMBER. OF TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND FOLKS NEED ET
RESOLUTION MEANING YOU HAVE
INFORMATION YOU NEED. A QUARTER
MILLION CALIFORNIANS STILL
HAVEN'T RECEIVED TAX AND I KNOW
IT'S CONVENIENT TO SAY LESS
THAN A MILLION BUT FROM YOUR
OWN NUMBERS IT APPEARS THAT ONE
POINT ONE THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS STILL HAVEN'T
GOTTEN FULLY PAID IN THEIR
CLAIMS RIGHT. FOR PAYMENT- AT
THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND AND THE ACTUAL ITEMS
THAT EDT- NEED TO TAKE ACTION
ON AND ARE DELAYED. A LARGER
VERSION FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CLAIMANTS- ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BUY BUT HAVE NEVER
GONE INTO THE SYSTEM TO
CERTIFY. THAT IS SOMETHING A
FROM OFTEN NOT ALONE THAT WE-
NOTED. MONTH HELLO CLAIM AND
DIRECTOR THAT WE- THREE HAD
SEVENTY CLAIM LAP MONTH IN
REMINDING THEM HEY GOING
CERTIFIED SO YOU CAN GET YOUR
BENEFIT. AS A RESULT WE SAW THE
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHEN IN THIS SORT OF BY
RIGHT AWAY AND 60% WERE PAID.
SO BASED ON THAT WERE NOW
PENDING- EMAIL- ONGOING AND TO
ORDER TO HELP PEOPLE EDUCATE
PEOPLE SO THEY KNOW THAT THEY
SHOULD GO AND CERTIFIED. FOR
WHAT. AND I UNDER A COUPLE
BECAUSE PROGRAM AND PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE THEY HAVE. TO GO
IN EVERY TWO WEEKS AND ACTUALLY
SIR. SO WITH THIS ADDITIONAL. I
THINK THAT WILL WILL REALLY BE
OFFENSIVE. WHY OTHER AREA WITH
ABOUT DATA THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN WORKING ON A DATA
DASHBOARD- WE'RE FEELING PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT IT BUT WERE WAITING
FOR THE TRACK TEAM TO COME IN
WE REALLY LIKE THEM TO PAY A
LOOK AT. IT ADD THAT. LATER ON
OR THEY MAY HAVE SOME OTHER
IDEAS C WE WANT TO MAKE THE
DATA USEFUL AT FOR EVERYBODY
AND IT IS OUR INTENT TO UPDATE.
COOLEY AGAIN WERE A- BY THE
STRIKE TEAMS WHO THEY BEGIN.
AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY DESPERATE
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE AS AS IT'S
OF. UP WHEN YOU YESTERDAY
COMMITTED THAT YOU WERE GOING
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT THE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND NUMBER
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND NUMBER. THE DIFFERENCE
OF. POINT TWO MILLION YEAH
WHICH NUMBER. IF YOU. THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS A TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE DOLLARS IN THAT YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT OUR OUR RESOURCES
LATER FOCUSED ON IN ORDER TO
DROUGHT THE BACKLOG BECAUSE THE
OTHER ITEMS THAT WE HAVE IN IN
WHICH WE CAN TAKE ACTION-
OTHER- THE OTHER BUCKETS ARE
NOT ACTUAL FOR US PEOPLE DON'T
GO IN AND CERTIFY THERE'S
NOTHING WE CAN DO ABOUT. THEY
DO HOWEVER LIKE I SAID WE ARE
NOW GOING IN AND SEND EMAILS TO
PROP PEOPLE TO HELP THEM NOW
THAT IF THEY WERE AND OF COURSE.
THEY'RE NOT. IF I CAN A VERY
LOW TIME COMMITTING TO AS FAR
AS THE NUMBER OF THAT WILL BE
RESOLVED BY BACK LIKE SHE CAN
JUST GIVE US A NUMBER. THIRTY
NINE HAPPENED TO THE OTHER
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE. IT
THE CLAIM HATE WELL LET ME TELL
YOU ABOUT AS DIRECTOR LET'S
FOCUS ON THAT ALMOST MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IT'S A LARGE GROUP
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR BENEFITS BUT
YOU NEED MORE INFORMATION. YOUR
HONOR PORTAL DOESN'T OR
CONSTITUENTS WHAT MORE
INFORMATION NEEDED HE NEEDS. IT
DOESN'T SEND CATIONS TO THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT SPECIFIED
WHAT INFORMATION YOU NEED OUR
CONSTITUENTS CAN'T REACH PEOPLE
THROUGH YOUR CALL CENTERS TO
TELL YOU WHAT YOU NEED SO HOW
ON EARTH. ARE THESE IT EARNED
ONE THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
SUPPOSED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
RESOLVE THEIR CLAIMS. THAT
NUMBER ONE. YEAH SO WE DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS IN
COMMUNICATION WE SEND EMAILS WE
SEND NOTIFICATION- NOTICES WE
HAVE UPDATED OUR FAQS OUR
WEBSITE WE'RE DOING PRESS
RELEASES. WE'RE EVERYTHING WE
CAN POSSIBLY THING OF TWO AND
THE THAT WAY TO AND HE OUR
CLEAN WE ALSO AS I'M- DID BE
DOING IT CAN. YEAH PEOPLE OR OR.
VERY ACTION AT SOME POINT. WE
CAN DO IT BECAUSE IS GOING INTO.
SO AGAIN IF I CAN JUST I JUST
MAKE SURE I'M OR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SAYING YOUR ONLY
COMMITTING AT THIS TIME. TO BE
ABLE TO RESOLVE BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER. BY THE END OF
SEPTEMBER SO SEVEN MONTHS AFTER
THIS ALL STARTED. TO RESOLVE
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND. CLAIMS AGAIN
POTENTIALLY LEAVING A MILLION
PEOPLE HANGING. IF I CAN I
THINK I'M GOING ON THIS I'M
JUST A ONE MORE QUESTION IN
THIS AREA A LITTLE AND I JUST
WANT TO ADD I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S A CORRECT
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE NUMBERS
IN HEAR YOU SAYING THAT YOUR-
BOBBI THE SUCH IS IN. EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE FIVE. MAYBE
ALL WITH ADDITIONAL. RELATED TO
ONGOING EMAIL BETWEEN OCCASIONS
TO ENSURE THAT WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING TO MAKE SURE THE
CUSTOMER KNOW THAT THEY NEED TO
CERTIFY- ABSOLUTELY WE'RE GOING
ABOVE AND BEYOND TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENING LET ME JUST AND
WITH THE ABOUT MY COMMITMENT ON
THAT I'M GONNA MAKE I'M GONNA
MAKE. A I'M GONNA. I'M GONNA
ASK. IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
THE FORMER CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
OF LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT MARTY MORGANSTERN.
ONE IS ADDRESSING THE FACT THAT
AT THAT TIME EDT HAD A BACKLOG
OF UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND HE SAID THAT
THE CONTINUING DELAYS WERE
UNACCEPTABLE AND WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN SUPPORT IN ORDER WAS MADE
TO IMMEDIATELY BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF PAYING BACK LAW
CLAIMS FOR CONTINUE BENEFITS
PRIOR TO A FINAL THE TRIP. THE
BILL ANOTHER WORDS RATHER THAN
IN ONE MILLION PLUS INDIVIDUALS
AS POTENTIAL SUSPECTS WE GOT
THEM HELP. IS SOMETHING THAT
YOUR DEPARTMENT WILL CONSIDER.
AS I MENTIONED THAT THE DAY ONE
WE REDUCE EL REQUIREMENTS AND-
ARE AUTOMATICALLY PAYING- ARE
GOING TO THE PROCESS ALREADY SO
WE'VE ALREADY STREAMLINED IT
AND DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN-
DEPARTMENT LABOR WE ARE YOU
KNOW IT'S A FEDERAL. I ASK YOU
I'M ASKING A QUICK QUESTION
YESTERDAY NO WILL YOU CONSIDER.
MOVING FORWARD IN ORDER TO
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN PAYING
BACKLOG CLAIMS FOR BENEFITS. SO
WE DID THAT IN APRIL AND MAY
AND DEPARTMENT OF LABOR CITED%
US AND- WE HAD TO STOP THAT.
AND I COULD I MEAN COULD YEAH
THAT WAS THE THAT THEY WERE.
LOOKING FOR MANY WITH THAT WE
DID THAT AND THAT PRACTICE ANNA
WASN'T IN CONTROL- WHAT DID NOT
CONFORM WITH FEDERAL LOCK SO WE
SEE. YEAH WE GET UP PROVIDING
VERY CALM ANSWER TO WERE LOOK
FOR SOLUTIONS HERE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR RESULTS- AND I'M
GOING TO SEE MY TIE BACK TO THE
CHAIR LOTS OF OTHER QUESTIONS
BUT THE LOOKING FORTY THE
DISCUSSION THANK YOU. MISS
BETWEEN NORTH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AT DIRECTOR HIRED AS- AS
I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS THE TWO THINGS I REALLY
WANTED TO GET INTO OUR CUSTOMER
SERVICE. AND THE DEPARTMENTS
TECHNOLOGY SO STARTING WITH
CUSTOMER SERVICE YOU MENTIONED
IN YOUR OPENING REMARKS THAT
YOU ARE WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK AND THAT'S ACTUALLY IS
I'VE- I'VE HEARD YOU GET
PREVIOUSLY SO. I HAVE WHAT ARE
THE OPENING HOURS YOUR CALL
CENTER RIGHT. WE HAVE TO
CENTERS RIGHT NOW- OUR- MAIN
ONE IS ON MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY
EIGHT AS WELL. AND THEN WE HAVE
A SECONDARY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM EIGHT TWO EIGHT
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. OKAY SO. I
AND IF I'M CORRECT THE- CALL
CENTER THAT STAFF WITH ACTUAL
TRAINED CASEWORKERS IS OPEN
FROM EIGHT AM TO. PM MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY IS CRACKS THEIR
TECHNICAL. I MEAN UP ALL OF OUR
GO AGENT- HAVE A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF- ASSISTANT BUT- SO DO
YOU OKAY HELP ME UNDERSTAND WHY
DO WE HAVE CASE WORKERS WHO ARE
ONLY WORKING FOUR HOURS A DAY.
THE OTHER OUR THIRD ROUND
PAYING BENEFITS. THAT WE WHAT I
MEAN AFTER PRIMARY- YOU KNOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR BENEFITS ARE
PAYMENT TO GO OUT THE DOOR IS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO WE NEED.
THERE ARE SOME LEVEL HUMAN
IMPRESSION OF NEED FOR.
PROCESSING NOT ALL OF THEM GO
THROUGH THE SYSTEM
AUTOMATICALLY. HOURS ON THE
PHONE WAITING FOR SOMEBODY TO
PICK UP AND THEN WHEN THEY PICK%
UP AND IT'S THREE O'CLOCK IN
THE AFTERNOON. YOUR TOLD SORRY
ARE. TRAINED SKILLED ACTUAL
CASE WORKERS ARE ONLY HERE FROM
EIGHT AM TO TWELVE PM. I CAN.
TRY TO ATTACK THE SYSTEM WHICH-
NOTHING. I'M SO I GUESS I WOULD
ARGUE. THAT AT EIGHTY AM TO
TWELVE PM IS NOT WORKING THE
CLOCK. ATM EXCEPT FOR A SMARTER.
AT SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO EXTEND THE
HOURS AND PROVIDE SERVICE. ALL
DAY FROM EIGHT AM TO FIVE PM.
SO I THINK I MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING REMARKS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO COMBINE THE CALL
CENTER THE TWO OF THEM INTO ONE
SO WE PROVIDE. SERVICE FROM
EIGHT EIGHT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS GREAT- I DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT DATE. I DON'T
HAVE AN EXACT DATE. AT ABOUT. I
APOLOGIZE IN A FOR. I KNOW THAT
WE'RE ON AND IT'S TIME CLOCK I
GOT A MY FIVE SO I'M JUST GONNA
COMPANY SO WE CAN MAKE MUCH
PROGRESS IS POSSIBLE. I'M OKAY
SORRY WHAT WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO- DELIVER ON THAT
GOAL AND HAVE OUR CALL CENTER
IS OPEN FROM EIGHT TO EIGHT.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY OPEN FROM
EIGHT EIGHT YOU KNOW YOU WILL
BE. LIKE THIS TO HAPPEN BINDING
ACTUAL CASE WORKERS FROM EIGHT
TO EIGHT. WE DO HAVE FULLY
TRAINED ON THE EIGHT EIGHT.
YEAH WE AIM TO CONTINUE TO
ENHANCE OUR- SKILLS OF OUR OUR
FOLKS EVERY DAY. BUT WE'RE
ADDING MORE AND WHAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF TRAINING
EVERY WEEK THAT ARE FULLY
TRAINED FOR CLAIM PROCESSING-
BEING ADDED TO THE POND AS WE
SPEAK. RIGHT SO THIS CALL
CENTER THAT'S RIGHT NOW OPEN
FROM EIGHT AM TO TWELVE PM. IF
YOU'VE SAID YOUR TARGET IS TO
EXTEND THE APRS FOR EIGHT AM TO
EIGHT PM WHEN IS THAT GOING TO
HAPPEN.SO LIKE I SAID WE
ALREADY ARE OPEN EIGHT TO EIGHT
AND WE DO PROVIDE BOTH
TECHNICAL AND CLAIMS- THAT
SYSTEMS AND WE'RE ADDING MORE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRAINED TO HELP
TO THE FULL GAMUT. AND A
ROLLING OFF ON TO THAT
TECHNICAL LINE EVERY DAY
DIRECTOR YOU'RE NOT IN THE
ROOMS YOU'RE NOT SEEN THE
NUMBER OF EYES ROLLING AND THE
NUMBER OF EXASPERATED FOLKS IN
THE AUDIENCE AS YOU ARE.
CONTINUING TO FAIL TO ANSWER
THIS QUESTION IT IT HONESTLY
IT'S A SIMPLE QUESTION AND THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO
ANSWER IT DOES NOT GIVE ME ANY
FAITH THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO ACHIEVE. THE GOALS AND
THE TARGET THAT YOU SHARED WITH
THE PART OF YOUR OPENING
REMARKS. WITH THAT BEING SAID
MAYBE NOT. FOR CONSIDER HAVE
ALSO BEEN TOLD. THAT YOUR CALL
BACK LAST HAS A FOUR TO SIX
WEEK WAIT TIME IS THAT TRUE.
RIGHT NOW IT IS UP FORTY SIX
WEEKS- WASTE TIME ON THE
COLLEGE. OKAY AGAIN DO YOU
THINK THAT IS ACCEPTABLE. NO
ABSOLUTELY NOT OKAY- AND WHAT
IS THE TARGET CALL THAT TIME
THAT YOU HAVE SET FOR YOUR
DEPARTMENT. I ACTUALLY TRYING
TO GET OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF
DOING CALL BACK THAT'S WHY
WE'RE UPGRADING OUR CALL
CENTERS SO WE CAN HAVE. A FULLY
TRAINED STAFF FROM EIGHT TO
EIGHT ONE VIRTUAL CALL CENTER
AND PROVIDING FULL SERVICE
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. SO THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE'RE- PUTTING FULLY TRAINED
PEOPLE INTO OUR EIGHT EIGHT
TECHNICAL. SO THEY CAN ANSWER
GOAL SERVICE QUESTIONS.
UNDERSTOOD THAT AGAIN YOU
SEVERAL TIMES MENTIONED THE
INITIATIVE YOU HAVE UNDER WAY
TO UPGRADE THE CALL CENTER TO
PROVIDE FULL SERVICE FROM EIGHT
AM TO EIGHT PM AND THAT'S YOUR
NUMBER ONE GOAL SO WHEN IS THAT
GOING TO COME ONLINE. I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT DATE OF THAT WAR
WE'RE STARTING WITH SKILL BASED
ROUTING- TO SO CALLED GO INTO
VERY DIFFERENT BUCKETS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO GROUND THE ISSUE.
TO HELP THE CUSTOMER AND- ALSO
MAKE IT EASIER TO PROCESS THE
WHATEVER THE CONCERN IS SO THAT
IS BEING ROLLED OUT IN THE
MIDDLE OF OCTOBER. I GIL BATES
ROUTING MOVING ON TO- WORKING
ON DOING THE CONSOLIDATION I
JUST DON'T HAVE A FINAL DAY ON
THE CONSOLIDATION. THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PROJECT
PLAN IS NUMBER ONE LIKE CLEAR
GOALS AND DELIVERABLES AND
NUMBER TWO AN ACTUAL TARGET
TIME LINES EVERYBODY'S WORKING
TOWARDS THE SAME GOAL SO IF WE
PAID FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
DELAY AND THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
GIVEN YOUR PROJECT PLAN. WITH
ACTUAL TIMELINETHEN I THINK
YOU NEED TO ASK FOR YOUR MONEY
BACK. I'M A CAT B. NINE AT A
LITTLE BIT SO. QUICKLY I WANT
TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS ON
THE TECHNOLOGY SIDE. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
ANNOUNCED THAT THAT
MODERNIZATION PROJECT WAS GOING
TO TAKE A LEVIN YEARS. I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT- WE FOLLOW THAT
THE POWER PROCESS SET BY TAKE A
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF THE
ANSWER IS YES FOR JESUS
CONTINUE. I'M OKAY I SO DURING
THE PANDEMIC YES DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE'VE BECOME AWARE
THAT A NUMBER OF STATES HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY OVERHAULED THEIR
YOU AYE SYSTEMS IN A MATTER OF
MONTHS OR EVEN WEEKS ARE YOU
AWARE OF THAT HAVE YOU READ THE
STORIES AND SEEN THE NEWS
ARTICLES ABOUT THE SUCCESSES
THAT OTHER STATES HAVE HAD IN
THIS- IN THIS. EVERY STATE IN A
DIFFERENT SITUATION OF BARS
WHERE THEIR SYSTEM IS MORE
FULLY MODERNIZERS AND SUMMER. I
AM MORE ANTIQUATED AND THAT SO
IT ALL DEPENDS WHERE THEY ARE
IN THE IN THE PROCESS. HAVE YOU
AT ANY POINT. REACHED OUT TO
YOUR COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER
STATES TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE IN ORDER TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFORM THEIR
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN A MATTER OF
WEEKS AND MONTHS RATHER THAN.
THE YEARS THAT IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S GOING TO TAKE US.
ABSOLUTELY WE PARTICIPATE IN
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
WORKFORCE MINISTRY- AND MEET
RITE AID AT THE COLLECTIVE
NATION. TO CARE ABOUT. WHAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING. AND I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH ANY- STATE THAT
HAS- MODERNIZE UP UNDER MY
WHOLE YOU AYE SYSTEM IN MIND.
AT ARE THERE ARE BEEN COUPLE OF
STATES WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
LAUNCH A CLOUD BASED SYSTEM US
AND LEVERAGING LIKE AMAZON'S
DELIVERY PLATFORM IN. THAT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO OPERATE ALONG SIDE
THEIR LEGACY SYSTEM I'M TO HAVE
YOU CONTACTED THE VENDORS AND
THE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES HAVE
DELIVERED. SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY IN THE FIELD NOW AND
WORKING. YEAH I AM VERY EXCITED
TO HAVE THE STRIKE FORCE- COME
IN AND HELP WITH THAT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL TECHNOLOGIES
THAT- COULD BE CONSIDERED. I
KNOW- JENNIFER WHO'S GOING TO
HEAD UP THE STRIKE TEAM HAS
GREAT TECHNOLOGY BACKGROUND. SO
I AM THRILLED TO HAVE ROB FORD.
RIGHT I'M SO I THINK THAT. I
THINK THAT THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF
THE STRIKE TEAM IS GOOD I WISH
HAD COME EARLIER BUT- MY
CONCERN IS THAT ALL OF THESE
TIME LINES JUST SEEM TOTALLY
OUT OF STEP WITH THE URGENCY OF
THE MOMENT THAT WE ARE IN I'M
AND IT TO ME ACTUALLY WAS
EXEMPLIFIED WHEN YOU POINTED
OUT THAT I YOU'VE NOW YOU'RE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD
ON I REQUEST- TO APPOINT A
SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT FOR
EACH LIKE. OFFICE AND THAT WAS
A REQUEST THAT WE MADE OF YOUR-
CAUGHT AGAIN EIGHT WELL. IN
FACT THAT YOU'VE GOT A PROBABLY
TOLD US NOW THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SHARE GUIDANCE ABOUT THAT
NEXT WEEK IN MID AUGUST. TO ME
JUST EXEMPLIFIES HOW SLOWLY
THINGS ARE MOVING AND- I'M
REALLY CONCERNED- I'M I'M VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT I'VE
HEARD SO FAR AND- I GUESS WOULD
URGE WOULD WOULD YOU URGE YOU
WOULD URGE US. TO EXPEDITE THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND RATHER THAN WAIT YOU
KNOW MONTHS FOR. REPORTS AND
MONTHS FOR ANALYSES ON WHETHER
OR NOT IT DATA DASHBOARD MAKES
SENSE TO ACTUALLY. MAKE
SOLUTIONS HAPPEN NOW IN
PROGRESS NOW HAVE. WITH THAT
I'LL TURN IT BACK TEACHER. WILL
WAIT FOR MY TURN MR OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I HAD
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PORTION
OF THIS PROBLEM BECAUSE I'VE
YOU THIS THIS FAILURE AS
PREDOMINANTLY IN I. T. FAILURE-
IT'S HORRIFYING TO THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SOME OF
THE SYSTEM STILL RUNNING AND
COBALT. AND BY THE WAY I IN MY
DAY I WAS ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD
PROGRAM AND I KNOW COBLE SO IF
PUBLIC SERVICE DOESN'T WORK OUT
FOR ME YOU SHOULD LOOK ME UP.
SO I'M GRATIFIED TO HEAR THAT
WE'VE GOT A STRIKE TEAM THAT'S
GOING TO BE INVESTIGATING
REPLACEMENT OF THAT SYSTEM. AND
I'M SURE THAT THE INDUSTRY
PARTNERS THAT YOU HAVE- THAT
YOU HAVE ENGAGED. ARE GOING TO
TELL YOU THAT- THE WAY TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS IS TO MAKE IT SO
THAT MOST PEOPLE CAN FILE
CLAIMS WITHOUT HAVING. ANY KIND
OF PROBLEM AND THE ONES THAT DO
HAVE PROBLEMS- ENABLE THEM TO
SUBMIT THEIR DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY AND HAVE A AN
AUTOMATED REVIEW PROCESS. TO
MAKE IT SHOULD MAKE IT SO THAT
A- HUMAN DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO
GET INVOLVED. AND THAT'S HOW
YOU SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF HAVING
TO STAFF ON HUGE CALL CENTERS.
IF I JUST ENDING A SYSTEM IN.
GET THE HOMES ALL WITHOUT
ACTUALLY HAVING TO CALL. SO
YOUR DOG GO AHEAD IF YOU'D LIKE.
I WOULD HAVE TOTALLY AGREE WITH
YOU AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
EXCITED THAT- WILL BE AWARDING
A VENDOR IN OCTOBER FOR
COMPLETE AND REPLACEMENT OF OUR
SYSTEM. I KNOW WE'RE ALL
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THAT
I HAVE A CONCERN THOUGH IN THE
SHORTER TERM. BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED. CARE IS TO IS
CURRENTLY BEING NEGOTIATED AND
CONGRESS. AND I SHOULD THAT
PASS IT IS LIKELY THAT THE
STRUCTURE OF THOSE ENHANCED
FEDERAL. THAT WILL BE MORE
COMPLEX THAN IT HAS BEEN BEFORE
SO IN OTHER WORDS INSTEAD OF
JUST A FLAT AMOUNT PER WEEK
IT'S LIKELY TO BE PERHAPS A
PERCENTAGE. OF THE REPLACEMENT
WAGES THAT THE CLAIMANT HAD
EARNED AND I'M CONCERNED AND
HERE'S MY QUESTION DOES OUR
EXISTING SYSTEM HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO HANDLE THEY CALL
FOR LIKE THAT AND WHAT KIND OF
DIFFICULTY ARE WE GONNA HAVE
SPENDING THAT UP. YES WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN- THEY REACHED OUT
TO US ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS AND- HOW LONG WOULD
IT TAKE A- IT IT DEPENDING ON
THE COMPLEXITY OF WHAT THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES. FROM ANY TIME
MORTGAGE. HIGHER WAGES THAT IS
VERY CHALLENGING- MATTER
BETWEEN TWELVE THE TWENTY WEEK
PROGRAMMING. SO IF I'M STANDING
EVEN IF CONGRESS WERE TO ACTON
EXTEND FEDERAL A SUPPLEMENTAL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
SHOULD THAT TAKE THE STRUCTURE
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING IT
TO TAKE US UP TO TWENTY WEEKS
BEFORE WE WERE ABLE TO START
PROCESSING THOSE CLAIMS. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY BEEN COMMUNICATING
BACK THE NATIONAL LEVEL AS WELL
AS FAR AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT
OF. LABOR EVERYONE VERY AWARE
OF IT AND WE'RE NOT THE OLY
STATE IN THIS IN THIS SITUATION
MANY MANY OTHER STATES HAVE
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM BUT WELL. THE
FEDERAL LEVEL HAS NOT SPENT
MONEY ON MODERNIZATIONS FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS. SO
THAT'S WHY SO MANY. A I AND
INSTALLATION. IF I COULD DOWN
ON THAT JUST FOR A MINUTE I'M
IN STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE AND I'M
NOT AN EXPERT I YOUR IT
SYSTEMS BUT I KNOW SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. IF INFORMATION ON
PAST CLIMATE HISTORY IN SALARY
IS THERE IN THE SYSTEM AND
WE'VE GOT ENGINEERS THAT ARE
CODING A SPECIFIC SOLUTION TO
THIS NEW FEDERAL STRUCTURE HOW
COULD A TAKE US TWENTY WEEKS TO
DEPLOY THAT. ALL OUR- HISTORY
IS IN OUR OLD LEGACY SYSTEM
IT'S NOT IN OUR MODERNIZE
QUESTION- AND SECONDLY WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OF THE DATA- WAGE DATA
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON P.
WAY. WE DON'T OKAY PEEL AWAY
THAT DOES THE FEDERAL
SUPPLEMENT WHAT. ARE WHY DON'T
WE HAVE THE WAY TO. AVOID OKAY.
RIGHT OKAY WELL THAT THAT MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE IT'S NOT LINKED
IN THE SYSTEM BOB OKAY WELL THE
WE COULD TAKE A REST OF THIS
DISCUSSION OFFLINE BUT THE
SOMETHING I'M VERY CONCERNED IT
SOUNDS LIKE. CONCERNED ABOUT
TO. I THINK THAT. THE GOAL OF
OUTRAGE THAT YOU'RE HEARING
TODAY WOULD BE NOTHING COMPARED
WITH. THE LEVEL OF OUTRAGE IF
WE WERE TO TELL THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT WAS GOING TO
TAKE ALMOST HALF A YEAR TO
PROCESS. THEIR FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
SUPPLEMENT SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT- WE'RE GONNA DO IT TO
THINK ABOUT. I AM JUST WE JUST
ONE OTHER THING. BEFORE I A
TIME THAT WORKS I JUST WANT TO
MAKE. COMMENT ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT WAS SAID EARLIER. ABOUT
REALLY A WITH OUR- OFFICES AND
I'D LIKE TO REALLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO VIEW US AS YOUR
PARTNERS. THIS ENDEAVOR BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LOT MORE DIRECT. FACE
TO FACE DAY TODAY CONTACT WITH
OUR CONSTITUENTS THAN YOU DO.
AND WE CAN BE KIND OF YOUR EYES
AND EARS IN OUR DISTRICT CAN
WILL WHEN WE- DO YOU. ARE
ELEVATE IT TO BE SOMETHING
THAT'S TO OUR ATTENTION. AND WE
COULD BE HERE- FOR YOUR
PARTNERS IN HELPING TO SOLVE
ITSELF I HOPE YOU WILL VIEW
THAT AS AN ADVERSE REAL
RELATION. BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WE CAN. BUT ALL YOUR- THE
PARTNERSHIP AND I'M A WE WERE
WITH THE STAFF EVERY DAY ALL
AND IT'S BEEN A HAD BEEN A VERY
GREAT PART AND WE HAVE BEEN A
LAW THE LEADS ACROSS AND WE
RELATIONS SO. PART MISSION IS
AREA. THANK MISTER CHAIR OF. MS
SO IT THERE IS THERE SEVERAL
THAT I TO GO AND FIVE MINUTES
ISN'T GOING TO BE ENOUGH SO
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT I AM A MY STAFF AND
PREPARED BUT IT IS A QUESTIONS
THAT I'D LIKE TO GET TO YOU.
AND THE AND I APPRECIATE A
TIMELY RESPONSE- TO ALL THE
QUESTIONS AS WELL BECAUSE I'D
LIKE TO POST THESE RESPONSES
BACK ON MY WEBSITE SO THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS CAN SEE- COULD GET
A SENSE OF BOTH THE ENORMITY OF
THE ISSUES AS WELL AS GIVEN THE
PARENTS IN THE NATION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THEY GET TO SEE
HOW THE INNER WORKINGS OF
GOVERNMENT ARE- SECOND AND I
APPRECIATE SUPPORTING MR DATE
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER ELISE BILL
OF I. THIS CALL THAT AGAIN I
THINK THIS WAS BROUGHT UP FOR A
CHAIR CAN TO HOLD HEARINGS I'M
HAPPY TO FLY UP OR DO IT
THROUGH OF ANY TYPE OF A SECURE
WEB SYSTEM OF MAYBE WE NEED TO
HAVE THESE HEARINGS EVERY TWO
WEEKS SIS BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
WE CAN GET THERE FIRST YEAR BUT
SEE IN OCCASION. TWO OF SO
MISTER CHAIR I LEAVE THAT TO
YOU I DO HOPE THAT YOU CONSIDER
THAT. A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
THAT I WILL JUST ASK RIGHT NOW
AT LEAST ARE HOW MANY EDT
REPRESENTATIVES ARE WORKING THE
PHONE LINES MONDAY THROUGH
FRIDAY EIGHTY AM TO TWELVE PM
YOU HAVE A SPECIFIC NUMBER.
RIGHT NOW ON THAT LINE WE HAVE
A HUNDRED. OUT OF A TOTAL WILL
BE DIRECTED. AND THEN WE HAVE
ALMOST ELEVEN HUNDRED ON THE
OTHER LINE WITH ANOTHER SEVEN
HUNDRED TO BE ADDED BY THE END
OF THIS WEEK. AND ARE FULLY
TRAINED. SO A HUNDRED PEOPLE
BETWEEN EIGHT AM TO TWELVE PM
WE'RE TAKING ALL THE GENERAL
CALLS. AND THEN SEVEN HUNDRED
THAT ARE FROM EIGHT AM TO EIGHT
PM. ONCE A WEEK RIGHT ONCE
THAT'S THAT'S A ONCE A WEEK
PROGRAM. CORRECT SO FROM A WELL
WE HAVE A HUNDRED
REPRESENTATIVE RIGHT FROM-
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
BY THE END OF THIS WEEK WILL
HAVE. AND. ELEVEN WELL I A
COUPLE. BUT WHAT DO YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW I THINK
THIS IS THERE IS ASKING NOT
NEXT WEEK RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
LOT OF HUNDRED AND BY THE END
OF THE WEEK WILL HAVE- PLUS
THERE'S- EIGHT. YEAH AND THAT'S
FIVE DAYS A WEEK I THOUGHT THE
PROGRAM WAS ONLY ONE DAY. SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
OKAY WHAT'S THE AVERAGE TIME-
PER CALL. FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ANSWERING CALLS
BETWEEN EIGHT AM TO TWELVE PM
AND INDIVIDUALS ANSWERING CALLS
BETWEEN EIGHT AM TO EIGHT PM.
ABOUT EIGHT TO TEN MINUTES. FOR
WHICH ONE. BOTH FOR BOTH ONE IS
TECHNICAL THE OTHER ONE DOESN'T
THINK SO TECHNICAL SO WHICH ONE
TO EXPAND. PEOPLE CALL ALL THE
DIFFERENT LINE SO EVEN THOUGH
WE HAVE HER CREDIT SEGREGATE
WHICH LINE- OUR CUSTOMER DO
BOTH OF THEM ENTERTAINED
CHANGER BILLY. SO IT REALLY
DOESN'T MATTER WHICH ONE AND
THEY CALL IT THE SAME SERVICES
BEING OFFERED AND- THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME.OKAY SO TELL ME
THIS ON A DAILY BASIS RIGHT NOW
HOW MANYPEOPLE REPORT TO WORK
AT EDT. RIGHT NOW. LET ME RIGHT
YEAH ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND. EXCEPT BETWEEN
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE TODAY REPORT TO
WORK AND OF THAT. A HUNDRED
PEOPLE ARE ON THE PHONES. IN
THE MORNINGS. BETWEEN EIGHT TO
TWELVE AND THEN CURRENTLY SEVEN
HUNDRED ARE ON ANOTHER SET OF
PHONE LINES. THIS ACCURATE.
220-011-8000 PEOPLE REPRESENTS
MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ARE
WORK MORE SERVICES PROGRAM ARE
DISABILITY INSURANCE PROGRAM
ARE TAX PROGRAM AND ON A POINT
WHERE RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THOSE
PROGRAMS THIS UNEMPLOYMENT WE-
WELL PEOPLE. I UNDERSTAND THAT
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ALSO AT A TIME WHERE MORE
PEOPLE NEED TO BE DEPLOYED ONTO
THESE PHONE LINES IN ORDER TO
CALM AND ADDRESS THE ISSUES.
YOU HAVE US YOU'VE HAD A- YEAH.
AND THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING EVERY DAY WE HAVE PEOPLE
ROLLING OUT OF TRAINING EVERY
DAY INTO A CALL CENTER. SO DOES
IT. THANK YOU OUT OF THE
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED TO EIGHT
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES EDT HAS
TODAY. HOW MANY OF THEM ARE NEW
HIRES WITHIN THE LAST THREE
MONTHS FOUR MONTHS. OR MOVED
SINCE MARCH. UP MARCH ABOUT
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND YOU'RE
GONNA BE HIRING ANOTHER FOUR
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED OR YOU
HAVE APPROVAL. HELP ME OUT. IN
A MINUTE WE'VE ALREADY HAVE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COMMITTED TO
THE JOB OFFERS SO THEY'RE
COMING ON BOARD EVERY DAY SOME
ARE ALREADY BEEN IN TRAINING
SUMMER STARTING TRAINING-
SUMMER PROJECTED TO BE IN
TRAINING IN A FEW WEEKS AND
WHEN THEY COME FORWARD SO WE
HAVE. TO HELP ME THEY WERE
HAVING PEOPLE START INTO OUR
TRAINING SESSION. NINE BUT SO
THERE GONNA BE FOUR THOUSAND
SOME HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS THAT
IN ADDITION TO THE EGGS
EXISTING EIGHT THOUSAND. SAID
ACCURATE OTHER OTHER FIFTY
THREE HUNDRED. FORTY SEVEN
HUNDRED ARE APPROVED TO HIGHER
SO THEY- WERE READY TO BRING
THEM ON AND- GET THEM GOING SO
THAT WE- BROUGHT ON ABOUT TWO
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. AND THE
RAM DOOR FIGURE OUT THERE START
DATE THINKING AMENDED TRAINING.
SO OF THE FIFTY THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ALREADY ON
BOARD WHICH MEANS ANOTHER
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED YOUR YOUR
EMPLOYEE BASE SHOULD BE
EXPANDING BY ANOTHER TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED. CORRECT. YEAH
CORRECT OKAY I'M TRYING TO THE
DIRECTION BECAUSE WE ARE LOSING
PEOPLE EVERY DAY AS WELL THANK
YOU SO. I UNDERSTAND THAT I'M
TRYING TO GET TO PACIFIC
NUMBERS BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S
THE ONLY THING THAT WE CAN RELY
ON. DATA IS THE ONLY THING THAT
WE CAN RELY ON AND I'VE BEEN
PART OF THIS COMMITTEE. FOR
EIGHT YEARS NOW I'VE HAD THE
HONOR OF ALSO SERVING AS CHAIR
IN FACT YOU'VE HAD YOU HAVE
THREE CHAIRS WHO BETWEEN MR
DALY MYSELF AND THE CURRENT
CHAIR. I GOTTA SAY IT. TAKES ME
TO NO END WHEN WE'VE AT
QUESTION IS YEARS AND WE'VE
GOTTEN. OF NOT TO RISK SAYS. AN
THOSE WOULD THE GOOD TIMES
DURING THE TIMES WHERE WE
ASSUMEDLY HER LEARNED FROM OUR
MISTAKES DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION WE HAD A ELEVEN YEAR
PERIOD TO RECOVER AND MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS TO MAKE
THE CHANGES NECESSARY SO THAT
WE WOULD NOT. THIS AT. BEEN
YOU'VE BEEN. PART OF THIS YOU
ARE THIS INSTITUTION YOU'VE HAD
A CAREER FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
WITH THIS INSTITUTION IF ANYONE
KNOWS THE DETAILS OF HOW TO
RECONSTRUCT WHERE THE FAULTS
ARE WHERE THE ISSUES ARE. HOW
TO MANEUVER CHANGE EFFECTIVE
CHANGE WITH APPROPRIATE
INCISION NOT JUST TAKE A SLEDGE
HAMMER BUT WITH THE APPROPRIATE
INCISION IT'S YOU. I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOU AND THAT'S WHY
I'VE BEEN THIS FALL THE
CHAMPION OVER- BENEFIT SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION PROJECT THAT
WERE- GOING TO BE- IN OCTOBER
AWARDING A VENDOR BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THE THAT THE- THAT
WE'VE HAD OVER THE YEARS WITH.
THE WHOLE TIME YOUR WIFE SYSTEM
THAT ARE MEANT IS MISTER
LANGUAGE THE SELLER WITH GREAT
LEVEL OF RESPECT I WOULD NEVER
FIGHT WAS IN YOUR MISSION I
NEVER USE THE WORD CHAMPION.
BECAUSE THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE
CASE FOR EDT RIGHT NOW. I CAN'T
EVEN BEGIN TO DESCRIBE HOW
FRONT BUT I AM THAT YEAH JUST.
TO YOUR IN YOUR COMMENT SAID
NINETY. WHEN MIL. THREE BECAUSE-
TOTALING FIFTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. JUST A LETTER. ISSUED
YESTERDAY JULY TWENTY NINTH YOU
SAY. BETWEEN MARCH EIGHTH AND
JULY EIGHTEENTH WE PROCESS
EIGHT POINT SEVEN MILLION
CLAIMS AND DISTRIBUTED FORTY
FORTY NINE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS I'M NOT TRYING TO. I'M
NOT TRYING TO BE TO BE THAT
THAT- BUT WITHIN A DAY. YOU'RE
TELLING ME THAT YOU WERE ABLE
TO PUT TOGETHER DATA THAT
REFLECTED SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CASES. DO YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
ABSURD THAT. ABOUT EVERY THIRD
DAY MA'AM DO YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
ABSURD THAT SOUNDS TO ALL OF US
THOUGH. THAT WEEKLY DATA COMES
OUT EVERY THIRD DAY. MAYBE YOU
THINK BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR TO ISSUE WEEKLY
STATISTICS WHICH WE DO. I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT DO YOU SEE
HOW BAD IT LOOKS WHEN YOU'RE
PRODUCING NUMBERS. THAT ARE
DIFFERENT BY A HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS WITHIN A DAY. TWENTY
FOUR HOUR PERIOD SAW YOU SIT ST
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
HEARING NINE POINT THREE
MILLION CLAIMS WERE TOTALING
FIFTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AND
YESTERDAY'S LETTER SUGGESTS
THAT. POINT SEVEN BILLION CLAIM
TOTALING FORTY NINE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. POINT IN TIME
FOR PAYING OUT BENEFITS EVERY
MOMENT SO IT'S JUST A POINT OF
TIME BUT THE OFFICIAL NUMBERS
ARE WHAT WE PUBLIC. EVERY
THURSDAY. I WOULD JUST VERY
MUCH OF. I WOULD KINDLY ASK
THAT OR CHAIR DOES CONSIDER
HAVING THESE HEARINGS WITH YOU
AND WITH THE TOP EXECUTIVE
LEVEL INDIVIDUALS. EIGHT EIGHT
IF POSSIBLE TO WEEK BASIS SO
THAT WE CAN GET CLARITY AND
CONTINUOUS NUMBERS SO THAT WE
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON BECAUSE- HAVING
THESE HEARINGS ON A- SIX MONTH
BASIS JUST DOES NOT MEAN MUCH
THERE'S- UNFORTUNATELY THAT
WOULD THAT'S WHAT LENDS ITSELF.
FOR US TO GET DIFFERENT SETS OF
NUMBERS AND BE LOST IN THE
ENORMITY OF ALL OF THIS THAT'S
NOT WHAT I WANT. I WANT TO SEE
CLARITY I DO AGREE TRANSPARENCY
IN COMMUNICATION SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO A MUCH MORE ROBUST
AND A QUICK FREQUENCY BASED BUT
COMMUNITY. YOU MEMBERS. WHICH
LACKEY. YES THANK YOU- IT SEEMS
LIKE SINCE OUR OUR OUR MEETING
IN MAY THERE HASN'T BEEN A LOT
MORE THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US. OUR
CONFIDENCE IN DD I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT. THINGS ARE VERY VERY
CRISIS DRIVEN RIGHT NOW THIS IS
A LIFE CONSUMING SO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I HAVE PEOPLE MY
DISTRICT OFFICE WHO HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT TO TEARS AND I'M
TELLING YOU THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TALKING ABOUT. HAVING
THEIR LAST SERVING OF RAMAN
LIVING IN THEIR CARS AND THESE
ARE PEOPLE WE LIVE WITH. AND SO
THE IF IT THAT'S A LITTLE
FRUSTRATION IT'S BEEN THAT THIS
SERVER REAL TO SIGN UP IT SEEMS
LIKE. MAYBE IT. UBER TO MANY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO- ARE IN YOUR
CIRCLE BUT LET ME JUST ASK YOU
FIRST OF ALL- FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANY
BENEFITS WILL THEY STILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EVEN ALL THAT SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
LA IS. FOUND ELIGIBLE- ANY
PAYMENT THAT WAS DUE- DURING
THE TIME IT WAS ELIGIBLE THEY
WILL GET THAT MONEY. SO THEY
WILL NOT BE HARMED IF FOR
WHATEVER REASON THEY WHAT I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO FILE AND
OTHER CLAIM PROCESS. FINALLY
OKAY THANK YOU- MY OFFICE HAS
NEARLY A TWO HUNDRED UNRESOLVED
DDD CLAIMS THAT WERE ASSISTING-
WITH WITH THEIR CONSTITUENTS
AND SOME DATING BACK TO SPRING
AND I MENTIONED LAST TIME THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO CHAT QUICKLY SO
PROP WE'RE EXTREMELY WITH OUR
THE HANG. I HASN'T BEEN ANY
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AT
ALL- OF BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL
HAPPENING. SO I'M NOT SURE
EXACTLY THE PACIFIC IF YOU WANT
TO SEND ME IF THERE'S A
SPECIFIC ISSUE WE CAN LOOK INTO
IT- BUT IN GENERAL I THINK YOU
KNOW WE TALK TO. WE'VE BEEN
PLAYING. WE'RE GOING TO. A
ENGINEER AND DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WERE
DEPLOYING. AGAIN WHEN THE
STRIKE FORCE COMES THE STRIKE
TEAM. I THINK WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL WILL BE RE LOOKING
AT EVERYTHING THAT WE LOOKED AT
AND SEE IF THERE'S MORE
OPPORTUNITIES AT. A LATER TIME.
I CERTAINLY HOPE TO SPUR FORCE.
AS GOOD AS OUR HOPE TO BE
BECAUSE THEY ARE WE GIVING
QUITE A BURDEN HERE-
CONSTITUENTS OF ALSO CALLED
EIGHTY. THE HELP LINE AND WE'RE
TOLD THAT. THEY SHOULD CALL
THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS HELP OF
THEIR CLAIM WE LOVE BEING A
PART. BUT NOT PART OF THE
INSTRUCTION PROCESS. FIVE I'M
SORRY THAT HAVE HAPPENED OUT
CLEAR A COUPLE TIMES WITH THEIR
STAFF MAKE SURE THAT THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE AT
THAT NOT OUR POLICY. OKAY THIS
WILL TALK ABOUT THE STRIKE
FORCE BEING OBVIOUSLY HAVE SOME
GOOD RESULTS FORTY FIVE DAYS
FROM NOW BUT YET THAT TAKES SIX
MONTHS INTO IT BUSINESSES IN
EARLIER YOU IN THEIR THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS WHAT COULD TRY
FORCED YOU SHOULD KNOW ALREADY.
THE THIRTY SEVEN PLAY OF EASY
DEAR THIS. WELL YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY BRING SOMETHING NEW
TO THE TABLE I THINK I
MENTIONED THE BEGINNING THAT
WE'VE BEEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
EDT OD I OFTEN. OF FROM THE
BEGINNING AND JUST HAVING THEM
PART DURING THE LAST FIVE FOR
FIVE MONTHS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DEPLOY A ADDITIONAL SOFTWARE AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE- WE HAD NOT
BEEN EXPOSED TO SO I AM HOPING
THAT YOU KNOW WE- AROUND. WORK
MIND THAT WOULD CAN AT ON EVEN
MORE. MR TING. THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU DIRECTOR HELLER FOR-
JOINING US TODAY I JUST REALLY
WANTED TO JUST THANK ALL OF THE
ALL ALL MY COLLEAGUES. I THINK
ONE HEARING. YOU ARE NOT A VERY
ACCURATE SNAPSHOT OF MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE FACE AND I
THINK AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LANCASTER THAT'S ABOUT THESE
ARE. VERY REPEAL PEOPLE ON WALL
THEY- ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE TRACKING I
EACH OF THOSE NUMBERS HAVE.
PERCENT SAID THEY CALL OUR
STOPS BEFORE EIGHTY. BECAUSE
NOW THAT MUCH FOR AS MANY MORE
STUFF TO WORKING AT HOME THE
FLANK AFFORDED TO WHERE THEY
ARE. SO BIG GET OFF BEFORE
EIGHT AM TO GET CALLS AFTER
EIGHT PM. ON SINCE WE AGAIN WE
WERE WE ARE ABSOLUTELY HAPPY.
TO CONTINUE TO BE YOUR PARTNERS
BUT I THINK. ON DIALOGUE WITH
OFFICES IN YOUR OFFICE HAVE
IMPROVED BUT THEY'RE STILL A
NUMBER OF SUGGESTIONS THAT
CONTINUED TO. AND OUT THERE I
WOULD JUST REITERATE FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR WHO
MENTIONED THIS TECHNOLOGY ISSUE
OF THIS TECHNOLOGY ISSUE WAS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THE- IS THAT
OUR OFFICE CONTINUES TO. WHICH
IS. IN THAT WE HAVE A DUAL
SYSTEM FOR SUBMITTING
DOCUMENTATION WE HAVE A DIGITAL
SYSTEM FOR VERY FIND THE
IMITATION.OR IS THAT MANY OF
THE- OLDER BACKLOG CASES
EXTENDS BACK TO THE ABILITY TO.
VERIFY IDENTIFICATION TO VERIFY
DOCUMENTS SO WITH THE STRIKE
TEAM COMING IN OCTOBER. I GUESS
WINDY AND HIS A. B. YOU. HELLO
MORE STREAM THE WHICH TO VERIFY
DOCUMENTS WHICH APPEAR TO BE
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS MOST OF
MANY OF OUR BACK LAW CASES SEEM
TO HAVE- IDENTIFICATION
VERIFICATION CHAO. RIGHT WE'RE
LOOKING TO DEPLOY THE UPLOAD-
DOWN FOR DOCUMENTS IN SEPTEMBER
WHICH WILL HELP ACT- EXPEDITE
THE PROCESS FROM THE CUSTOMER
AND IT DOES PROVIDE EFFICIENCY
IN OUR- OUR PROCESSING AS WELL.
SO THAT IS OUR HIGHEST. I D.
EFFORT THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
RIGHT AND LIKE I SAID WE'RE
LOOKING TO DEPLOY IT IN
SEPTEMBER. AND SINCE YOU
DISSIPATE HOPEFULLY. BEING ABLE
TO GOLD LIVE WITH THAT TYPE OF
FROM. APPLICATION IN SEPTEMBER.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY ONE ONE OF OUR
NUMBER ONE INITIATIVES RIGHT
NOW THAT THAT'S WONDERFUL JUST
A FULL FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO HOME HE HE
MENTIONED THAT MANY MUCH OF THE
FOLLOW UP IN A AND THIS IS FOR
ME OUR OLDER CASES HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
DOCUMENTATION OR INACCURATE OF.
HAS BEEN SUBMITTED HIS TO GET
VERIFIED- IN WHEN I THINK
YOU'RE ASKING A QUESTION. I'M
THIS LIKE GO DIRECT PROCESS
FIVE DA. SNOWY FOR PHONE OR
LETTER THAT COMES BACK TO ME TO
SAY. YOU NEED TO RESUBMIT THIS
DOCUMENT THIS DOCUMENT THE
STOCK. SORRY WE DO WE
DEFINITELY SEND CORRESPONDENCE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
EVERYTHING- THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS BUT DEFINITELY TO THE
UPLOAD PROCESS ONCE WE HAVE
THAT THE PLACE WILL BE ACCEPTED
A BETTER. IRAN IN SEPTEMBER
THAN WHAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
WHICH IS ANTIQUATED NIGHT
TOTALLY AGREE SO OR LOOKING
FORWARD TO IT. BOB RIGHT NOW.
YOU YOU MAY SEND A LETTER
SAYING HEY YOUR DOCUMENTATIONS
INCOMPLETE BUT YOU ACTUALLY
SPECIFY WHAT DOCUMENTS NEED TO
BE RESUBMITTED OR VERIFIED.
GOOD FOLLOW UP LETTER MOST
DEFINITELY. I'M SORRY COULD YOU
SAY THAT AGAIN DIRECTOR. THANK
YOU ONE WAY SEND OUT A FOLLOW
UP LETTER AND ABOUT THE BY.
OKAY THANK YOU. ONE ONE
QUESTION FROM MY- MY DISTRICT
OFFICE WAS ALSO NOW THAT WE'RE
ENTERING. CAN WE START CASE OF
PEOPLE APPLY TO MAC HAVE
RECEIVED BENEFITS. IT IS.
CERTAINLY NEED THE CURRENT
HARDSHIP PROFIT ABOUT THE PRO
THE PENDING ON WITH SAID. BUT
YOU'RE MORE WELCOME SET FORTH
ANY. PEARL THANK YOU AND
THERE'S NO LIMIT ON THE
HARDSHIP REFERRAL. IN AND THEN
AND LAST THREE COLUMNS BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOUR-
YOU'VE BEEN SAYING ORGANIZED
WITHIN THE TERM HAS SAYING THAT
THERE ARE THE DO ATTEMPT TO
CALL- PEOPLE UP TO NINE TIMES.
ON AS WE KIND OF GET FEEDBACK
MORE CONSTITUENTS IT FEELS LIKE
IT'S MAYBE ONE OR TWO CALLS- I
THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS
ARRIVE I FULLY RESPECT THIS IS
THAT- DO YOU ATUALLY. CALL
FROM AN ON BLOCKS NUMBER OR
FIGURE OUT HOW TO CALL FROM A
BLOCKED NUMBER FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
PEOPLE CALL ME LAW I DE. LOS
THE CAPITAL. I DON'T. AND I
KNOW A LOT PEOPLE DON'T PICK
ACOSTA BLOOM IDEAS SO THAT THAT
YOU BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS
DROPPING THAT RIGHT NOW YES
THAT HAVE BEEN A CHALLENGE WITH
THAT BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE MAKING
ALL THESE CALLS OUT AND PEOPLE
ARE ANSWERING THEIR CALL. THEIR
OWN. BEEN WORKING ON VERIZON'S
THAT OUR HOPE PEOPLE ARE HOPING
TO BE ABLE TO ROLL IT OUT VERY
STAND. ALTHOUGH IF YOU NEED
HELP WITH. WE CAN HELP YOU
THERE TOO. SEC I THINK MY- IN
MY COLLEAGUES COVERED A GREAT
RANGE OF WHAT WE- HEALTH
CONCERNS WITH I DEFINITELY DO
AGREEWITH. MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WITHIN JUST A PERHAPS WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE HAVING
HEARINGS- MORE FREQUENTLY TO
REALLY STAND TOP THIS ISSUE AS
FEEL THAT WHEN THE HEARINGS
CALM THINGS TO BE. UP TAKE IN
RESPONSE. FORTUNE IT SHOULD BE
NATURALLY OCCURRING IN THE AB
IN THE FLOW OF THE DISCUSSION-
JUST. ACTUALLY FORCES US TERM
PUSH AUSTIN SCHEDULE MORE
HEARINGS HICH I DON'T THINK
IS- ALWAYS THE BEST WAY TO
COMMUNICATE I THINK COULD BE
JUST A KID AND- NOT FASHION
MEETINGS AND- SHOULD PROCESSES.
SO THE IS NOT BASED ON THE- YOU
GOT A FROM THIS HEARING BUT
ALSO IN THE REGULAR
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR OFFICES
THAT WE DE MANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS AND MANY OF THESE
ISSUES START TO BE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I DON'T WE
CAN MEET WITH ALL THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS EVERY
OTHER FRIDAY. AND THAT'S BEEN
EXTRA. AND ADELINE KANE ANY
KIND OF COMMUNICATION THAT YOU
THINK IS THAT WHATEVER VALUE
NOT NOT NOT NOT WE DO THANK YOU
FOR THAT I KNOW OF MY DISTRICT.
IS ON THOSE. EVERY EVERY TWO
WEEKS AND THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
HELPFUL SO THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT. THANK YOU. WE'RE HOPING
UP TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY SO I
WOULD ALSO QUEUE UP THE-
HEARING ROOM IN VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM IF YOU HAVE.
THEY'RE SO I'M IN I SEE NO WAS
SPEAK HERE- SO THIS WILL GO TO
OUR- HEARING ROOM IN VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. AND THE
FOLKS THERE THAT WAS TO MAKE
COMMENT. NONE OKAY- IF WE GO TO
OUR- DIAL IN OUR PHONE FOLKS
OPERATOR YOU THERE. YES WE ARE
HERE. RELATED IN JIM IF YOU DO
WANT TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST WILL COME
FROM THE LINE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
COKE AND I AM JUST REPRESENTING
MYSELF I'M ASSUMING YOU CAN
HEAR ME YES CORRECT GOODNESS
COPELAND. RELIGIOUS FIRST HOLD
ON YES MA'AM REAL WOMEN OUR
SPEAKERS TO ONE MINUTE PLEASE
ONE MINUTE. IN FIVE. OKAY I'LL
TRY TO DO WHAT I CAN EXPECTING
FIVE HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY COMMENTS I WANT TO
START OUT BY SAYING THAT IT
CAUSES ME GREAT STRESS EVEN
FIGURE OUT AGAIN I'M HARPER.
I'M THINKING ABOUT THE
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA CENTER. OF THE
FUNCTION OF EDT WHY INITIALLY
FELT THE PATHETIC FOR THE
ORGANIZATION I'VE I UNDERSTAND
HOW UNDERSTAFFED THEY MUST HAVE
BEEN AT THE TIME OF THE CRISIS.
CAME ABOUT THE SYMPATHY CLEAR
WROTE IT. FOR MY INITIAL OUT
REDUCE THE EDT CONSISTED OF
TWENTY SIX HOURS ON HOLD ONLY
THE REPRESENTATIVE HANG UP ON
ME AFTER THEY DID NOT KNOW. MY
QUESTION THIS IS NOT ONLY
HAPPENED ONE. ALL THE- YOU MAY
NOW I HAVE BROKEN DOWN. I'M NOT
ME IN ANYTHING WAS ON THE PHONE
ONLY HAVE A GREAT ANSWER AND
HANG UP A MATTER SECONDS OUT
WHO. ANYTHING A- IT COULD
BECAME A- THAT THE RIGHT.
DURING THE FALL A DIFFERENT.
MAKE INFORMATION I BEEN TOLD
NEW PLAYING THAT AREN'T CORRECT.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS I UP
DEDICATING A- TWO. HOURSOF MY
LIFE OVER THE COURSE OF EIGHT
WEEK- I TO CONTACT EDT FOR
ALTERNATIVE. MEANS AND ALSO
READ. RETAIN UNEMPLOYMENT THE
DOCTOR ON A ASSISTANCE WHICH
POLITE MODELED AFTER. PDAS
DECISION WHETHER YOU AYE A. B.
ADDITIONALLY I'VE SPOKEN AT THE
LAST THREE MONTHLY IF YOU AYE
A. B. MEETINGS AS WELL AND YES
MY APPEAL TO THE FEW AYE AB
RESULTED IN A LOW DOWN I KEEP.
MY FAVOR HOWEVER FORTY EIGHT
DAYS LATE EIGHTIES HAS NOT OF
MY ACCOUNT ACCORDING TO WHAT
THE A- RULED ON IN MY CASE. AND
I HAVE A- I WANTED. BUT
PROBABLY A MINUTE I TOOK MY TO
LEAVE YOU A FEW. THOUGHTS I
UNDERSTAND THAT PARTICULAR IF
IS AN ISSUE OF THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BUT ISN'T. A HYBRID
WORKERS. PENALIZED FOR BEING
ABLE OFTEN AND- EMPLOYED THERE
FULL INCOMES. AND CALCULATING
THEIR- YET. BOTH THE ONLY. ALL
WOULD BE TO HAPPEN PAY THE THAT
THEY- FOR BY THE U. I. SYSTEM
THE REMAINS BY FEDERAL WHO WAS
THEM. THIS WAY EACH AT THEIR
FAIR SHARE. I THOUGHT. IT THE
YOU FOR CALLING AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OPPORTUNITY. I HOPE
YOU. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
LINE SO. ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THANK YOU HELLO AND HELLO
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. MY NAME IS TRACY
AND GROW AND I WORK FOR EDT.
AND WHAT I DO FOR YA IS I AT
CALIFORNIANS NOW OFTEN
CONFUSING YOU LIKE THIS THEM BY
FILING CLAIMS FOR THEM AND
ANSWERING THEIR QUESTIONS
TRYING TO REASSURE THEM THAT
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE
FAMILY. AT THE JOB. I YOUR
FRUSTRATION YOUR THEM
EVERYTHING FOR. AND MANY OF MY
COLOR INCLUDE MIKE THOUGH. HAVE
TO TAKE GRAY. TO GO AWAY AND A
FEW TEARS WHEN WE HEAR THE
HEARTBREAKING STORY. FROM OTHER
CALIFORNIA EITHER NOT. ON THE-
IS THERE ARE AND BE THERE ARE
FAMILY THE PEOPLE WE KNOW WE
UNDERSTAND THE STORY THAT WE
FEEL THEM DEEPLY- MANY TIMES AS
AN APR WE'RE- ABLE TO DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO WITH THE CLAIM.
STATED TECH. I'M ON WHAT WE ARE
ALLOW TO DO WE DIDN'T WE ARE
NOT IN POWER EVEN IF WE HAVE
THE SKILL SET. TO DO WHAT IS
NEEDED. HELP OUR CLAIM IT AND
IT CAN MAKE A PAYMENT TO OUR
CLAIM AT AND CAN HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THAT BACK WHILE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION. PEOPLE PASS WE- SHARE
THEM BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
WHILE IT IS EASY TO GO TO. AND
I THINK ABOUT I'M THANK YOU
THAT. THING ALL THIS OTHER. THE
RANGE FILE I AM ALSO. AT THE
ARE YOU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND WE
HAVE BEEN SCREENING FOR UPDATED
TECHNOLOGY MORE THING FOUR YEAR
AND OUR OUR PLEASE HAVE FALLEN
ON DEAF EARS. MORE BANKING AND
WE NEED AN IN DEPTH. I HE FOR
EATING AND WE ALSO NEED A PLACE
AT THE TABLE AND DETERMINING
THAT- TECHNOLOGY. RANK AND FILE
MEMBERS WHO ARE ON THE FLOOR
DOING THE- HI YOU'RE NODDING.
IN THAT CONVERSATION AND WHEN
THOSE CONTRACT OR WORDED AND AT
NEW SOFTWARE IS ROLLED OUT WE
OFTEN FIND IT DOES NOT WORK
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WITH. THAT
DID NOT DIG IN AND WE HAVE IT
DIDN'T WORK WHICH RESULT AND
THAT'S THAT WOULD MENTION
EARLIER THAT THE GOVERNOR TO
INTERVENE IN ORDER PRESS. AS
RANKING. THAT ARE ASKED DOING
THE WORK WE NEED A PLACE AT
THAT TABLE TO HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO WHAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY YOU'RE PLANNING.
THAT TIME TODAY THANK YOU THIS
CALL UP. THE NEXT CALLER IS
LINE TWENTY THREE. LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES GOING TO OKAY SO I'VE GOT A
TIME I'M GONNA SAY INTERNET THE
PROBLEM I JUST WANTED TO
ATTENTION TO A FEW THINGS-
FIRST CANNOT. RELATION TO A
CALIFORNIA VERY SOON SO SOME-
OUTSIDE POINT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T OF THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
BENEFITS SYSTEM- I WOULD AT
LEAST TALK TO THE STRIKE FORCE
TO POINT THAT OUT OF ALL- IN
GENERAL I JUST. EIGHTY FAILED
AND PEOPLE HAVE TO WAIT MONTHS
I'VE HAD THE WAIT APRIL
NINETEENTH OTHER NON COMES AT
THAT TIME- BARBER SHOPS FOR
EXAMPLE PRINTED UP PROTECTING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO INCOME
LOOK AT BECOMES A PUBLIC HEALTH
COMPONENT- I'LL FOCUS TRIPS
FOUGHT FRAUD PREVENTION IS SORT
OF A PROBLEM OF THE DEPRESSION.
DEPRESSION YOU. AND WE GOT FROM
BACK AND- I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OURS A PRIEST YOUR I PERSIST
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE TOPIC ESQUE
SITUATION WITH THE CALL
CENTERS- IT IT'S BEEN QUITE A
PROBLEM YEAH I CALLED AT LEAST
FIFTY OF SOMETIMES A HUNDRED
TIMES TRYING TO GET THROUGH ALL
THAT HAVE TO DO IS HAVE PLACE
WE- CAN. YOU CALL BACK AT A
LATER TIME. I'M SURE. NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH IF COLOR PLEASE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE LINE.
FORTY TWO LINE FORTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK MUCH MY NAME IS- CHARLES
TAPED IN THE I'M A RE DIRECTED
STAFF MEMBER WORKING IN ET DE
VIRTUAL CALL CENTER- MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE BEEN.
WORKING SIGNIFICAN ALL THE TIME.
THE CULTURAL. TWELVE HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING HARDTO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS GET THE
BENEFITS THEY NEED. WE WANT TO
AGAIN SURE THAT UNDER STAFFING
ON OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY REALLY
STANDS IN THE WAY OF THE BE.
PROVIDING THE BEST CUSTOMER
SERVICE PARTICULARLY DURING
THIS TIME OF CRISIS. THE
SOLUTION IS THAT THE FUNDING
WILL BE DOING EXPAND THE STAFF
AND INVESTMENT SYSTEMS THAT CAN
BE MANAGED BY ACTUAL EATING BE
EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU ON THIS
CALL PLEASE. OUR NEXT ONLINE IS
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS ONE FORTY JOANNE
D'ANTONIO VALLEY GLENN. HOW
MOST OF US WERE EMPLOYED FOR
YEARS BEFORE COVERED OR NOT
USED TO THE ISLAND AND SYSTEM
I'VE BEEN LIVING. IN A CONSTANT
PEOPLE TRYING TO GET BACK FROM
THAT WILL NOT GET THEM UNLESS
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR ISSUE
IS RESOLVED I GOT MY CLAIM
INITIALLY CERTIFIED IN WHICH
RECEIVING BENEFITS THEN I
EXPERIENCED IN THEIR- EMAIL FOR
ME D. D. I THOUGHT THE EMAIL
WAS ELECTED A PROBLEM MONEY DE.
LAND AND I WAS BEING PAID. TEXT
MESSAGE WOULD HAVE BEEN GREAT
BUT I DON'T THINK EIGHTY DAY
EVER ASKED FOR MY CELL PHONE
NUMBER ONLY MY LAND LINE. I
ENDED UP MISSING SIX WEEKS
BENEFITS FIVE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN DOLLARS. I
SUCCESSFULLY RESTARTED MY CLAIM
ONLINE BUT I NEED A WAY TO GET
TO MISS WEEKES BENEFIT. ET DE
MAY TELL ME I'M NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR THE LAST WEEK TO SAN TO MY
THINK THE- SAVING THOSE SUPPORT
NOTICE FROM EITHER DE. FOR OVER
A MONTH. CAN YOU GET THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM OTHERWISE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WILL BE LEFT OUT OF
REACH READING BACK BENEFITS. IS
THERE WAY THE ASSEMBLY CAN
HELP. EVEN IF I HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET THROUGH. THE DAY. YOU
WERE I TRIED I WOULD BE I WAS
OUT OF WHACK. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT IS LINE FIFTY FIVE LINE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD NEAR
LINES OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE RIGHT I'M ONE OF THE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND. PEOPLE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA I RESIDE IN SAN
DIEGO I FILE MY CLAIM ON MARCH
TWENTY FIRST WHEN MY COMPANY
WAS SHUT DOWN DUE THE PANDEMIC
I'VE HAD TO CALL EVERY WEEK.
WHICH IS TO EIGHTEEN WEEKS TWO
HUNDRED TIMES A DAY. I CALLED
THE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN NUMBER
THAT MISS HILLIARD CLAIM IS
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGED ONLY TO BE
HUNG UP ON FIFTY NINE. I'VE
REACHED THREE HEIGHT AND
WONDERFUL SPECIALIST IN THE
EIGHTEEN WEEK AT THE EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER- THAT WERE ABLE
TO. PAYMENT GREW. I AM I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND DAVID
CHAO AND MISTER LACKEY OR
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS MY
ADVICE. MY FAMILY'S LIFE. AND
IT'S VERY HARD TO HELP FIGHT OR
THINGS THAT I WITH AWARDED OR
ENTITLED TO YOU AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR MY CRYING BUT I'M ANGRY FOR
THE UNDER OTHER EIGHT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE. EIGHT PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING THROUGH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO APOLOGY
NEEDED THANK YOU. OPERATOR
COLOR PLEASE. IS LINE THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YOUR FOR YOUR CALL MY
NAME IS CHAD ADAM. QUESTION AS
I WOULD BELIEVE THAT MY JOB
BACK IN MARCH- FOUND OUT THE.
THERE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT TILL
JULY ARE. DONE EVERYTHING
CERTIFIED- THIS REALLY THE YOU
KNOW THE PROBLEM WITH PEOPLE
NOT PART OF OUR OUR CERTIFIED
WEEKS AGO. CULTURE MY MAC
CERTIFICATION AND STILL NO PLAY
MAN ART SHE SAID THE MOST OF
THE AUTOMATED WHICH I FIND THAT
HARD TO BELIEVE BECAUSE I'M
STILL WAITING ON OUR WAY TO
ALONG WITH THE OTHER PEOPLE
WERE FORTUNATELY. WAITING FOR
THREE. WE ARE STILL WAIT TO SAY
ABOUT HAVE WHO ARE. IN ORDER TO
ROUTE GOING TO TRY. CONTRARY
THAT I'M FAR NOT I HAVE NOT
RECEIVED ANY COMMUNICATION FROM
ATV EVEN SUBMITTED A- MESSAGE
ON. ABOUT A WEEK AGO I WAS IN
THE WEST THERE'S FIVE OF THEM
DAYS TO APPROACH DAY TO. SO
THOUSAND PEOPLE. WAITING FOR
CORY TO BE VERY NOT. I DON'T
CLAIMS PROCESS WHERE IT'S BEEN
IN THE VERY BEGINNING A LOT
THREE WEEKS. THE YOU VERY MUCH
OF ALL OUR THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. THAT IS LINE EIGHT NINE
LINING NINE PLAY GO AHEAD YOUR
OPEN. THANK YOU HEAR ME YES
DON'T. OKAY MY NAME IS MEGAN
HALL- I'VE LIVED IN FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I BECAME
UNEMPLOYED YOU TO CALL THE
NINETEEN ARE ON MARCH
THIRTEENTH. I FILE MY CLAIM
THAT DAY WITH OUR UNEMPLOYMENT-
EDTA AND I AM NOW AT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE DAYS. OF NOT
RECEIVING PAYMENT I WAS
REQUESTED BY EDT DEFENDANT
VERIFICATION OF IDENTITY WHICH
I DID WITH AND THAT TEN DAY
PERIOD THAT THEY A LOT. AND
I'VE BEEN IN LIMBO. I HAVE
CALLED EVERY SINGLE. AND MARCH
THIRTY. OVER TWO HUNDRED A DAY
I'VE BEEN ON HOLD A- OF THIRTY.
OUR WITH EIGHTY D. ALONE JUST
TRYING GET THROUGH ON THEIR
BOTTOM SYSTEM. WE ARE NEXT. AND
GROWTH WE NOW. I AM ON MY RIGHT
AND ALL MY BILL I HAVE A BLANK
FOR AT SEVEN. BUT I CAN BARELY
AFFORD FIFTY. EVERY DAY I READ
OUT FOR THE AND THEY DO PUT IT
BACK AND FURTHER AND- TODAY I
WAS ON HOLD FOR HOURS AND
THIRTY EIGHT MINUTES. THE ONLY
BE COLD BY I WITHOUT THE- VERY
OF CALL. OF THEM INCLUDING.
SOCIAL TO. NUMBER BACK TO WHAT
IT SHOULD BE BECAUSE THE I
GUESS IS. AND IT MIGHT BE IN
FOR THE AND THE- NUMBER WITH
ABSOLUTELY ON OPTICAL. THANK
YOU FOR MY TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT CALL PLEASE. THIS
CALL IS THE FIFTY EIGHT ONE
EIGHT GO AHEAD. HI THERE I MANY
KELLY ANDERSON ABOUT THREE MY
CLAIM WITH RANDOMLY DOWN AFTER
A RECEIVE. TO PAYMENT OUT SINCE
THEN I'VE SINGLE DAY I CALLED
DE DE EIGHT IN THE TRYING TO
GET THROUGH TO SOMEBODY BY NOW.
EIGHTY SHOULD BE PAID MY PHONE
BILL WITH YOUR OF TIME THAT
I'VE BEEN A THE PHONE I BY WAS
ABLE TO GET THROUGH TO SOME
BECAUSE I HAD THE RANDOM IDEA
CALL MY PLAYED DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE. THAT LOCAL THEY CALL ME
TO CALL ASSEMBLY RICHARD BLOOM
I DON'T KNOW WHY BECAUSE A FOR
AN ON AND IS THE PER ANSWERED
WITH VERY ULTIMATELY DID NOT
READ MY- SINCE THEN HAD AND
WERE OF RANDOM NUMBERS TO ME BY
FOR THERE ARE LISTED ON ANY OF
YOUR THAT I'VE HAD TO GO
THROUGH. TO HELLO AND EIGHTEEN
THAT AS THE YESTERDAY MY
PROBLEM IS BEING ON BUT BEEN
THREE MONTHS AND DEEP ON BILL I
THINK THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
IN CHARGE OF US AND. AGAIN YOU
GOT PLENTY OF UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE
WILLING TO TAKE YOUR JOB THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE THIRTY TWO. LINE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU'RE OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU MY NAME IS
WILLIAM CHOI LIVE IN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT EIGHT I'VE CONTACTED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
PERSISTENT BUT THERE STEP OF
EVEN TOLD ME THAT HE DID THE
MORNING RETURN THEIR CALLS SO.
I HAVE NO HOPE THAT THE I CAN
BE REACHED ON MY TRADE HUNDREDS
OF TIMES- LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
TRYING TO CONTACT THEM BUT I
CAN NEVER GET THERE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT REPUTABLE MISTER.
ONLY BUSINESS FOR FOUR HOURS A
DAY THAT'S UTTERLY RIDICULOUS
I'VE EMAILED THEM THROUGH THEIR
WEBSITE- TWO MONTHS AGO AND I
GET A REPLY THAT. I SHOULD
RECEIVE SOMETHING WITHIN SEVEN
DAYS IT'S BEEN TWO MONTHS
ALREADY HEARING FROM- LET'S
LAWYER TODAY I HAVE NO FAITH
THAT I WILL BE ABLE TO COME IN
ONE CALENDAR YEAR. HELLO MY
ISSUE. I HAVE ACTUALLY RECEIVE
BENEFITS BUT I PREVENTED FROM
USING THEM BECAUSE OF AN ISSUE
BETWEEN. ETV IN MY BANK AND I
CAN'T REACH ANYONE TO GET AN
ANSWER ABOUT THIS. SO THE
BENEFITS THEY'RE ON THE CART ON
USE I CAN'T TOUCH THE- MAY. AND
FIRST AS HELL. EXCUSE MY
LANGUAGE- BUT THIS IS JUST THE
TYPICAL. WHAT WE JOKE ABOUT
THINK ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY AND- INEFFICIENCY
IT IT'S- I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS
IS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE EXIST.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE THIRTY THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
I'M RECOUP REPRESENTING MYSELF
I'M A TOURING MUSICIAN AND THAT
MY INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE THE
LAST TO COME BACK. I MEAN ABOUT
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS LAST
YEAR WITH CONTRACT MAKE EVEN
MORE THIS YEAR AND THANK YOU
THANK. THE ATTENDANT. NINE
LITTLE TRACKING DOWN THE BUT I
WAS YEARS OLD BUT I'M BUT THEN
FORTY HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
YEAR WAS USED TO CALCULATE MY
FULL AMOUNT I DO WITH THEIR W.
FROM THE CABLE COMPANY
THEREFORE MIGHT BENEFIT IS
THREE DOLLARS A WEEK. WEEK FIND
MUCH I'M EXHAUSTED ALL MEDICAID
THAT WE NEED FIGURE OUT THIS
EIGHT ALL MIX SIMPLE BURKE IS
BECAUSE IT IS NOT THERE AND
WE'RE BEING PUNISHED FOR NO FOR
HAVING JOBS THAT ARE MIXED- I
WOULD LOVE TO GET THIS RESOLVED
AND I THINK DIRECT WE NEED TO
RELY ON THE IF SUCH A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NOT TO GO TO THE LINES. SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. I
APOLOGIZE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES MA'AM. OKAY HELLO
MY NAME IS CHENEY TURNER- I AM
A OPEN RESIDENTS- SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS- ED THIS.
CALLING BECAUSE I APPLIED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT IN MARCH. I HAVE
YET TO RECEIVE A CHECK LIKE
MANY PEOPLE IN THE FOLDER- I
HAVE SPENT NUMEROUS HOURS- ON
HOLD. TO GET CUT OFF IT HAS GOT.
OTHER COUNTRIES PROVIDED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. TO PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY WHAT DOUBTS PARTY.
WHAT IT BEING EXPOSED IS THAT
CALIFORNIA THAT THE CARE ABOUT
POOR PEOPLE. PEOPLE ARE ON THE
PHONE LITERALLY SAYING THAT
THEY ARE IN DANGER OF LOSING
HOUSING. WE LIVE IN A STATE
THAT HAS ACCEPTED TECHNOLOGY SO
THE FACT THAT THE MADE EXCUSE
THAT HELL YOU'RE USING IS THAT
WE NEED TO GET OUR- IF IT. THE
BOOK AND YOU MAY. WE WILL SEE
IT INCREASE OF HOMELESSNESS
HELLO IF YOU A CRY. IF YOU DO
NOT GET PEOPLE THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY NEED
IMMEDIATELY THIS IS AN ATTACK.
BUT MAINLY FOR. POOR BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALL. THE
COLORS DEALER. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THE LINE IS STILL
CONNECTED YEAH WILL MOVE TO THE
NEXT ONE THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT.
SERVER LAW NINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS- BARBARA
FAIL GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A
PROUD- I'M A PROUD YEAH YOU ARE
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND NUMBER- I
WORKED FOR CALIFORNIA BERMAN
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT NORMALLY
I PROVIDE WORKFORCE. IS A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE- I CALL AND
TODAY- LOCALLY TO JOB. ONE TO
SHARE WHAT IT'S LIKE TO. DURING
THE RECORD LEVEL ON. THE WORK
LOAD FAR EXCEEDS THAT OF THE
GREAT RECESSION LIKE MANY STATE
WORKERS I'VE BEEN RIGHT RE
DIRECTED TO HELP UNEMPLOYMENT
DURING THE- UNPRECEDENTED
CRISIS- WORKING IN A HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED UNIT CALLED WORK
SURE PROVIDING AN ALTERNATIVE
TO LAYOFFS AND- CLOSURES.
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF THAT
STATE'S DROUGHT CALIFORNIA THIS
IS A VERY. OPPORTUNISTIC AN
INCREASE IN WORK SHARE. WHICH
BY THE WAY STILL REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYERS MAILING. BY WEEKLY
PAPERS OUR PROGRAM IS HELPING
TO MAINTAIN A CAMANCHE ECONOMIC
STABILITY FOR EMPLOYERS AND
WORKERS IN SHORING UP
CALIFORNIA- BUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE ARE KIND OF
NEVER FILED BEFORE AND- AND
AREN'T SURE. ABOUT THE PROPER
AND CORRECT ANY INFORMATION
EVEN TOO MUCH INFORMATION
REQUIRE SPECIAL HANDLING BY AND
ONE STOP. SIGNIFICANTLY
DELAYING- PAYMENT OF BENEFITS.
BUT DESPITE THE BOMBARDMENT OF
NEGATIVE SENTIMENT AND PAY CUTS
AND ARE REYES CANTICLE. WE
CONTINUE TO WORK HARD TO
PROVIDE TO PROVIDE BENEFITS TO
DESPERATELY MY COWORKERS AND I
HAVE BEEN WORKING TEN TO
THIRTEEN HOUR DAYS SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK- MANY OF THE CORE
UNEMPLOYMENT YEAH BUT NOT TAKEN
A SINGLE DAY OFF FROM MONTH TO
KEEP PAYMENTS MOVING. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE-
LIFELINE FOR MANY STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS BUT WE ARE
UNDERSTAFFED AND UNDERFUNDED
AND- FACT- FUNDING IS NEEDED
YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN REALLY WORK
SHOULD UNFORTUNATELY IT TOOK
THAT HAVE DAMAGE TO PROVE THAT.
WE KNOW THAT CONTRACTING OUT OF
NOT- ACTUALLY THE QUICK FIX
SOLUTION- WE KNOW THAT THE XIN
IT. PERFORMANCE BY LOW PAID
WORKERS WITH INADEQUATE
TRAINING THE LACK OF EXPERIENCE
IN THAT CREATES AN EVEN GREATER
WORKLOAD FOR TRAIN STOPPED AND
BARELY ADDING TO THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP BUT DISLOCATED WORKERS.
POLLUTION IS TO FULLY FUND AND
DVD AND AMPLIFY TRAINING AND
MENTORING TO RE DIRECTED AND
NEW EMPLOYEES AND EXPAND THAT
THING FUND INVESTMENT IN HOUSE
PROGRAMMING THAT CAN BE
DEVELOPED AND MANAGED BY EDT
EMPLOYEE. WHO HAVE DEPARTMENTAL
KNOWLEDGE AND ARE EXPECTED AND
FIX THAT WHEN NOT TEMPORARY
WORKERS NOT THE ONES THAT IN
AND OUT COME. YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. THAT'S COLOR PLEASE.
THE NEXT ONE IS LINE FORTY FOUR
ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. OKAY MY CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT I DO I DID HAVE AN
EXISTING CLAIMS WHICH DID NOT
EXPIRE UNTIL THE END OF MAY I
DID NOT LOSE MY JOB TO CODE IT
UNTIL- THE MIDDLE OF MAY. I
IMMEDIATELY REOPEN MY CLAIM.
AND I WAS TOLD THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO OPEN A NEW CLAIM
BECAUSE MY OLD CLAIM HAD
EXPIRED. I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT I DID WHAT I WAS TOLD
AND- I RECEIVED A LETTER FROM
BDG SAYING THAT I WITH ELIGIBLE
NOW FOR THE EXTENSION. AND I
COULD CERTIFY FOR BENEFITS. SO
I RECERTIFIED AGAIN. FOR THE
SAME THREE WEEKS. AND I
EVENTUALLY OF RECEIPT THE FINAL
PAYMENT ON JULY TWENTIETH FOR
THOSE THREE WEEKS. HOWEVER I
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO CERTIFY
FOR ANYTHING AFTER JEAN SIX IT
JUST WON'T OPEN THAT
CERTIFICATION WON'T OPEN I SENT
SIX EMAIL EDT TRYING TO CONTACT
THEM BECAUSE THE PHONE NUMBERS
ARE JUST THEY'RE JUST
OVERWHELMED THEY CAN'T HANDLE
IT- MY HUSBAND EVEN SAT ON THE
LINE FOR THREE HOURS IN THE
MORNING ONE TIME FOR ME. BUT I
HE DID FIND OUT- TO CONTACT
SENATOR PANTS OFFICE BECAUSE WE
LIVE IN ELK GROVE. AND FOR
AWHILE MISTER POWERS WAS ABLE
TO- GET SOME KIND OF ANSWER AND
I'M SURE IT WAS HIS HELP THAT
GOT ME MY- BACK PAY.BUT EVEN
HE CAN'T GET DE DE DE NOW AND
I'M STILL SITTING HERE WAITING
FOR ANYTHING WELL FOR TOO MUCH.
IT'S COMING UP TO AUGUST I
DON'T KNOW BY A HAVE A JOB IN
AUGUST BECAUSE I AM A TEACHER-
BUT WHAT THEY CALL AN ADJUNCT
TEACHER SO I'M ON. EMPLOYEE AND
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO-
ARE RETIREMENT IS BARELY
ENOUGH. TO PAY OUR RENT. AND
THAT'S IT- WE STRUGGLE EVERY
WEEK FOR FOOD- FOR MEDICINE.
AND I AGREE WITH THE ONE CALLER
WHO SAID THAT- THE HEAD OF THE
DD SHOULD BE FIRED SHE SHOULD
BE THIS IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE
I REALIZE THAT THIS NUMBER
PEOPLE HAS NEVER BEEN OUT OF
WORK BEFORE. EVEN IN THE GREAT
RECESSION WHICH I ALSO WENT
CARRILLO. BUT THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME I'VE ENCOUNTERED
DIFFICULTIES WITH THE DEFEAT.
SO IT'S NOT THAT SOMETHING THAT
SHE CAN JUST BLAME ON A
PANDEMIC. THEY HAVE
CONSISTENTLY UNDER PERFORMED IN
THEIR JOBS- AND THAT'S IT I'M
SORRY- I DON'T NEED TO TAKE IT
OUT ON YOU GUYS YOU'RE TRYING
TO HELP BUT- BUT YEAH YOU ARE
CORRECT IN THAT SHE DOES NOT
WANT TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU AND HAVE A GOOD DAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
OUR NEXT LINE ALIGNED SEVENTY
NINE. LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME. MY NAME
IS CAROLYN MOSES AND I AM
EMPLOYED BY THE STATE AND THE
LAN AND- UNEMPLOYMENT EMPLOYEE.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE
THE ON LINE AND WE ARE THE
FORGOTTEN THE SENSUAL WORKERS
WE UNDERSTAND THE WORLD
LIFELINE TO STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS WERE UNDERSTAFFED
IN WERE UNDER FUNDED WE SHIP IT
A LOT OF OUR POSITIONS AROUND.
TO HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
WORK FLOW SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE PEOPLE. WE LOST A LARGE
NUMBER OF REALLY GREAT
EMPLOYEES PRIOR TO AND CAN MAKE
DO TOOK A LOT LOW SALARIES IN
THE NON PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT
STATUS. WE SAY THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF A HUNDRED THOUSANDS
TO MILLIONS OF CLAIMS THE POT
LARGEST PROP. PLANE PILING
MULTIPLE CLAIMS WE HAVE. FILING
A NEW CLAIM EVERY WEEK AND WE
HAVE TO COLLECT OLD PLANE
BEFORE THEY. CAN BE PAID AND-
BOB PLANES THAT ARE TO GET
THROUGH. THE CHECK. OUR SYSTEM
IS OVERWHELMED AND BREAK DOWN
THAT CALL DEADLY BUT WE ARE
WORKING HARD FOR THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU PLEASE. NEXT TO
THE LINE SEVENTY EIGHT LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY THERE- MY NAME IS
ON THE WAY WHEN I WORK IN THE
KNOWLEDGE CAPTION DESIGN WITHIN
THE FILM INDUSTRY WHERE WE'RE
GETTING GIGS- AND WATCH ALL THE
ACTION STOP YOU TO GO THAT.
MAJORITY THE JOB THE WORKER TEN
NINETY NINE WITH A FEW. IF YOU
I AM A PROUD EXCEPT WHY WOULD
THERE OF THE ONLY MEN AMOUNT OF
MY EARNINGS ON AVERAGE AND MAKE
BLOCKING THE SEVENTY K. YEAR
WOULD BACK ON THOSE EARNINGS ON
YOU I'M BENEFIT NOT REFLECT
THAT THAT'S ONLY THIRTY A WEEK
ALL BACKED BY TWO GIGS THAT
WERE THE CRIMINAL FIVE DAYS-
THEY'LL POP UNDER HIS. I
UNDERSTAND IS A FEDERAL ISSUE
AND I ARE QUITE. WOULD YOU. YOU
A PRO OR ACT THAT THE OF YOU TO
THE NINETY NINE ZERO AND
COLLECTION BENEFIT IN ADDITION
WE ARE ACT JACK OF THE GIVEN
OUR TROOPS MY THE DATE YOU WORK
A YOU COULD NOT. Q. THIS CALL
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
LINE. FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU'RE
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON AND
OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
BEN HAVING THAT LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA I ALSO IN THE MIXED
INCOME WORKER AND- I TOO HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCING THE- TO
BUCKLE THAT- IS THE ET DE AND
THE UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM GREW UP
THIS COUNTRY AND WHEREAS
CONGRESS IS CURRENTLY TRYING TO
FIX. THE PROBLEM THAT. ARE
CURRENTLY FACING- WITH REGARDS
TO- THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
PAY BASED ON LOW W. TWO INCOME
THAT WERE NOT BEING TO. YOU AT
LEAST STATE THE IS THE OTHER
THING TO SAY THAT IT WON'T BE
RETROACTIVE SO. LOSE ALORS
BASED ON THAT NOW GRANTED IN MY
COULD YOU AND MY OF A LOT OF
OTHERS THERE ARE WE'VE PAID
RIVER BEING PAID LESS THAN WE
ASK SHOULD BEING PAID BUT WE
ARE BEING PAID HOWEVER MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THE
EDT IS AT LEAST TWELVE HUNDRED
TIMES THAT I'VE HAD THE CALL
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PAST
FOUR MONTHS OF THOSE TWELVE
HUNDRED TIMES I'VE ONLY BEEN
ABLE TO ACCESS A REAL LIFE
PERSON TWICE. THE FIRST PERSON
I SPOKE TO AFTER WAITING FOR
SEVENTY MINUTES- I EXPLAINED MY
SITUATION SHE SAID THERE WAS
NOTHING TO BE DONE AT THE CARE
EXACT AND THEN I NEEDED TO ASK
AFTER TO BACKDATE MY CLAIM TO
WHEN I ACTUALLY WAS STARTED BY
WE DID UNTIL PEOPLE TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH WAS WHEN HE WAIT
CAN'T BILLABLE AND I WAS TOLD
BY EIGHT PEOPLE ATTHE ET DE
DURING A SACK AFTER A- WEAPON
ARC TO WAIT UNTIL THE TWENTY
FIFTH SO I DID EVEN I WAS HELLO
BACK IN MARCH. AND UP FOR THE
LATER I RECEIVED A LETTER
SAYING THAT I WAS DISQUALIFIED
P. WAY BECAUSE. OF MY YOU ARE.
AT WHEN I THEN STARTED TRYING
TO CALL AAIN TO GET THE SIX.
NOT ONLY. DID THAT PERSON AT
THE CUSTOMERS ARE IS NEEDED NOT.
SHE WAS SHORT WITH ME SHE WAS
LIKE YOU CAN ANYTHING TO. THE
SHE UP ON WHEN I EVEN BEFORE I
WAS ABLE TO ASK TO BACKDATE MY
CLAIM. SO IT TOOK ME ANOTHER
TWO DAYS OF GETTING IN TOUCH
WITH- OF CALLING AT LEAST TWO
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED TIMES.
BEFORE I WAS ABLE TO SPEAK TO A
REPRESENTATIVE. WHO THEN
INFORMED ME THAT I HAVE
BASICALLY TWO OPTIONS ONE I
COULD EITHER BACK THE- PLANE TO
WHAT I ACTUALLY WAS. FURLOUGHED
WHICH WAS- MARCH SIXTEENTH. BUT
IF I DID. THEN I WOULD HAVE TO
CHANGE MY- FLYING PERIOD AND
THERE WILL BE AN EVEN LOWER.
RATES OF WEEKLY BENEFIT AMOUNT.
FOR YOU WHY OR I COULD DO. TO
GET THE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
DOLLARS THAT I'M RECEIVING
RIGHT NOW WE- AND THEN LOW. THE
FIRST FOUR WEEKS OF MY
UNEMPLOYMENT SO WITH A LOSE
LOSE SITUATION FOR ME EITHER
WAY LOOKED AT IT I WAS GOING TO
BE. AN EFFECTIVE I AM AN ACTOR
THAT HASN'T WORKED IN DOWN THE
W. TO- PAYCHECK. SINCE JULY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT'S BEEN
THREE YEARS ALL OF THIS IS
RESIDUAL INCOME THAT I MADE.
THREE TO FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
WHICH IS THE NINE YOU THE P.
AWAY. AND BECAUSE OF BAD. I NOW
AND GETTING. LESS AND- ALL OF
OUR- BUT HOPEFULLY SOON WITH
CON OF THEY'RE ABLE TO CHANGE
BUT THE EASY DO YOU WORK THEY
NEED TO BE TRAINED WE NEED
TRAINED TO BE CARING EMPATHETIC
CURRENT SITUATION LIKE YOU'RE A
BUNCH OF THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CALLING IN RIGHT NOW SENATOR
UNDERSTAFFED ACOSTA
UNDERSTAFFED. A SLAP IN THE
FACE TO EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIANS HERE THAT HAS.
BEEN THE JUST LEARNED THAT
THERE'S ONLY ONE HUNDRED
SPECIALIST THAT ARE CURRENTLY
MANNING THE PHONES FOR FOUR
HOURS MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY
THAT IS IN STATE. AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE BY THIS POINT IT
WAS A HUNDRED PEOPLE WHICH I
DON'T THINK THERE WAS BACK IN
MARCH AND APRIL. BUT THERE
SHOULD BE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
BY THAT POINT TRAIN FOR THAT
KIND OF SITUATION. SO THAT
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND THE OTHER
ONE TO TWO MILLION. TWENTY THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO GET THROUGH CAN
ACTUALLY GET PRINCE. SPECIALIST
AND MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN TO
THAT. I PERSONALLY ON PEOPLE
GET. MY BACK PAY EVEN THOUGH I
SEE. HEARD FROM MY STATUS.
DURING THE OFFICE. THAT I
ACTUALLY DID QUALIFY TO GET MY
PEOPLE TO. BACK ME CHANGE. ON
JUNE SECOND I RECEIVED THE MAIL
FROM HIS ERRANDS OFFICE SAYING
THAT EVEN. AWARE OF IT. IS JULY
THIRD. THAT HAS HAPPENED. IN.
FIFTY HUNDRED. UNACCEPTABLE THE
YOU SO MUCH FOR TESTING SIR
NEXT CALL PLEASE THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL TO THE LAW. TWENTY
SEVEN. LINE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOU'RE OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME MY NAME IS KELLY YES MA'AM.
RIGHT SO- I'LL I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE THAT THE
COUPLE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY SPOKE ABOUT OUR HYBRID
ISSUE BUT I'M I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT- THE EDT- FIRST OF ALL
IT'S ACTUALLY DEPLORABLE
COMMUNITY IT APPEARS THAT THE
EDT DIRECTOR AT OUR EMPLOYEES
CALLING TO DEFEND THEIR AGENCY
ON THE CALL. I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE TWO SIDES TO EVERY STORY
IMAGE JOURNALIST HOWEVER THE
MEDIA EXPERIENCE THE BEEN
NOTHING BUT ABOMINABLE I'M
TRYING TO GET THROUGH THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE IS TERRIBLE I
WORK IN CUSTOMER SERVICE AND I
HAD BEEN FIRED IF I DEALT WITH
PEOPLE THE WAY THAT THEY DEAL
WITH I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
PANDEMIC AND TO CREATE THIS.
AND THERE'S LOTS OF THE DEAL
BUT. I JUST WANTED. REALLY
APPRECIATIVE THAT BE A FAMILY.
I'VE HAD THESE MEMBERS GOING TO
IT TODAY. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU WERE I HAVE FINALLY
LOOKING INTO ISSUE. MY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO
MY OWN PARTICULAR CASE BECAUSE
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO CALL THAT
BY. MY FAMILY MEMBER TODD
GLORIA WHOSE HOPEFULLY THE NEXT
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
I'M I HAD TO REACH OUT HIS
OFFICE TWICE AND THEIR HANDS.
ACTUALLY I DO AS WELL IT'S
RIDICULOUS YOU BECAUSE THE WAIT
GOT IT. HANDLED FINALLY WHAT
MIND. BEING ON THERE FOR IN
DEPTH AND MAY. SO SOMETHING OUT
BE DONE ABOUT THAT AGENCY I
WOULD NEVER WELL THEY THEY
WOULD CALL FOR SOMEONE TO BE
FAIR BUT IF I DID MY JOB. OR
BELIEVE WHAT I DEFINITELY WOULD
BE FIRED. SO I'M JUST. JUST A
LOT ABOUT THE LAW. THANK YOU
FOR ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THIS
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO SPEAK ON
THE EVERY TO WEEKS. IF YOU
DECIDE TO DO THE- I WILL BE.
CALL EVERY WEEKS. WHEN YOU ARE
WITH. AT THAT EIGHTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THAT'S COLOR PLEASE.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO LAW SO
SIX ONE SEVENTY SO ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT IMAGE. YEAH HOPE
YOU'RE YOU'RE BREAKING UP THE
FIVE ARE WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OH
SORRY. TRY GOING TO THE PHONE.
YEAH IT'S LIKE A CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. THE WORK OF
THE HE HAD LABOR. A HARD TIME
HEARING YOU. RIGHT. BUT NOTHING
THAT RIGHT YEAH GET CAUGHT BY A
LOT OF THINGS. TIMES ONE MAJOR
ISSUE WHICH IS THAT IT REALLY
SEEMS LIKE. HEY GROWING. THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE TO DO NOT WHAT
BOOKS RUN IT COULD. THAT IT'S
JUST THAT YOU BRING THAT. HEY
THIS. NOT AND SO NUMBERS IN THE
BADGER I REALLY DON'T COLLECT
THE REALITY. APPLE IS THAT
PEOPLE JUST GIVE A ON THE-
THOSE THE CALL AND CALL AND
CALL. IF YOU'RE NOT NOTIFIED OF
THE FACT THAT RIGHT. THIRTY SIX
HOURS ABOUT AND WRITE DON'T
WHAT SOLUTION IS NOT PEOPLE.
LIKE THAT VERY OFTEN. LIKE THIS
REALLY ARE START BECAUSE IT IS
ONE WAY THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THE WE TRY NARROW THE DOWN GET
BACK. FIND OUT WHAT THE- IS
BECAUSE WE HAPPENING NOW. I
THINK THAT ABSOLUTELY NEED
ATTENTION. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. NEXT RUN AROUND THE
LINE THIRTY THREE ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU'RE
OKAY. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING MY CALL TODAY ABSOLUTELY
THE FIRST. MY STORY CAN
ACTUALLY BE TOLD TO A BEATING
HEART MY NAME IS CHRIS LEE AWAY
NOW AND I'M A THIRTY FIVE YEAR
OLD WIFE AND MOTHER OF TWO GOOD
STRUGGLING TO STAY AFLOAT
MENTALLY PHYSICALLY AND
MONETARILY. I'D DEPLETED MY
LIFESAVING I DEFAULTED ON MY
BILL AND I JUST APPLY FOR FOOD
STAMPS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MY
LIFE. I FIGHT FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ON APRIL FIFTH. FOUR
MONTHS AGO. IT'S BEEN A HUNDRED
SIXTEEN DAYS BY FILE FOR
BENEFITS. I THANK MY ID
VERIFICATION ON APRIL FIFTEENTH
I HAVE YET TO RECEIVE ANYTHING
ANYTHING BACK WORK ON IT. I
FEEL THIS IS GROSS NEGLIGENCE
AND EXTREME INCOMPETENT ON DVD
BEHALF. I'D LIKE ON CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT WHOSE WORK IN THE
STATE SINCE I WAS SIXTEEN AND
IT NEVER FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BEFORE IT IS HEARTENING TO SEE
HOW MUCH THE BUREAUCRACY OF IT
ALL HAD LET ME. AND SO MANY
OTHERS DOWN. MY HOPE IS THAT IN
THE FUTURE IF YOU DO YOU CAN
ACTUALLY INVEST IN REVAMPING
THEIR SYSTEM FOR FUTURE
APPLICANTS. SO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE MENTAL ANGUISH
THIS IS BECAUSE SO MANY HUMAN.
WE'RE NOT JUST THE NUMBER.
WHERE MOM OR DAD. EMPLOYEE
FRIENDS. PEOPLE HAD JOBS WHO
WORKED HARD THEIR ENTIRE LIFE
AND WE DESERVE TO BE MORE THAN
JUST THE NUMBER TO YOU WE
DESERVE TO BE HEARD. WE DESERVE
TO BE NAME. AND I AGREE WITH
THE CALLER WHO SAID MISS
STEWART SHOULD RESIGN. I SHE
HASN'T BEEN FORTHRIGHT IN
TODAY'S MEETING. AND IF WE
CAN'T TRUST YOUR TO BE HONEST
IN FRONT OF US TODAY. HOW CAN
WE EVER YOUR TO BE HONEST IN
THE FUTURE. LAST WEEK THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO MY ASSEMBLYMAN JIM
PATTERSON. FIRST YEAH NOT AND
EATING OUT ON BEHALF OF THE-
SITUATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE WIND
SEVENTY TWO LINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LIKE WRITING
ABOUT TEN HI I. WORK FOR E. D.
AS WELL I WORK FOR-
ADMINISTRATION BRANCH WE ARE
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO GET THE
PAPER CLAIMS. ANY CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE- DOING THIS. I AND WHAT
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT IS WE
HAVE PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH AN EDP WHO
HAPPENS THERE'S ONLY FIVE THEY
NORMALLY WORK. ON FIXING STOP
IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT THEY
BECOME FULL TIME. EMPLOYEES TO
HELP WITH THE WORK WE ARE DOING
I ALSO HAVE PEOPLE DOWNSTAIRS
IN MY DEPARTMENT GET ALL THE
MAIL TO ALL THE SCANNING
FORMATS WERE NOT ONLY HE BUT HE
AYE- AND THEY ARE OFFICE THIS
IS SPEECH GENERAL. THEY NEED A-
RAISING THEIR TITLES THAT
THREATENS THE OFFICES EXISTENCE
HI THIS OR- ADOPTED TECHNICIAN.
IN MY BUILDING- BSM STARTED IN
OUR BUILDING AND THEY'RE GOING
TO COME BACK TO OUR BUILDING-
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
DONE WITH THEM I'VE BEEN
WATCHING THEM AND EVERYTHING
AND I HOPE EVERYTHING GETS
IMPROVE SOON. AND I HOPE THAT
WE ATE WHO WORK IN THAT
BUILDING WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE WORK THAT THEY DO I ALSO
THINK THAT WE HAVE QUALIFY. IT
TECHNICIANS WHO CAN DO THE WAY
BETTER GOING TO GET HAVE BEEN.
WHY DON'T WE USE OUR I HE TO
KEEP TO WORK THERE WEREN'T WHAT.
THANK YOU. YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NOT GOING AWAY TWENTY
FOUR. ONE TWENTY FOUR GO AHEAD
YOU'RE OPEN. WHITE YOU MUCH OF
MY NAME IS JIM SLADE AND I'M IN
UP DISSED. IT'S JUST STRUCK ME
A REALLY HARD TO DAY LISTENING
TO THIS I'M UP ALL MY WIFE AND
I ARE NOW FILING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT WERNER SIXTIES WE
LOST BOTH OF OUR JOBS. NONE OF
OUR FAULT. AND WORLD RIGHT NOW-
DOBLES. NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED. BUT
JADE- COMMISSIONER HILLIARD OR
WHATEVER HER TITLE IS SHE GAVE
YOU GUYS A LOT OF FALSE
INFORMATION. EIGHT THAT THE
PHONE NUMBER OF EIGHT THREE
THREE THEY DO NOT HELP YOU THEY
CAN'T HELP YOU. THEY'RE NOT
TRAINED TO HELP YOU YOU WE
TALKED TO FIVE OR SIX OF THEM
AFTER ABOUT FOUR FIVE THOUSAND
CALLS. EACH TIME THEY PUT US
OFTEN TELL US WE'RE NOT TRAINED
TO DO THAT WE CAN'T HELP YOU.
AND THEN THEY HANG UP ON THIS.
ALSO I AM ONE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT IS UNDER THE TAX SYSTEM. I
RECEIVED A WELCOME CáC FROM
EDT. AND AFTER BEING FOLLOWING
FOUR TIMES NOW SPUR
CERTIFICATION THEY'VE NEVER
ANSWERED ME BACK. THERE'S NEVER
BEEN ANOTHER TEXT. THERE'S
NOTHING THERE'S THING THERE'S A
PROBLEM. WHEN WE TALK TO THE
PEOPLE AT THE EIGHT THREE THREE
NUMBER THEY SAID PAUL MY WHITE
HAS A PROBLEM AND I HAVE A
PROBLEM. AND IT ONLY CAN BE
HANDLED BY TALKING TO. SOMEONE
AT THE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER.
AND NOW OBVIOUSLY AFTER TODAY'S
TESTIMONY OF ONLY ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE ANSWERING THE PHONE.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN EVER.
SO WE'RE GONNA GO ON AND ON IN
LIMBO. IN OUR SIXTY ABOUT TO
LOSE OUR HOUSE. BECAUSE WE HAVE
NO INCOME. YEAH ALSO IT COULD
OF A STARK. LOOK HERE WHY ARE
ALL THE PEOPLE FROM EDT CALLING
YOU ISN'T THERE A MECHANISM
THAT THEY CAN GET OUT OF OUR
WAY TO CLIENTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY SUFFERING THAT ARE
GETTING PAID IS THERE A WAY
THAT THEY CAN JUST SEND. EMAILS
THAN EVERYWHERE ELSE TO YOU
EVERYWHERE I'VE EVER WORKED IN
MY LIFE WE HAD A WAY TO CONTACT
THE HEAD OF THE COMPANY OR
PEOPLE OR OUR CONGRESSMAN OR
ANYONE ELSE. THROUGH EMAILS OR
TEXT BUT THEY'RE TAKING UP OUR
TIME HERE AND IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE THEY WANT TO JAM UP THE
PHONE. WITH A LOT OF THEIR WELL
WITH ME PROBLEMS WHEN THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TALK TO YOU. SO
BASICALLY THAT'S IT I
APPRECIATE YOUR GUY TIME
ENOUGH. I APPRECIATE THE
PATTERSON AND- MISTER SHOE FROM
UP SEPARATE CISCO I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING HE'S DONE FOR. THE
LITTLE GUY THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NATURAL ONE
FORTY EIGHT AND FORTY EIGHT
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
MY NAME IS JOBS. I AGREE WITH
MOST EVERYBODY THAT THIS HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY HERE ARE
ESPECIALLY THOSE HAVE OBJECTED
TO- DDD EMPLOYEES CALL AND TRY
TO JUSTIFY THE IN THAT PROCESS
THAT THEY HAVE. HAS ON MARCH
THE EIGHTEENTH OF THIS YEAR. I
RECEIVED THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD RULING
BARRING EDT TRYING TO ASSESS
ANY MONIES THAT I WOULD BE
SEEING. I'M BENEFITS. OUR MAY
FOURTH I RECEIVED A BILLING
PROMOTER PAYMENTS. WHICH I
IMMEDIATELY SENT THEM BACK A
LETTER. WE HAVE A COPY OF THE
JUDGING BUT OF THE OF THE ROAD.
BUT BROWN MAY THE TWENTY SEVEN
THROUGH CURRENT THEY'VE TAKEN
MY MONEY EVERY TIME I'VE CALLED.
I DON'T EITHER TOLD THAT
THERE'S TOO MANY CALLS ARE
READY AND I'M HUNG UP ON THREE
OCCASIONS. IN ALL THESE MODS
ARE CONTACTED THREE DIFFERENT
PEOPLE. PINE TOLD ME OH WELL
WE'LL RACES TO THE NEXT LEVEL
AND WITHIN TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY
EIGHT HOURS SOMEBODY WILL
CONTACT YEAH YOU GET A RETURN
CALL. AND I CALLED DAY IN AND
DAY OUT WHEN I SAW THIS ON THE
NEWS IS THIS MORNING I SAID I
NEED TO CALL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. OUR NEXT QUESTION
COMES- COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE OF ONE NINETEEN ONE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS CHECK A PRICE AND I
AM FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE BEEN. DEALING WITH THE
KERN MARKS ONE YEAR WHEN I WAS
LET GO- I WAS PREVIOUSLY LET GO
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR- AND
QUICKLY GOT ANOTHER JOB. AND
THIS TIME AROUND. WHEN I WENT
TO GO BEGIN MY CLAIM I WAS
UNABLE TO LOG INTO MY ACCOUNT.
AND IT TOOK MY FIANCE AND I
CALLING OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
TIMES IN ONE DAY TO FINALLY GET
A HOLD OF SOMEBODY. ONCE WE
WERE ABLE TO GET A HOLD OF
SOMEBODY. WE GOT THE ACCOUNT
COULD YOU ASIAN FIGURED OUT.
SINCE THEN IT HAS BEEN HURDLE
AFTER COLONEL AFTER HURDLE IT
SEEMS LIKE NO MATTER WHAT I DO.
I CAN'T GET A STRAIGHT ANSWER
FROM ANYBODY AND- IT SEEMS LIKE
A QUIRK OF THE DRAW IF YOU CALL
THE EIGHT EIGHT PHONE NUMBER- I
FINALLY. GOT THROUGH TO
SOMEBODY THE LAST TIME I CALLED
TWO WEEKS AGO WHO SEEM TO KNOW
WHAT WHAT SHE WAS DOING
INTERNET NOT THE FIRST TIME I
THAT HAPPENED. BUT I'VE BEEN
LUCKY ENOUGH TO. FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON. THE
FRUSTRATING PART THREE IS THAT
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED I HAVE
ONLY RECEIVED ONE COMMUNICATION
FROM ET DE. CALLING ME THAT MY
CLEAN HAD BEGUN I HAVE NOT
RECEIVED ANY LETTERS ABOUT
NEEDING- IDENTITY VERIFICATION
I NEEDING TO CONTACT APPEAL
BOARD THE ONLY REASON I HAVE
FOUND OUT ANY INFORMATION IS BY
CALLING AND- FINDING OUT FOR
MYSELF. AND THAT HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING THE FACT
THAT THEY CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO
GET OUT A SIMPLE LETTER. IS
JUST RIDICULOUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR. WE DO HAVE ONE CALLER
ACTUALLY ON. ONE PUBLIC SPEAKER
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS POSSIBLY
TO. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR. BUT.
COOL ALL I SEE I DIDN'T SEE
THAT. PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY HI
MY NAME IS GARY CALL EARLIER
I'M A FORMER STATE EMPLOYEE
UNFORTUNATELY I LAUGHED OFF TO
TONY'S BUT MY PROBLEM IS I'M
NOT GETTING ANY UNEMPLOYMENT
AND WALL HOW COME. I GOAL DOES
IMPLY MANAUS UNEMPLOYMENT WELL
WHAT HAPPENS- YOU CAN'T COME IN
THEY SAY NO YOU CAN'T GO TO
SEPARATE STATES OFFICE- NO BUT
FOR THESE PEOPLE SAYING YOU
CAN'T GO TO THE OFFICE ACROSS
THE STREET FROM THE
UNEMPLOYMENT ATV. NO YOU CAN'T
GO IN THERE EITHER BECAUSE THEY
SAY ALL BUT THEIR NON EMPLOYEES
OF THE STATE THEY ARE. SOMEBODY
FOR SECURITY BUT THEY'RE NOT
SECURITY EMPLOYEES OF THE CITY
IT IS DOES IT SACRAMENTO
THEY'RE NOT ANYTHING THEIR NON
STATE EMPLOYEES BUT THEY REFUSE.
ME TO GO TO THE SEPARATE STATE
OFFICE AND ASK FOR MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT SOMETHING
ELSE. WHAT IS GOING ON WITH OUR
STATE WE NEED TO HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION. I LOST MY HOUSE
OVER THIS LAST OF ANY INCOME
FROM HAVING. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
NOTHING NOT ONE PENNY. NOW I
DON'T UNDERSTAND IT I GOT
SOMETHING FROM THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT GREAT. BUT
APPARENTLY THAT DOESN'T RELATE
TO WHAT THE STATE IS DOING.
EIGHTY DE IS RIDICULOUS I'D
LOVE TO. PLEASE PUT YOUR MASK
ON SIR I KNOW ALL BUT DAMMIT I
TOLD YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY
CORONA VIRUS AND I DON'T HAVE
ANY. COPD I HAVE A PROBLEM
DURING THE BREEZY SO PLEASE
WRAP UP SIR OKAY WELL ANYWAY
ALL I WANT TO DO IS I'D LOVE TO
GO BACK TO WORK AND GET MONEY I
LOST MY HOUSE BECAUSE THE CITY
A SACRAMENTO IS SO CORRUPT. BUT
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE STATE
OTHER THAN THEY SHOULD
INVESTIGATE THE STATE THE CITY.
OF SACRAMENTO BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER STORY I'M UNEMPLOYED
EIGHT AND I'M ALSO WITHOUT A
HOME TO LIVE IN THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE IT WHAT WHAT ELSE
DOING THAT AT. THIS SPEAKER
PLEASE WHAT WHAT. WHAT IS THIS
GUY AN EMPLOYEE. WHAT THE HELL.
NINE WHAT. IS WHAT YEAH WE NEED
TO INVESTIGATE THE CITY
SACRAMENTO EIGHT WE ALL HAVE
THE BEST WHY. RIGHT I'M NOT A-
OKAY SO I GUESS I AM AMAZED
SOMETHING. HE. THE CARD WILL BE
THERE FOR REMEMBER. OUR. ALL
RIGHT WELL. HI. I WAS THE FIRST
TIME I'VE EVER SPOKEN BEFORE
GROUP LIKE THIS AND I'M USUALLY
WAIT IS HERE WITH MY OWN
INDIVIDUAL BUSINESS AND TRYING
TO WORRY ABOUT ALL THAT I'M
NORMALLY AND EVERY OTHER YEAR
BASEBALL UMPIRE WILL WE HAVEN'T
HAD A BASEBALL GAME SINCE. THE
SIX THE MARK. NOT A NOT A VERY
GOOD CHANCE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ONE SO THE CHANCE OF ME GOING
BACK TO WORK. EVEN UNTIL NEXT
JANUARY ARE SLIM. I ALSO DRIVE
UBER WHICH BECAUSE OF THE
DEMAND IS WAY DOWN. I FILED FOR
A SELF EMPLOYMENT. UNEMPLOYMENT
CLIMB. AND THAT WAS AFTER THE
PERIOD WHERE THEY WEREN'T GOING
TO LET S AND THEN THEY WERE
GONNA LET US AND THEN THEY WORK
ON A LOT OF AND THEN THEY WERE
GOING TO LET US AND FINALLY YOU
COULD APPLY HERE BUT YOU HAD TO
WAIT UNTIL TUESDAY MORNING I
PUT YOU THROUGH A- TON OF
DIFFERENT GROUPS. WHEN I
FINALLY GOT. APPLICATION WITH
THE NINETEENTH OF MAY. FOR
THOSE OF YOU COUNTING THAT
SEVENTY FOUR DAYS AGO. AT SIXTY
DAYS ARE ALLEGED TO HAVE THE
FIVE WEEKS AGO I GOT MCCARTY IS
OFFICE INVOLVED. AND THEY
STARTED AND THEY DIDN'T TELL ME
THEY HAD HUNDREDS OR TENS OR
HUNDREDS OF CASES BEHIND ME.
AND THEY SAID THEY WOULD MAKE A
WHAT THEY TERM A DAY. HARDSHIP
CASE. I HAVEN'T HAD IN SEVENTY
FOUR DAYS OUTSIDE OF THIS
MORNING. SO MUCH AS A SYLLABLE
OUT OF THE EIGHTY D. I HAVE
SPENT HUNDREDS OF PHONE CALLS
HUNDREDS SOMETIMES HUNDREDS
DURING THE DAY BECAUSE YOU FALL
CALL TEN TIMES AT A TIME. THEY
TELL YOU AT THE END OF THE TAPE.
THAT THEY WERE OVER BURDENED
AND I CANNOT HANDLE YOUR CALL
AND THEY HANG UP ON YOU. IF YOU
GO TO THE OFFICE THE EDT OFFICE
AND I'VE BEEN TO THREE AT
SEVERAL. AT SEVEN IN THE
MORNING. THERE ARE LINES OF
DISGRUNTLED PEOPLE IN FRONT OF
THOSE OFFICES MATTER IN HELL
THAT THE LITTLE ECURITY GUARD
WON'T LET THEM ANYWHERE NEAR
THE BUILDING BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
GET INTO ANY DD OFFICE WITHOUT
A PHONE APPOINTMENT. THE CATCH
TWENTY TWO IS YOU CAN'T GET
THEM ON THE PHONE TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT. NOW IN MY CASE.
THE ACTOR SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A
WEEK FOR SIXTEEN WEEKS COME TO
ABOUT NINETY SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS. AND THE VALUE MY EDT
CLIMB IS EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS IS NOT CHUMP
CHANGE. I AM CURRENTLY
SUFFERING BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO
HAVE A LITTLE MONEY I HAVE SOME
SECOND GAVE THE TRUST THEY
DON'T WANNA LET ME FOR CLOSE.
BUT THOSE PEOPLE ARE. WHERE'S
MY PAYMENT MIKE MY CURRENT THE
OTHER. SIX MONTHS BEHIND RIGHT
NOW. THE NOTE IS DUE IN THE
TWENTY FIFTH OF SEPTEMBER. WELL
VERY UNLIKELY THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO GET ANYTHING TO PAY ARE
THEY STILL GOING TO. KEEP ME
FROM GETTING MY MONEY. I HAVE
SPENT FIVE WEEKS WITH KEVIN
MCCARTY IS OFFICE. ROBIN AND
LAUREN AND I NORMAL BY NAME AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAS
AGREED WITH ME THAT THIS IS
BEYOND THE PALE. THIS IS SO FAR
BEYOND THE PALE. THAT I'M
LOOKING TO PROPERTY OUT OF
STATE I'M A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN.
THIS IS NOT MY STATE ANYMORE.
THEY'RE MORE WORRIED ABUT PAN
PLAYING POLITICS WITH THIS
MONEY. THIS IS KERR'S MONEY
THIS IS MONEY THAT CAME FROM
THE US GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
IS HOLDING IT BACK. THIS MONEY
IS DESIGNED TO GO INTO THE
ECONOMY. I CAN'T SPEND IT
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE IT. I
DON'T HAVE IT BECAUSE HE DID
TELLS ME THAT MY BIRTHDAY IS
NOT MY BIRTHDAY. I'VE SURPRISED
I SUPPLIED. A PASSPORT I
CALIFORNIA REAL ID MY SOCIAL
SECURITY CARD YEAH MY MEDICARE
CARD. AND TODAY THEY HAD THE
AUDACITY AFTER SEVENTY FOUR
DAYS TO TELL ME THAT THERE
WOULD BE FURTHER DELAYS UNTIL I
FAXED THEM WHICH I DON'T KNOW
ANYBODY THAT HAS A FAX MACHINE
ANYMORE FAX THEM A COPY OF MY
UTILITY BILL. NOW WHY THAT HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHO I AM OR
WHAT MY BIRTHDAY IS I HAVE NO
IDEA. BUT LESS THAN TWO HOURS
AGO I GOT A CALL BACK. SAYING
WELL. THEY COULD SEE THEIR WAY
CLEAR TO CHANGE MY BIRTHDAY TO
THE PROPER BIRTHDAY. THE WOMAN
THAT TESTIFIED THIS HARDING
CHARACTER. I THOUGHT I WAS
WATCHING DANCING WITH THE
POLITICAL STARS. SHE DIDN'T
GIVE YOU A STRAIGHT ANSWER OUT
OF ANYTHING. TO TELL YOU FLAT
OUT IN A BOLD FACED LIE. THAT
THEY'RE NOT REFERRING PEOPLE TO
OUR REPRESENTATIVES. SHE SHOULD
BE HELD ON PERJURY CHARGES.
THIS IS BEYOND THE PALE WHAT I
LISTEN TO FOR TWO HOURS HERE AN
OUT OF STATE FOR THE REST OF
HAD TO GRAB GO MOVE MY CAR. BUT
IT JUST BEYOND THE PALE. WHERE
SOMEONE IS SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD
LIVED HIS ENTIRE LIFE HERE THE
ENTIRE CAREER AND SAT IN
CALIFORNIA TO PUT UP WITH THIS
AND BE TOLD THAT MY BIRTHDAY IS
NOT MY BIRTHDAY BECAUSE THEIR
RECORD YOUR BAD EVEN THOUGH FOR
DOCUMENTS. FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
SAYS MY BIRTHDAY'S MY BIRTHDAY.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IT THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU. IT WILL CLOSE
PUBLIC COMMENT- ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR TO. THANK YOU BOB LET ME
FIRST START BY THANKING ALL THE
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC FOR SHARING
YOUR EXPERIENCES AND KNOW THAT
WE ARE HEARING YOUR SAME
EXPERIENCES EVERYDAY IN EVERY
SINGLE OFFICE. TIMES MANY MANY
MANY TIMES FOLD SO THANK YOU
FOR SHARON LET ME- I HAVE A
COUPLE POINTS I'D LIKE TO MAKE
AROUND CUSTOMER SERVICE AND A
FEW QUESTIONS TO- DIRECTOR
HILLIARD ABOUT TECHNOLOGY. I
WAS ASTONISHED WHEN THE
DIRECTOR RESPONDED TO MISTER
LACKEYS PRIOR QUESTION AROUND
HANG UPS AND SAYING SHE HAD NOT
HEARD ABOUT IT BECAUSE YOU
HEARD SO MANY INDIVIDUALS TODAY
TALK ABOUT IT. AND IT IS SO
CLEAR THAT THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
WHAT CERTAIN STAFF MAYBE DOING
AND WE KNOW THERE A LOT OF
STAFF THAT ARE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING. BUT HERE NOT HANG
UPS EVERY DAY THE WEEK AND IN.
CENTER OPERATIONS YOU HAVE
PLANE TICKET NUMBERS OR- AS WE
ARE HERE WHEN WE CALL THESE
CALL CENTERS QUOTE THIS CALL
MAYBE RECORDED FOR QUALITY
ASSURE. I WANT TO. THANK FOR.
LOOK INTO THAT BECAUSE- THE BTD
HAS TROUBLE IT WILL FULLY BLIND
I TO THIS. SECOND ONE SAYS TO
RUN. THE FACT THAT ET DE HAS
FORCED TO CALL HUNDREDS OF
TIMES WITHOUT BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH AND I CAN'T BELIEVE IT
IT'SUNFATHOMABLE FRUSTRATING.
WHEN MOST PEOPLE CALL CUSTOMER
SERVICE WITH OTHER TYPICAL CALL
CENTERS THERE'S GENERALLY
FEATURE THAT ALLOWS FOR
AUTOMATIC CALLBACKS IT'LL CALL
US BACK IN HALF AN HOUR SIX
HOURS AGAIN WE WANT TO HAS TO
STRIKE FORCE TO LOOK INTO
BASIC. CALLBACK TECHNOLOGIES
FOR THE DELOITTE COMIC CENTER
THIRD THING I WANT TO ASK- WE
HEARD THAT- THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS A DASHBOARD WE WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
DASHBOARD AND HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT DASHBOARD. TO WITH A
SENSE- IF I COULD JUST RECTOR
HILLIARD. HOW MANY CALLS WERE
RECEIVED BY HOW MANY UNIQUE
CALLERS THIS PAST MONTH. IT'S
DR HOWARD ONLINE. YES I'M HERE-
WHAT I REALLY ATTRACTED BY
WEEKLY IS TO- AROUND- BETWEEN
500-100-0600 THOUSAND EVERY
WEEK. FIVE DOLLARS HE CALLS AND
HOW MANY HOLES WERE MADE DURING
THAT TIME PERIOD. THREE PRIVACY
ALLOWED MILLION A WEEK SEOUL
LEVIN MILLION CALLS A WEEK AND
ONLY FIVE TO SIX HUNDRED UNIQUE
COLORS ABLE TO GET THROUGH THAT
IS ASTONISHING WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THE SITUATION I HOPE
AND BELIEVE THAT AUTOMATIC CALL
BACKS OR THINKING OF HOW TO GET
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND HANG
UPS AS A WAY. TO DO THAT- I
KNOW OUR- MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
HAD ASKED A COUPLE QUESTIONS
AROUND THE BERRIES CALL CENTERS
AND- UP. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE VERY
VERY FOCUSED IN FACT THAT ONE
CALL CENTERS WHERE YOU CAN.
ADDRESS CLAIMS IS ONLY OPEN
FOUR HOURS A DAY. YOU HAVE THE
OTHER CALL CENTER THE DELIGHT
CALL CENTER MY UNDERSTANDING IS
STAFFER PAID FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR. TO ANSWER GENERAL
QUESTIONS THE STAFF CAN ONLY
ANSWER BASIC QUESTIONS AND MAKE
VERY MINE. TECHNICAL MINISTRY
CHANGES TO ACCESS YOU ACCOUNT
AND IF I DO THE MATH. FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR TIMES
FORTY HOURS A WEEK TIMES FIFTY
WEEKS A YEAR IF THAT'S HOW
PLAYS OUT. UNDER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PERSON. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
ME THAT PER LANE GENERAL
INFORMATION THAT'S ALREADY IN A
WEBSITE IS WORTH THAT. AND
WE'VE A LOT OF QUESTIONS ON
WHETHER. THAT AGREEMENT WITH
THE LIGHT IS REALLY WORKING FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
WANTED I'M JUST CURIOUS IF
THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSION OF HOW
SHIP THOSE PERSONNEL. FROM
ANSWERING GENERAL QUESTIONS TO
ACTUALLY ANSWERING QUESTIONS
AROUND SPECIFIC CLAIMS. YES WE
HAVE BEEN KILLING BOTH OF THE
LAWYERS AND THE ETV STAFF OR
THE COMBINATION OF PEOPLE ARE
ON THAT LINE- WE PROVIDE
ONGOING TRAINING AND THEIR LATE
WE HAVE ENHANCED HER ACCESS TO
DRAFT THE SEPTIC. CLAIM ISSUES-
SO I MEAN THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
DOING THAT THE MOST DEFINITELY.
OKAY BUT WE STILL HAVE FOLKS
FOR BEING PAID AT THAT EVEL
TO- ON THE ON THE GENERAL LINE.
THE GENERAL LINE IS THAT I MEAN%
IT PROVIDES A WHOLE ARRAY OF
SERVICES IT'S- ADVOCATE AND IT
DOES GET INTO CLAIMS SPECIFICS
FOR DIFFERENT PEOPLE THE CAL. I
THINK YOU'RE ACTUALLY LYING TO
US AGAIN BECAUSE THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT THE EXPERIENCE OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS NOR IS THAT
ACTUALLY WHAT IT EVEN SAYS I
THINK ON YOUR WEBSITE SO- AGAIN
NOT TO BELABOR THE POINT BUT
IT'S SUPER FRUSTRATING THAT
THIS IS HARD TO. TO WORK
THROUGH LET ME UP I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AROUND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN DDT AND
DELIGHT SO YOU'RE VERY WELL
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT. WHEN
EDT SYSTEMS FELL TEN YEARS AGO
ET HIGHER DELIGHT FOR YOUR
PROJECT THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
COST FORTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS THAT PROJECT MASSIVELY
FAILED CREATED MASSIVE DELAYS
IN PAIN UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS
ACCORDING TO A CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY INSURANCE COMMITTEE
REPORT FROM TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THAT CONTRACT WENT
FROM A FOUR YEAR FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR CONTRACT. TO
ASSIST HERE NINETY FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR CONTRACT AND STATE
AUDITOR'S AND OTHERS HAVE FOUND
MASSIVE MISREPRESENTATIONS OF
PROGRESS ON ACCEPTABLE LEVELS
OF DEFECT INVOLVING THAT
RELATIONSHIP NOW. I UNDERSTAND
LLOYD CONTINUES TO BE A VENDOR
OF YOURS OUR OFFICES ACTUALLY
MET WITH THE LIGHT A FEW TIMES
THE RESPONSES WE HEAR FROM
THEM. IS THEY CLAIMED RESPONSE
OR- TAKEN. WITH HER ONE DAY
SYSTEMS. THEY SAY THEY ARE NOT
AT FAULT FOR ITS HAPPENING THEY
DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO FIX
THINGS. GIVEN HOW MUCH YOU PAY
THEM. I WANT TO ASK YOU. WHAT
DO YOU THINK THEY ACTUALLY DO.
COUPLE YES OR NO QUESTIONS SO
DELIGHT BUILT AND MAINTAINS THE
YOU WHY ON MY PORTAL SYSTEM
RIGHT. AB THEY MAINTAIN THAT WE
IS LLOYD SERVICES TO IT THAT.
RIGHT YEAH OKAY AND I KNOW ET
DE SUPPOSE IT OWNS THE DATA BUT
IF YOU DID A NEEDS TO RUN DATA
QUERIES AND PULL DATA FROM THE
U. I. ONLINE PORTAL DELIGHT
STAFF HAS TO HELP YOU RUN THAT
DID IT RIGHT. YEAH OKAY AND- IF
YOU DE IS BUILDING A NEW
FEATURE INTO ITS ONLINE PORTAL
OR SOME OTHER ASPECT TO THE
WEBSITE AT THIS TIME. THE
LIGHTS INVOLVED IN THAT RIGHT.
YES THEY ARE AND COMMUNICATIONS
FROM THE U. I. ONLINE PORTAL TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS. ARE MANAGE
AND HAS WORKED ON THAT WITH
DELIGHT RIGHT. YEAH AND DELIGHT
HOLSTERED MINISTER IN AUTOMATIC
COMMUNICATIONS THAT APPLICANTS
RECEIVED FROM THE U. I. ONLINE
PORTAL RIGHT. THEY'RE NOT IN
CHARGE OF IT THEY DO IT IN JOE
AND PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR AYE HE
STAFF IN OUR PROGRAM STAFF AS
A- AS A- IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ADDRESSING ALL ASPECTS OF
THE- ANY PROJECT THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON. YEAH WELL YOU KNOW
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE ALL OF THE
ANSWERS THAT YOU JUST PROVIDED
TO ME. ARE CONTRADICTORY TO
WHAT THE LORD HAS TOLD US.
SODALITE IS TELLING US THAT
ANYTHING THAT'S BROKEN IS YOUR
FULL. AND THEY'VE ABDICATED
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THEY HAVE
GIVEN US ANSWERS WHICH ARE
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE
HAVE JUST. WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU
NOT JUST DISCUSSED AND YOU KEEP
SIGNING NEW CONTRACTS WITH THE
LIGHT FACT THIS YEAR YOU
ENTERED INTO I THINK A SECOND
NO BID CONTRACT. WITH THE WHITE.
A LOT OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
AS WELL AS FROM THE MEDIA
WHO'VE BEEN ASKING WHY DO WE
KEEP ENTERING. INTO NO BIG
CONTRACTS WITH SOMEONE. THAT
HAS SUCH A LONG HISTORY OF COST
OVERRUNS AND PROBLEMATIC I. T.
WORK. MALES ONE FINAL QUESTION
TO YOU YOU KNOW HOW MUCH THE
STATE HAS SPENT WITH THE
LAWYER. OR LEAST EDS SPENT WITH
THE LIGHT IN RECENT YEARS. YES
I'M AWARE HOW MUCH. THE REASON
YEAR HERE- LET'S LET'S SAY
SINCE THE FAILURES IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN SO- YOU KNOW FOR
THE LAST TEN YEARS THE
RELATIONSHIP YOU'VE HAD WITH
THIS COMPANY. IT HERE I EITHER
HAVE A DOWN BROKEN DOWN TWENTY
ONE MILLION FOR CALL CENTER
SUPPORT FIVE MILLION FOR THE
PORT IN ANOTHER TWO POINT SEVEN
FOR THE SUPPORT. LET ME TELL
YOU THAT EDT HAS SPENT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS ON TO LLOYD. TO A LATER
GOING BACK. FOR THE VERY FIRST
CONTRACT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN THERE IS A- CONTRACTOR
NINETY ONE MILLION OUT WITHIN
THEIR PARTIAL MODERNIZATION OF
THE PROJECT. YOU KNOW AGAIN.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE THE YOU MAY
NOT HAVE THE STATISTICS ON THE
CONTRACTS IN FRONT OF YOU BUT I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT EDT HAS
SPENT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS WITH THIS
VENDOR WHO HAS ALSO FELL
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S A LOT OF YOU
WHY CHECKS AND BECAUSE OF THE
COLLECTIVE FAILURE OF EDT
ANDROID. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THERE SO- I WANT HAS TO STRIKE
FORCE IF YOU CAN LOOK INTO THAT
WORK. AND HELP EVALUATE IT LET
ME JUST END WITH ONE FINAL
THING THAT I WANT TO READ.
SUMMARY THIS US FROM A FROM A-
COMMITTEE HEARING OUT THE
PROBLEMS. UNDERSCORE THE
ABILITY DE SYSTEMS TO HANDLE
THE DEMAND OF CURRENT
UNEMPLOYMENT. AS THE STATE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY. EDT REPORTED
MILLIONS OF ATTEMPTS MADE PER
MONTH TO REACH EIGHTY
TELEPHONICALLY. YOU WHY
COMPLAIN OF A CLAIMANT'S FOUND
HUMAN CONTACT WAS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE. EDT CHOSE NOT TO
STAFF THERE CENTERS WITH ANYONE
WHO COULD PERSONALLY ASSIST.
THERE YOU AYE QUESTIONS A
GROWING NUMBER OF UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS KEEP RE DIALING EDT. TO
NO AVAIL. I ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF YOU COULD GAS WHEN THIS WAS
WRITTEN. TWO THOUSAND TEN.
WRITTEN IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE
ARE EXPERIENCING GROUNDHOG DAY.
THIS AGENCY MISS HILLIARD YOU
KNOW THAT YOUR AGENCY. HAS
EXPERIENCE WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. BEFORE
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS
BEFORE YOU'VE BEEN PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP FOR YEARS AND YET WE
ARE HERE EDT CONTINUES TO FILL
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS WHY WE
ARE SO INCREDIBLY DISAPPOINTED
AT HOW LITTLE PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE AND AGAIN IF I COULD ASK
THE CHAIR I DO HOPE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE CONVENIENT
AGAIN I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING WHAT PROGRESS EDT HAS
MADE ALL THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE RAISED. THANK YOU MISTER
TO. IN A QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SO MISSILE YOU
MIGHT WHAT MY FINAL QUESTION
FOR YOU IS THAT YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT STAFFING EIGHTY D.
IS THAT CORRECT. YEAH WE- WE DO
NOT- WE HAVE THE BUDGET TO
STAFF AND WE CONTINUE TO HIRE
TO ENSURE WE GET TO THE LEVEL%
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS IN A MANNER THAT WERE
ALL PRODUCTS. IN THE PAST AND
YOU PUT IN SUFFICIENT BCP'S.
ASKING FOR STAFFING OR MONEY
THEY HAVE BEEN TURNED DOWN NOT
NOT THOSE ARE GOOD FEATHER WITH
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND. WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY TURN DOWN FOR
THE MOST PART AND THE FUNDING
TO WE'VE GOT FOR THIS CRISIS IS
COME IN ADDITION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS ECURE ENCRYPTION IS
ISSUES AND NOT REALLY WORK FOR
THE TASK FORCE- SO- MISSILE YOU
KNOW WHAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING- THIS
COMMITTEE WAS TO WORK WITH YOU
BUT- HAVING BEEN HERE. FOR SIX
YEARS NOW MISTER CHIU WITH MR
SHOWS COMMITTEE IT'S
FRUSTRATING SOMETIMES WHEN YOU
KNOW EVERY YEAR PEOPLE COME
BACK FOR UPGRADES FOR MORE-
MONEY FOR COMPUTER SYSTEMS. AND
YOUR LAST AGENCY USING COBALT.
IN THE STATE IS THAT. THAT'S
JUST THAT'S JUST AS MR
OBERNOLTE HE'S- AS THAT REASON.
GRADUATE FROM MIT I BELIEVE.
CELTIC OF IT'S JUST FRUSTRATING
YOUR AFTER YOUR FOLKS COMING
BACK. IN THIS IS LAGGED FOR SO
LONG SO WE WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU ON BE PARTNERS WITH YOU BUT
ULTIMATELY- YOUR DEPARTMENT
HEAD AND REPORT TO SOMEBODY
ELSE- SO- JAVA LEGISLATURE'S
LEGISLATE. WE'RE NOT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH BUT WORK LOCAL
EQUAL- SO. WE'RE GONNA WRAP
THIS UP I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR CALLING IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE BEING AIR
OF THE FOLKS FOR COMING IN
CALLING IN. VOICING THEIR
CONCERNS IT IN THIS WEIRD I
HOPE YOU TAKE TO HEART THE
COMMENT YOU HEARD FROM THOSE
CALLERS- WE HEAR IT DAY IN AND
DAY OUT FROM OUR DISTRICT
STAFF. AND POSSIBLE COLORS AT
THEIR WIT'S END IT IT'S SAD IN
THERE ARE HANG UP MY STAFF HAS
TOLD ME THEY'VE HEARD IT.
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
TIMES WERE FULL TO BIG HUNG UP
AT SO THE ONE THING. BOTHERS ME
IS THAT FREEBIE THE DIRECTOR
SAID YOU'RE NOT AWARE OF IT.
THAT'S NOT OKAY LIKE I GOT A-
CALL. YOU KNOW I GOT A CALL A
SPADE A SPADE. IT'S HAPPENING.
EVERY DAY WE'RE TELLING YOU
THIS. THE FULL SET COLIN DID
MAKE THIS STUFF UP YOU CAN'T
MAKE IT UP. WE'VE GOT TO DO
BETTER. WE CAN DO BETTER FOR
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA- SO
THEY FOR BELIEVING OF ALL WE
APPRECIATE IT. THANKS TO STAFF
ESPECIALLY CHRISTIAN. AND
GENEVIEVE AND ROLL A FOR THEIR
HARD WORK APPRECIATED. THAT
CONCLUDES THIS HEARING THANK
YOU.